[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
s
for this cozy coastal town the holiday
season isn't over
in fact the most wonderful time of the
year has really just begun and Checkmate
abdusitara played a brilliant game he is
a monster
once again vikon Zay starts the new year
as the center of the chess Universe this
year as host of the 85th Tata steel
chess tournament
a magnet for the best players in the
game some recognize the Masters field of
2023 as its strongest in recent memory
of course it helps when eight-time Tata
steel chess champion Magnus Carlson is
back Magnus is a beast doesn't give up
we know the kind of comebacks that he's
capable of in the position
the world's number one looks to further
cement his legacy in this event and the
game's history
chasing Magnus will be amongst the best
in chess several have been crowned
Champion here before some have even
shocked the world in doing so
don't leave out those poised to capture
their first Tata title Anish is taking
down the world champion Magnus in
absolute shock
although winter Tata steel chess is also
known as the place new stars come to
bloom Magnus one here is a teenager this
year's event has its fair share of young
players on the rise each hoping to
follow in Carlson's footsteps a huge win
for prognananda against dingley wren
the Dutch refer to Tata steel as The
Wimbledon of chess for 85 years in
running this tournament continues to be
steeped in Prestige and Legacy and does
so again in this welcoming Little Dutch
town by the sea
mind Brendan it's the 85th edition of
the Tata steel chess tournament and it
starts right now
foreign
ladies and gentlemen to the 85th Tata
steel chess tournament coming to you
from Amsterdam the capital of the
Netherlands it is the fifth round of
Tata steel so we are currently in the
Johann Cruyff football arena which which
will be a special one-day venue for the
event I'm Grand Master Daniel nariditsky
alongside me today International master
yovanka fuska yovi I'm a big fan of your
commentary it's a pleasure and honor to
be doing this with you good afternoon
good afternoon and the feeling is mutual
and boy have we been spoiled for chess
so far I mean it's been such an amazing
tournament each round has featured so
many electric games and the day before
yesterday we had three decisive results
and even the draws were incredibly
exciting you can see their prognananda
with really the game of the day Yobe
correct me if I'm wrong all he really
did was defeating dingley run with what
it's not that the world champion lost a
game as well so you know yeah I'm just
gonna say yeah I know there was a close
call actually I mean what a spectacular
day of Chess and I have to say pregnant
with the black pieces and in such a
positional style was wow absolutely
wonderful and then of course and of
course a niche oh my God he is getting
better and better he seems to be
leveling up and making it all look so
easy
yeah and uh yeah Niche with the win
against the world champion and that
propels him to the top of the tournament
standings alongside with Notre back
abdusitar of both of them sitting pretty
on three points out of four man
anishkiri he has just been electric he
is confident and he is atop this
tournament after four rounds and
speaking of Anish giri he offered us his
own Insight uh in a very entertaining
interview after his win against Magnus
Carlson let's listen in
but it was in the bag uh after first
time after he allowed me bcbc because I
think I thought it was actually dead
lost and then I blundered 96 and then
the second time I thought after 85
Bishop 5 Rook C8
I mean I thought okay it's very
convertible
um even for me but you know still
possible like I was almost blunder at
one point I thought he has no moves I've
almost played King G2 then there's 93
check Cheapo so there's like but then
when I saw that I was like oh yeah that
that's that blunder it I should avoid so
that was good actually I was sort of
just thinking that uh the odds of me
messing this one up are higher than
usual that made me feel relieved because
uh I didn't put much pressure on myself
I thought like okay you know
very likely I'll mess this one up
somehow I don't really see how maybe it
will happen uh I didn't feel the usual
Magnus effect because um I felt like he
was missing stuff
um and he was making moves that I
thought were weaker than the moves I
expected and um that gave me confidence
but in terms of like uh yeah I think
it's a sort of a historic moment I've
beaten him once but everybody knows it
was a little bit lame he blundered
something
and I was so small it was a different
person back then so yeah I really and
it's always a kind of a weird story
because I always tell my story in order
so I beat him at 16 and I've never
beaten I never beaten him ever since and
that's always a weird like and I was
thinking something I think like I have
to beat him at some point right we're
not going to wait till like we're both
50 and we played this match like team on
carpal for playing you know like uh so I
thought like okay so I'm really happy
that I won because now you know yeah I
was was a fair and square
I don't know why but that interview just
makes me smile there's something
wholesome about it and listen historic
is not an exaggeration if I beat the
world champion it would be a glass of
wine there would be a nice dinner at a
French restaurant but anishikiri cannot
rest on his Laurels Yogi Kenny
no he absolutely can't because today he
still has a tough opponent to face and
he'll be facing pradmananda and of
course there are many other exciting
matchups
there are indeed we're going to take you
through those matchups one by one first
of all Magnus he needs to bring the heat
fighting Notre back Anish giri's
co-leader of the tournament you don't
say this often but Magnus is coming off
a loss he's gonna be mad and he's gonna
have the white pieces so we can expect
Magnus to take some risks
yeah and I remember the last time that
Magnus played Nordic back with the white
pieces in the world rapid championships
Magnus bought well he played in the most
spectacular way ever I mean I know he
just learned from the Legends himself a
fantastic game just check it out if you
can
yeah I mean this is just such an amazing
match a matchup of the generations and
they've also never played in classical
before that's really weird to say
because you think that's impossible but
we actually have a couple of these
matchups given this very eclectic roster
we have in this year's Tata steel one
matchup that we have had many times is
the All-American matchup between Fabiano
caruana who takes on Wesley so now yovi
Wesley he has drawn all of his games but
that can change at the drop of a hat
yeah absolutely I've always likened
Wesley's style to that of a bear if you
you know it looks quite tame but if you
provoke it well he comes at you and the
thing I've noticed about these two is
that yes they do play a lot of drawers
but they do have a lot of fireworks
along the way
they do indeed and of course Wesley
coming out with an E4 course he is armed
to the teeth with both white and black
as is Fabiana carwana so I really think
that matchup is going to give us
something very interesting uh in the
opening
speaking of the opening gukeshigan's
report I mean two incredibly exciting
players who are languishing in the
bottom of the tournament standings Yogi
but I mean it's just it's just been four
rounds so it's weird to talk about last
place or first place because we know how
quickly things can change especially
when we talk about rapport
yeah exactly I mean both these players
are kind of bit streaky I feel that when
they're doing well they're really going
to start motoring and like you say it is
only around four soon you know it's
going to be the middle of the tournament
and these players need to catch up so
they really need to start racking up
some points and the same goes for
Maxwell and Jordan van Ferris these are
some of the most creative players and I
for one can't wait to see what Jordan is
gonna bring to the table when it comes
to opening surprises
yeah and Jordan never really
accomplished anything in the Tata steel
he only won the tournament uh during its
lockdown phase three years ago he
defeated actually Anish giri in uh the
rapid playoffs to win the title steal so
Jordan he's really really well prepared
he doesn't have all that much to lose
he's sort of an underdog and those
players can be really really dangerous
because they have a chip on their
shoulder and they're trying to prove
themselves worthy of playing the top
guys so definitely an exciting matchup
as is of course Prague against Anish
Prague coming off a win against England
he is confident and he is incredibly
dangerous the battle of the kingslayers
yogi
yeah you said it Frank of course taking
down Ding and he's taking down Magnus I
mean this is going to be such an
exciting game I mean both players are
well prepared both players are riding
high it's gonna be a fight
it is indeed and our final two matchups
are gonna be Arjun era geisey against
England Arjun has also drawn all of his
games he's been very very solid and
finally we have of honoronian against
Vincent kymer they've had some
absolutely crazy games yovi you pointed
out in 2022 they had a wild Affair so
we're likely to see something exciting
yeah something about those Styles but of
course the headline game is gonna be
Magnus Carlsen against Nordic abdusa
tarov and uh there we can see in order
back waiting for Magnus to arrive
magnum's not yet at the board I mean
always late he likes to be fashionably
like he likes those two minutes well he
has two minutes because the time
controller is so generous the format
it's a 13 round event it's a long
tournament with all players receiving an
invitation the winner earns a point a
draw gets you half a point as is
standard and the player with the most
points after 13 Rounds wins the Tata
steel Masters if there is a tie then
there is a set of Rapid games that break
the tie but it will cross that bridge if
we get there there's a lot of bridges to
cross in terms of the time control first
you have a hundred minutes for 40 moves
then 50 minutes for the next 20 moves
and then another 15 minutes after move
60 is made and of course we have the
standard 30 second increment after every
move you know it's a generous time
control this allows for some of the
highest level chess that we see each
year and that is why people left how to
steal
yeah absolutely and in terms of chess
games this is a marathon this is uh in
competition in endurance and like you
say you know it does allow the players
to play such great quality chess
especially in the later stages of the
game and there we can see Wesley so and
Fabiana carono with his new hairstyle
getting ready and Magnus has made an
appearance at the board and both players
getting ready and we can see that
Norberg seems to me slightly nervous
yeah he was kind of smiling uneasily
there I mean black against the world
champion is going to do that too
[Laughter]
what are your predictions for this game
do you think Magnus will open with E4
and uh take on naughty back Sicilian or
will it be a seafood will we see even
crazy moves from the world champion I
mean we have seen him also open up with
B3
yeah I mean it really for with Magnus it
depends on how he feels and he can play
absolutely anything if he wants a
theoretical battle we're going to see E4
maybe he doesn't want a theoretical
battle maybe he just wants a deep breath
after losing to giri and you called it
one C4 is the first move of round five
of Tata steel executed by Magnus Carlson
here we go seat belts fastened
yep and uh kind of expecting in order
back to play E5 he's done that before
and I think the very first time that
they played each other in 2020 oh no we
have a symmetrical English copycats
indeed C4 C5 the first moves of this
game and the symmetrical English has a
fantastic reputation I mean it is
alongside one E5 uh the frequent choice
of Highly theoretical players and the
ball back and Magnus to scored he is
really the one who has to choose a setup
here
yeah absolutely and I find that in this
in these some magical englishes that the
game kind of takes on a maneuvering uh
phase I mean both players will just
develop the knights out get their pieces
onto good squares and then just wait for
the actions to start brewing either in
the center or quite commonly on the
wings and uh there you can see the
nights just developing
yeah Knight F3 Knight F6 and what I said
about Magnus being in control of the
setup isn't entirely accurate he's
played Knight C3 now Knight C6 is not
obligatory black has a couple of
Alternatives there's the move E6 there's
the early Queen side fiancado of course
you can also play them with G6 but
that's often frowned upon at the top
level because it actually allows white
to transpose the game into an
accelerated Dragon a morosi bind system
not to notorbeck's liking as he does
indeed bring the fourth Knight out to C6
riveting position thus far
so what is your prediction for how long
they will copy each other
I mean how many how many moves will they
go well I guess if I just plays D4 then
something tells me Notre back won't go
D5 if Magnus goes E3 I think they're
gonna keep it going E3 E6 D4 T5 you
could go for another four or five moves
here potentially
yeah I was also thinking about if you're
chattering keep it going for it all the
way
system as long as possible here Magnus
actually taking a little bit of time
here did he decide on a system before
the game maybe he actually didn't expect
notorbeck to play uh the symmetrical
English but finally chooses the move E3
and we're gonna keep following this game
and update you on whether noderbeck
continues to copy the world champion not
a bad strategy but for the first time
today let's go back to our beautiful
bird's eye view Yogi my favorite view as
we see all of the positions as they
currently stand
yeah and uh let's uh have a walk in the
park and let's take a look at whether
anyone has launched any opening
surprises
or
have a well there's fireworks on the
board um can we take a look at uh
magsudu again
I was so hoping you would say that let's
go
what do we have here a crazy position
after only seven moves you called it I
mean sometimes you just hear about a
matchup and you just know that they're
gonna bring their opening a game to the
table what do you make of this chaos
that's on the board after White's
seventh move well first of all I'd like
to rewind and see how we got to this
position because uh my impression of
Parham is basically that he likes his
schemes you know he tends to live on the
third row as I call it develop his
pieces and uh here we see a departure
from that style and I was really curious
as to see how Jordan was gonna shake him
up and uh here we see
well yeah this is immediately this is a
standard line of the Queen's Gambit
accepted where it gets off the rails
here is after Knight F6 white takes on
E5 now black does not take on e4 which
seems quite tempting I can't exactly
tell you why instead he clings to the C4
Pawn with B5 and I suppose the reason
you don't take on e4 probably has to do
just with Bishop takes C4 attacking F7
and white is quickly able to shelter his
King uh keeping very strong pressure on
F7 so black trying to keep White's light
squared Bishop at Bay now of course
white has to defend E4 so the moves make
sense yovi but as a result we've got a
wild position A3 and then A4 is White's
last move Geez Louise
yeah I know it wasn't what I expected I
mean I could kind of predict up to a
certain point but that I would not have
thought about this last move because my
focus would have been simply in
developing the pieces in primarily the
king or perhaps trying to establish a
pin but uh wow I mean
A4
I'm still digesting this I think well
the Tactical point is that if the move
B4 which is very tempting runs into 95
takes C4 and the bishop on A5 is hanging
that's actually why he played A3 first
to provoke the bishop onto a vulnerable
square and if black can't play before
well black does have the move C6 but
that Queen side it does not look stable
yovian after C6 maybe white can take
once on B5 and it's got a pretty
imposing Center a nice Knight on E5 the
eval bar seems to approve of Mike
sudlu's early opening experiment
yeah uh unexpected but very good I mean
the only problem that I would see with
white is uh of course would be the king
safety I mean White's King is still two
moves away from this from getting to
Castle to castling and uh you know like
does have the opportunity to chip away
at the center and wow Jordan is
accelerating the play I mean talk about
fighting fire with fire uh unexpected
stuff there I mean we thought he would
just support the pawn but no
yeah normal support the pawn moves nah
that's not in his vocabulary C7 C5 and
every time we think the game's about to
calm down it somehow just becomes more
chaotic so what does this move
accomplish well it obviously attacks the
D4 Pawn Barham has to respond to that
and the way I see it he's got two
candidate moves there's the move D5 and
there's the move D takes C5 just
grabbing the pawn and saying what you
got ask for which of those I would
prefer D take C5 actually looks really
good to me ovian maybe I'm missing
something but if black now plays Queen
C7 looks like a very strong Fork White
has this incredibly nasty move Queen to
D6 and if you trade Queens you've
stumbled yourself into a probably losing
end game at this point
yeah and you still have to deal with the
pressure on B5 as well so I agree with
you um like cannot trade Queens
um
yeah
that looks convincing so I mean my first
thought was Queen C70 are there any
other moves for instance I would just be
I would perhaps forget about the pawn
and C5 try to claim that it's kind of
dead wood and instead focus on
developing this pieces I'm thinking
Bishop takes uh sorry Bishop E6
yeah I mean you kind of have to get your
pieces out ASAP that's the only way you
earn compensation but I'm going to keep
gobbling Bishop E6 I'll take on B5 maybe
B4 is possible now but the problem again
is that white takes on d8 again Rook
takes d8 there's Knight takes C4 and
let's not talk about Bishop takes the at
this this looks Mighty ugly White's
gonna win C4 and Knight T5 isn't even
the best move probably Knight B5 is even
better let tell you what Yogi this could
be early major trouble for Jordan if
maxulu takes this Pawn on C5
yeah I remember how natural is it to
take that pawn because my vibe was you
know I'm a pawn Pusher I'm gonna push
the D5 pawn and grab that space I mean
how is that
yeah D5 D5 makes sense I mean white
drives the wedge into the center I think
the one major counter argument against
D5 is that black can now play B4 because
one of the byproducts of Black's last
move is that it's connected the queen
and the bishop which means it's taking
this thing out of Knight takes C4 so
unfortunately for Jordan I I just don't
see Parham declining that pawn
yeah okay well I'm already in control
and uh
it's just such a wild position you kind
of almost feel like you should deep dive
into it but of course we should carry on
our walk in the park because there is
action on the board on this game but is
there action anywhere else
most of the other games
yeah I mean most of the other games have
relatively standard positions let's go
to Colorado Wesley if that's uh okay
with you Yogi as we look at the bird's
eye view one more time I mean we've got
a lot of Rich openings here we've got a
grunfeld on the right side of your
screen between gookash and report is
there anything else that's that's cash
in your eye or should we go to the
All-American matchup
and let's go to the All-American matchup
and because that one looks to me like
it's a scotch and I was not predicting
that I was expecting that uh Fabi would
play a low pass maybe a Vienna game
definitely not a scotch because it's
fallen out of fashion because the pawn
structure is so imbalanced and it
provides both players with a lot of
chances to win and of course that means
to lose as well
yeah I mean the scotch was most popular
probably in the 90s Gary Kasparov really
introduced it to the highest level but
back in the wild west days I mean you
could push any pawn at the start and
kind of make it work you know with deep
Fritz 2 offering its Sage thoughts now
you really can't get away with that kind
of stuff so I always love it Yogi when
these top players bring back something
that's out of fashion because you start
wondering what it is that they have in
their pockets for that game this is a
standard position Bishop to A6 here is
the most popular move but you can also
drop back the Knight immediately as far
as I know and that's looked upon
favorably by current uh theoretical
knowledge as well
yeah yeah I I mean I'm not okay with the
latest trends but I remember it was very
popular to go Bishop B6 uh sorry Knight
B6 and then also fianchiato the dark
Square bishop and a very ambitious play
from Fabi
uh what do you think Wesley would do
because also bearing in mind that the
players have just come off a free day
Fabi will have spent all of his rest day
preparing the scotch meanwhile for
Wesley it's a surprise
yeah do you kind of stick to your normal
repertoire you kind of like have faith
in your openings or are you actually
going to uh just depart because
um incidentally there was a nice story
from uh Magnus actually after when he
was asked his thoughts about losing to a
niche in game four he kind of said well
he felt that Anish wasn't playing so
confidently and there we see the light
Square bishop move to the edge of the
board pinning the queen and he said well
you know Anish was taking his time and
so he decided to go Rogue and play
something completely different to what
he had prepared so he kind of went for
an intuitive choice and of course we all
know what happened on game four he got
crushed by any
yeah it did not turn out well but this
brings up a very interesting point Yogi
I think there's a misconception that top
players they they prepare an opening
they look at their file and then always
things go according to plan and they
always stick to what they had planned to
do that's not true I've heard a good
amount of interviews where top players
actually say that they do make spur of
the moment decisions in the opening more
often than people realize and often they
make those spur of the moment choices
precisely when they're facing something
unexpected because they know that if
they go down the path that they've gone
down previously they might run into some
incredibly nasty preparation so
immediately you run into this dilemma do
you play what you know best or do you
play something that you don't know as
well but your opponent isn't likely to
expect as Fabiano breaks his own Bishop
out to A3 two can play it that game says
Fabi and Wesley actually has a really
cute simplifying combination here which
I don't think solves all of his problems
Yogi but probably is Worth showing on
the analysis board he's got the move
Queen takes A3 in his Arsenal
and after Knight takes A3 you don't take
the Knight you play Bishop to B4 check
and King D1 runs into the fork but King
D1 isn't going to be White's choice is
it
no okay you gotta block that check with
your queen unfortunately
not nasty
this end game just looks slightly worse
for black I mean you've got the damage
Pawn structure and what do you have to
show for it
yeah I mean this you know actually this
Pawn structure is so bad that uh black
could often be pawns ahead and still he
has problems with the light Square
bishop and still white would be better
so I mean here white just looks like
they're killing it to be honest with you
and we've got control Bishop is locked
out of play
all you need to do is just connect your
Rooks and start advancing those pawns
I'm a big fan Daniel of advancing pawns
grabbing space
yeah no and and this is the last thing
that Wesley wants you know a worse end
game with minimal winning chances you
know after move 10 so as we go back to
the live board if he's not taking on A3
you can't check on B4 immediately
because the knights still controls C3
that means you either have to move your
queen don't move it up to E6 there are
hot coals here that Wesley has to avoid
I've seen the move Queen to G5 played in
similar positions but maybe Fabby in
that case is just gonna trade on f8 and
then bring his Knight out to D1 note
that Queen C1 is never that dangerous
because the queen can just slide back to
D1
yeah I've also seen moves such as uh
Knight B4 as well blocking the attack on
the queen
just absolutely yeah just to kind of
dissuade White from
castling to queenside
I'm so used to saying to the left to the
right but I forgotten
indeed
that makes that makes total sense night
before yeah Knight before does look
pretty interesting and Wesley is going
to continue pondering
his next move but what an interesting
opening here a scotch essayed by Fabiano
caruana something tells me this is going
to be a decisive game
yeah and definitely they've gone off
script as well you know normally they've
played quieter positions and then fire
was happening in the middle game here
they're going for broke immediately and
please can we fast forward to the Arjun
aragaisy dingler end game because well I
always get very excited when one person
has a push Pawns in front of that King
and there we see ding Loren he is really
taking a very committal approach it's
quite standard in Lopez I'm very excited
about it but it is standard but still I
find this kind of battles very complex
and extremely fascinating
let's jump into that game you can see
Magnus at the top of your screen they'd
stopped copying each other and Notre
back putting on the board a very
ambitious setup with a bind in the
center but we will get to that a little
bit later I'm on the same page the Eric
ICD game is so entertaining already and
not only has ding played H6 and G5 the
most ambitious way to meet the Italian
but he's also Castle to that same side
of the boardyovi which a lot of players
might find Radical wildly surprising but
in reality
well first of all black is often the one
who attacks on the king side anyway and
second of all yes black has some holes
on the king side but it's not like
Checkmate is imminent here
no it's certainly not imminent and uh
one thing I I remember reading uh this
book by Max Irvine on the Moodle game
and he was talking about these
particular positions and he was saying
and it's all to do with Pawn breaks you
develop your pieces and then white is
either going to get D4 or the other one
is F4 and uh by playing this particular
way there's no chance in any Century or
any version of life that white is ever
gonna get F4 in and uh here comes the
other Pawn break in the center you know
I love this they are players are
following the rules you know if you take
space on the wings you gotta strike in
the center this is the classical chess
and you got to pay homage to Max irva
who you mentioned the Dutch world
champion is beloved in Amsterdam I've
been to Mexico of a square I think
there's a Max of a museum and so how
fitting that Eric icy follows uh irva's
prescribed method of play D4 what an
ambitious move now first order of
business I think we need to explain uh
perhaps I need to explain to myself why
exactly black can't snatch up the pawn
on D4 so let's bring up an analysis
board and dig in now I assume that after
Ed White's gonna play CD yovi what
catches your eye here perhaps a queen uh
sortee over to H5
yeah definitely uh that's that's the
first move that I'm thinking about I'm
also thinking about just accelerating
the play and just blasting open the
Santa with E5
um but okay let's have a look at what
happens if the queen goes over and makes
a foray over to the black king and yeah
yeah it looks very scary
oh you're gonna grab even more pawns ah
the Eva's laughing in my face as usual
it's like you want Queen H5 give me some
of your pawns I the problem I was really
I was really attracted to this check
you'll be because it looks pretty
unfortunately it does exactly zilch
after Bishop G7 so here you're at a dead
end I actually think you're right I
think white is probably best advised to
try to open up another side of the board
such as the center with a move like E5
yeah that was kind of my vibe and you
know you've given up one Pawn give them
all up and uh just start shifting over
your minor pieces so this one looks a
little bit dangerous actually and I I I
have a tendency to use the British form
of understatement you know a little bit
dangerous very dangerous tiny bit just a
tad Mr yeah
yeah but okay you have to be
cold-hearted about these things I mean I
mean white does have their choice of
playing E5 and I mean when to do it
after Pawn takes porn could you do it
when the Knight reaches D4
yeah that actually might even be better
because you're not giving up B2 or takes
takes takes and now E5 I agree yeah
and uh
is there D5 here though
potentially I mean but is that a big
deal because if the bishop drops down to
D3 it's on the perfect perfect attacking
diagonal
yep and queen B1 could come later that
night is actually going to be trapped on
H7 if you think about Queen B1 is a huge
threat crazy I would ignore the computer
evaluation hero man this looks exactly
like what you don't want against a
well-prepared margin error guys this is
also not in ding Style
so if we rewind to the position after D4
you don't have to take immediately you
can also push G4 to knock the Knight off
of F3 first but you could also just play
H5 and say I don't care about the D4
Pawn I'm going to continue my king side
expansion
okay I I kind of like that one as well
keep the center closed but uh how scary
is that because obviously you have to do
something about your dark Square Bishop
push the pawn forward
H3 because
somehow I'm a little bit chicken when it
comes to the Pawns in front of my king I
don't want to take too many bold
decisions so my vibe is just to go H3
and I'm just going to curl up in a ball
but that could be very passive yeah
black could follow up with H4 and then
G4 and just throw all caution to the
window throw the kitchen sink at White
on the king side and again I just need
to point out this King on gate I mean it
sounds totally Brazen to play H5 and G4
but the reality is that if you hide the
King on h8 this Knight on H7 he moved it
back did dingler and I think to play the
move F5 originally but the Knight is
also a very good Defender when it's
curled up as you said in a ball it's
it's surprisingly hard to access Black's
King if it's just kind of chilling in
the corner White's King on the other
hand could get caught in the crossfire
very easily even though technically he's
got more Pawns in front of it
um yeah definitely I will we've seen
quite a few games actually at a high
level where we see this kind of scenario
white has this great Santa and black is
just attacking with all the pieces and
well definitely one to watch shall we
have uh another check on the bird's eye
view to see which other fights are
Brewing up I'm never going to say no to
that hey you can bring up the bird's eye
view any hour of the day and I'm gonna
say yes to it we've got so many diverse
openings here some with E4 some with C4
do we have any d4s well I guess in my
sulu's game we have that Queen's Gambit
accepted by the way that's over to the
right side of your screen he did take
the pawn and then Forest running from
the queen trade like you know from a
fire as he drifts his Queen from d8 over
to E8 hitting that Knight on E5 but
we've got you know a whole a whole
assortment of interesting positions what
else catches your iovi
well I have to say I mean we should this
seems to be just a few contenders I mean
like just taking just taking a look I
mean if we quickly kind of pop in a
pregnant under a niche I mean that just
seems like a very normal position
and uh not much to see
it's yeah it
does well the thing that kind of catches
my eye is that both players have kind of
put their Bishop on E3 and E6
respectively because I mean one of the
battles that I've
have come to understand in the Vienna is
all about this light Square dark Square
Bishop I mean most most sides kind of
prepare this bishop coming to E3 or
coming to E6 they want to recapture with
a piece but here perhaps they've been
inspired maybe pride has been inspired
by his game against ding because in that
game he has four doubled horns on the
e-line
so maybe he's kind of saying hey let's
repeat that pattern
I think that's a great point and I think
this position is very deceptive because
you look at it and you you basically
think draw this is just going to stay
symmetrical all the pieces are going to
be traded but if you look more carefully
there's a very high likelihood as you're
indicating that the pawn structure
actually becomes incredibly asymmetric
in the next two or three moves because
we you can't keep this tension forever
white the ball right now is in White's
Court he's the one who has to make a
decision and conceivably Prague could
take on E6 and then take on C5 and as
you said Black's Pawn structure is
ruined cosmetically but if you think
about it the pawns on C5 and E5 are
doing a great job of clamping down on
the B4 square and of course black has
the semi-openf file to operate on 1C
Castle's King side so that's why Prague
is taking his time here you don't
automatically want to take on E6 and
these types of Italian structures
yeah definitely something something to
ponder on also again like you mentioned
with the imbalance support structure it
does mean that the energy transfers to
the pieces you have a open F line
control the D4 Square
uh but to me it's also a very typical
Italian because
this is the whole name of the game there
you know it's a very much a waiting game
both pieces get their pieces developed
and then in the middle game you know all
hell breaks loose because one person has
broken free and uh tried to break in the
center or perhaps done something at the
wrong time is such a subtle opening and
I have to say I'm still trying to
understand it despite having played it
and watched this opening form now coming
up to a long time actually I'm not gonna
I'm gonna reveal how many years
well let's see I mean two years you're
not just kidding
um yeah I'm hey I'm at that I'm at that
stage as well where I don't wanna I
don't want to mention anything that has
to do with years or the first time I
played something because we're talking
about the early 2000s and you know
I don't know let's just uh table that
conversation but a conversation I don't
want a table is the one about
the matchup of the generations right
this is something I always love about
Fields about tournaments with an
Eclectic field this is only the second
classical matchup between prognananda
and giri again when you say something
like that it sounds crazy because Prague
has become a household name but you'll
be this really is one of his first
opportunities to match wits with the top
players on Earth and you know these
young players they come into these
tournaments they're not just trying to
put in a performance and phone it in
they're they're all trying to win
they're trying to Buck the trend they
don't care that it's their first time
playing they're going for the throat and
that makes it a terrifying experience
for the top guys
yeah absolutely they're very confident
and what I find very scary about Prague
is the fact that he's uh so calm with
his emotions I mean we saw him after he
beat Deng he did an interview and he
just said you know I've been in this
position before I've played great games
and afterwards after the free day I lost
a few games so I'm just gonna be calm
about it I'm not gonna display too much
happiness I'm not gonna display too much
sadness about anything it's just about
the chess and that Focus I think is
deadly and I see it it's such a common
trait amongst the young Indian Juniors
there are very very cool customers and
they don't have this ego and this
arrogance that is normally associated
with like the old players instead it's
just all about learning about getting
better
and I I find that this is
quite scary when it comes to chess
talent because it just means that these
youngsters are just lovingly leveling up
all the time they're just
you know when you think that you've
detected a weakness
you have for five minutes and then they
fixed it
so it's so easy to root for as you said
I mean they're modest their humility
makes them uh Unstoppable and as you
said they don't get too high with the
highest don't get too low with the lows
if they have a bad tournament you know
they're they're sitting at their desk
analyzing the games on the very next day
they just don't let anything get to them
we're talking gukash prognananda
aragaisy this generation of Indian
Talent is so so exciting and all three
of them anyhow Saran have World
Championship aspirations that would not
be an exaggeration Bishop takes C6
meanwhile has indeed happened why has a
kind of a cool resource Knight takes E5
here in order to meet Knight takes E5
with D4 that occurred to me as you were
making uh some great points about Prague
but he's actually the one taking his
time Geary has more time than he started
with so obviously still in his
preparation and I'd be terrified if I
knew Gary had an hour and 43 minutes uh
against me I would be trying to you know
take the back roads whatever you do
avoid the freeway avoid his opening
files
yeah that's true but in this type of
position I mean can you just play it
cool and just do something or should you
play in the principled way which would
be actually the trade off the bit dark
Square Bishops
the more I look at it the less I like
Bishop takes C5 I feel like it'll be
very hard for white to operate in the
center and in the Italian you often want
to leave yourself as far as I know with
the possibility of playing D4 speak of
the devil D4 is on the board immediately
yeah
and okay
you're very good fortune teller and so
okay what happens now so there's a
choice now you the bishop can Retreat or
there could be a capture and the first
move that I would be calculating would
be capturing on D4
um I presumably with the pawn but it
does occur to me that there are other
captures on the board like Knight takes
porn
yeah if you're gonna take three times it
really doesn't matter what you take with
but you want to leave yourself as
flexible as possible probably black
should take with the pawn so if people
have an analysis word here real quick
the first thing we should understand is
what happens if black just trades
everything on D4 is this just Josh or is
there some Intrigue in this position
yovi my instinct is to say that this is
about equal you know black it even just
Castle kingside but maybe Prague is a
little something something after E5
yeah my my instinct was uh was that
black
is under some slight pressure actually
and to do with the King safety because
say black says hey I don't want E5 I'm
gonna play E5 myself the queen can kind
of move herself to C4 and the question
arises like what are you gonna do about
the king and yeah you're kind of calling
out that F4 is very much in my uh fears
uh before as well but uh
so my vibe is don't trade off everything
I don't think that's necessarily a good
idea but you can initiate a set of
Trades
um
and then maybe leave it here
is this a possibility
and just like Castle
yeah but then you do ruin the pawn
structure and I'm not a fan of having an
ugly structure yeah
um
so then I would kind of rewind and say I
don't like this just because I I don't
like the Aesthetics or the position
and uh perhaps keep keep the knights on
the board
can we do it that way
or do we have to make the trade of
knights the issue is that here you would
love to play Knight D7 uh to stop E5 but
but G7 hangs and you're walking into
Queen H5 so yeah no no no no I meant now
yeah
oh you might take first or you meant
here yeah take first yeah because I was
trying to kind of go through my thought
process like so first of all now I would
like take care and then I would look at
moves like maybe Queen to D7 so not
not uh I I'm very aware there was a rule
by a it was a lesson actually by Ben
Larson I was reading his book and uh he
said you know if your king is on an open
diagonal it's unsafe you've got to
protect your king and I was just
thinking Queen D7 with the idea that
Knight takes night you can go Queen
takes night keep it nice and solid keep
it calm
I love Queenie salmon I think that I
actually think that solves all those
problems because here if you compare
this position to the one that happens if
black takes on D4 White's Queen is a lot
less active it doesn't have access to
that C4 Square we were talking about
earlier and guess what if black castles
here you've got some pressure on F2 I'm
you know let's say white offers a draw
here I'm thinking about playing on here
with black I I like Black's piece
activity and of course the pawn
structure remains intact so I had to
make a prediction I actually think you
called it I think Gary is going to take
on D4 and play Queen D7 the one bit of
good news for Prague is that Anish Gary
has actually started to think shocker
oh but but wait one second this also
means that Prague hasn't played the best
moves because if they have been playing
the top engine Choice then hey
um Niche would have responded instantly
so yeah swings and roundabouts
indeed D4 is on the board tension is
happening in the center anisha's pushing
his chair in he's gonna settle in for a
nice long think
I think what we should take this
opportunity to swing ourselves back to
the bird's eye view let's see what's
going on on some of the other boards and
Magnus is positioned getting real
interesting but I'm happy to go where
our heart desires yovi oh man yeah the
problem is that there are so many
exciting games I mean
I mean there's one that I'm just itching
to go back to but we've already been
there it's Arjun erag I see against me
too
um
because it really reminds me of arjun's
game against Liam laquan in the
Champions chess tour
and there Eric icy just sacrificed like
three pawns even with a check uh giving
them away with a check and he just
checkmated liamza King it was such a
brilliant tactical Fest and I'm
wondering whether aragaisi is also
having the same kind of
um I'd say uh Deja Vu feeling well we
have to go back also because of the last
move on the board there was also crazy
stuff happening in the maxillo game
we'll get to that next because there was
a psac carried out by a bloodthirsty
Parham but oh my goodness this is not a
transmission error look at Arjun
aragaisy's last move which he carried
out in about five seconds first of all
ding decided on something we did point
out Yobe he plays G4 first he knocks the
Knight away then he takes on D4 Rook A1
to B1 this is modern chess ladies and
gentlemen
this right here
this is the epitome of modern chess
so so tell me about this mysterious
brick move um what do you think it's all
about I I mean the positional uh person
in me just goes well you know after porn
tastes born he's just gonna recapture
and then the light Square Bishop can't
come out
I think you're exactly right I think
you're exactly right Yogi when I in my
limited experience judging
computer moves they're usually played
for prophylactic reasons and prophylaxis
in chess is the art of stopping your
opponent's threats and ideas so you look
at a move like Roku you want I think the
only conceivable reason can be that the
rook's placement is going to be
justified in the event of a trade not
only is black gonna have a hard time
bringing his Bishop out but you could
actually swing The Rook from B5 to H5
later I think nothing is out of the
picture here or out of the question the
position that's that's this unorthodox
and you know what scares me the most
let's hear it take a look at arjun's
clock time he's got more time than he
started with and when your opponent is
playing Rook these are kind of weird and
wonderful moves like Rook B1 oh you know
you're in some home-cooked preparation
oh my God love this
this is bad news for ding you're exactly
right this would be so disconcerting you
have a position that's getting more and
more tactical your opponent's play is
merely getting faster but ding takes a
sip of I think that was water ABT
he's you know talk about not getting too
low with the lows not getting too high
the highest ding is so experienced he is
an E4 E5 player for many many years so
he expects his opponents to be well
prepared and he doesn't let that get to
him but white has so many tactical ideas
here there's Knight H4 to G6
my big question here yovi is what
arjun's next move is going to be let's
say ding plays Bishop C8 to D7 for
example how is he going to keep
accumulating the pressure on the king
side
well my first kind of view is that first
of all you should try to look at ways to
get the queen over
but I since I mean I would really love
to kind of somehow magic the queen over
to H5 since that is quite unlikely I'll
be just looking at improving my pieces
or maybe trying to initiate a
breakthrough so like maybe E5 is
something that I would also be
considering
and speaking of magicing the queen over
to that side of the board what's
stopping the queen of course is G4
but after Bishop D7 you could train
Knight H4 to F5 you could try to slice
off the connection between the bishop
and the Knight let's bring up an
analysis board here real quick Bishop D7
let's say Knight F5
okay Bishop F5 EF and your movie five
Yogi has the effect of opening up the E4
Square for the Knight or The Rook this
has the exact same effect something like
Queen G5 could run into 94 couldn't it
you'd have to calculate what happens
after Queen takes Pawn as well
I mean the play is getting Fast and
Furious here then the bishop comes down
to D3 oh
this is this is oh
it's crazy
um I mean I mean is there any way to do
any repair work like for instance
move the night to hit E5 I mean he just
has to or maybe 95 I'm not so sure about
but I like 95 though because you're
attacking the tale of the discovery
yes the problem though is the night can
get exchanged so there is Bishop takes
Knight
um what other things are there and then
there could be a potential discovered
for sure
you could maybe this is Quincy too
no you're right it's yeah there's
nothing decisive let's put it that way
clearly nothing decisive here
yeah so um this is such a wild position
Okay so
going back to the game
Night comes to F so Knight F5 is
definitely
a move that one would consider
and uh
what else is there
it's an idea that's I'll put it modestly
it's it exists it's somewhere out there
in The Ether and it's on arjun's radar
and so the thing is though you know I've
been trying to train myself
um quite a bit these last few months to
think about alternatives to kind of come
up with that list you know I'm trying to
be very schematic about it and then
choose from that list so it's like
checks captures threats going back to
the good old CCT and so the first kind
of moves is like again I don't know why
I'm drawn to E5 I mean it's such a I
don't know maybe it's not the best move
another move that I was thinking about
was just because I'm
a sucker for Pawn breaks and I really
want to go F3 or H3 but obviously if I
go F3 I'm exposing the king so I was
thinking do a Carolina tuck it in the
corner and then get ready to shift
everything over
um I mean I yeah that pawn on G4 is the
main obstacle to White's attack so I
think you're absolutely right that white
needs to Target it whether you do Knight
F5 or H3
yeah and if you go H3 if you go like
hell yeah let's throw caution to the
wind
enough yeah
[Laughter]
yeah
I mean is there anything there
um Queen G5 is the problem you know the
queen always has to protect her King
and you're not kind of
getting anywhere there
no you're not that Queen d8 G5 that's a
move which makes an appearance both
after Knight F5 and as you said you play
Queen H5 prematurely it has the opposite
effect the last thing you want with
white is a queen trade but looking at
the Evo bar there's just no way that
Ding could have anticipated this because
this is the new type of preparation you
go for a position where it's minus point
three it's minus 0.5 so it's really hard
to anticipate if you just follow the top
line but players and their seconds they
make the decision that from a practical
perspective the position is hard to play
even though it could be a little bit
better for the opponent even if you
aren't acquainted with the ideas if you
aren't familiar with the best way to
play you could just dig yourself into a
hole within a couple of moves and ding
he's digging himself into a hole on the
clock Yogi so this is a game that we
definitely want to keep track of
yeah and uh talking about games you want
to keep track on we have we have to go
to the game uh between Max hoodloo and
Van Forrest because you kind of said
there's a peace sacrifice and uh when I
see that on the board well my my need
for uh
how do you go what do you call it do you
know when you have that insatiable
desire to observe everything you've got
to be there sitting there Wanderlust I
don't know it's just wonderlust that is
my word yeah you have to travel to Each
corner of the world that is a
fascinating game but before we get to it
we are going to recharge and refill our
coffee cups we are going to go on a
short break ladies and gentlemen as this
incredibly exciting round five of Tata
steel has gotten underway and we've got
such an Eclectic mix a fascinating
position of positions we will bring you
the magsudu van Forest barn burner along
with all of the other games after we
come back to our coverage of Tata Steel
2023.
just played an exciting game and want to
see if you got a brilliant seat or maybe
where you could have improved
chess.com's game review is just a click
away game review is a fast fun and
instructive guided review of your games
see your accuracy and your opponent's
accuracy check out the eval graph for an
instant overview and scroll down to see
how many great moves best moves blunders
and yes brilliancies you have played
learn from chess.com's coach who gives
move explanations opening statistics and
shows you the best lines of play
with retry mistakes you can get another
shot at finding missed opportunities
try game review today on web iOS or
Android
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to Tata steel 2023 this is
round five the players are fresh they're
fresh off of rest day and they are
showing it Jam Daniel noditski and I am
yovi Huska bringing you commentary on
this lovely day and what a lovely day it
is you'll be wherever your eyes turn
you've got super exciting action and
particularly like suit Lu against van
Forrest carowana Wesley magnus's game
all of them rivaling each other in terms
of their Intrigue level
I I know we couldn't have asked for a
better start I mean the players have
certainly used the rest day to come back
refreshed and energetic and we've seen
people get in the opening preparation
we've seen surprises and uh We've also
seen a peace sacrifice which can we
quickly go over to this game between
Parham and Jordan van forest and uh
there we see it
Jordan has that oh no look on his face
like what have I gotten myself into you
know we've all been there
yeah absolutely and uh I mean people at
home are asking maybe why is this a
peace sacrifice and the whole point is
that Bishop takes Knight will be played
and after Pawn takes Bishop there is
Queen takes Knight on the board and uh
what is uh maxoodloo's idea behind this
peace threat I mean is he planning to
put the queen in the middle of the board
and say hey look at me I've got three
passports or is it something deeper and
more first he's going to say I think
he's gonna say hey look at me I've got
three pass pawns and you've got no
pieces developed no first of all it's
important to point out this is not a
blunder like he definitely sees Bishop
take C3 and I think the situation is so
bad for black even after he accepts the
sacrifice Jordan is actually thinking
about declining it with a move like
Queen takes B5 and just accepting
basically a pawn down miserable
situation because takes takes takes
Queen comes out to D4 if you trade
Queens you're just gonna get run over
over by all of the pawns I mean that's
not even close why it's just winning
there I think
yeah and if you don't trade trade of
Queens of course the best the pawn on C4
will get picked off and uh that pawn on
C5 is just so strong and not to mention
that white still has very active pieces
I mean I always have this phrase in
chess it's not what they are it's what
they do
and when it comes to the pawn on C5 and
again the bishop on C1 and the one on
Arrow that's soon to be on C4 on that
that is just a really really bad
position for black I mean just take a
look at his extra piece it's not going
to be utilized at all
no and something Robert Hess would point
out anytime a pawn in the night are on
the same file and there's two squares
between them not good news for the night
and you have that situation here that
pawn on B5 completely restricting the
mobility of Black's Knight on B8 let
alone the fact that the Rook is out of
the game that the bishop on C8 has no
real good square and black is suffering
on the dark squares if he takes on C3 so
Jordan kind of raising his eyebrows
there really this is what I have on move
11. this is troubled times here for the
Dutch Grand Master and one incredible
preparation by Mike Sudlow
yeah absolutely but do you think he
predicted it or do you think it was just
something he had in his
um Arsenal
yeah it's a good question given how fast
he's played I think if he had that in
his Arsenal he probably would have taken
a little bit longer to remember his file
so if I had to make a guess I think he
predicted the Queen's gamut accepted
from Jordan which is so impressive
because Jordan really can play anything
to play grunfeld I've seen him play
nimso Indian so harham and his team
doing phenomenal work here in the early
going but his job is not done the game
is not over and you'll be in the
Challenger section A couple rounds ago
we saw him the Iranian Grand Master
blunder a piece and one move on move six
and come back to beat his opponent there
was no compensation there but he managed
to spin up some complications and uh I'm
sure I'm sure that Max Sulu is aware uh
that that is a possibility so he is not
resting on his Laurels here at all
yeah no I have to say that vike does
have that tradition of uh certain people
just blundering pieces and the position
being unbalanced enough to be
complicated and the reason I'm saying
this is because Magnus actually lost a
piece to Gwen Jones I think it was in
and uh you know he just carried on as if
you know whoops didn't didn't realize
that and just carried on so nothing
happened and then and won the game and
turned it around
and uh it was quite funny because
tatabate he's kind of said in his
interview that that was his inspiration
here
yeah
man I mean I'm just trying to take a
deep breath and let these games settle
in
but another game that we have to get to
Ivanka is the Wesley so car won a game I
know we haven't touched the world
champion in a while but we have to spin
our way back to the Carolina Wesley game
which is right over on the left side of
your screen
any objections
no absolutely not let's get there and
let's Zoom there as quickly as we can
because that position is crazy I mean we
have opposite side King's castling we
have both sides just attacking each
other I mean first of all what on Earth
is happening I mean who is going to get
checkmated here and
you need to take about half an hour here
to digest this position oh goodness me I
mean like first of all if I were black I
would be thinking
is my king gonna get checkmated if the
queen comes to H3 is it Checkmate and my
quick observation is no it's safe
because that Bishop on G7 is a defensive
Beast
and if that's the case yeah
and if that's the case and if it can't
get rid of then I've got a free move to
do something and that could be like
putting a rook on an open line
or making some no I can't touch any
pieces that's the thing I'm also
thinking about moves like C3 as well so
I've got my steadcom calm and controlled
move a rook to the center another move
that I'm considering would be like just
playing C3 and saying hey I'm attacking
your Bishop but maybe that's too over
optimistic
oh God there's so many moves
there are C Institute C3 caught my eye
as well because I was very attracted to
the prospect of deflecting the bishop on
B2 if you can sink your teeth into the
A3 Pawn black can whip up some mating
chances of his own what I will say uh
just to piggyback off of your point I
don't think either side is an imminent
threat of getting checkmated I think
that white needs three or four moves to
actually set up real mating threats
three or four moves in the context of a
middle game like this is an eternity so
black has time he doesn't have a lot of
it and the question for Wesley is how do
I use my time to properly generate
threats against White's gang and you
pointed out a couple choices you could
Ring The Rook to d8 and set up some
sacrifices on D2 you could play the move
C3 try to simplify the game and trade
the Bishops you could play a move like
Queen C5 and bring the queen into the
attack you could play Knight T5 I mean
the abundance of Canada move sounds like
a good thing but it's not a good thing
if you haven't studied this position
before and and White's plan is very
clear you'll be I think there's two main
ideas there's Queen H3 Queen H7 the
second idea is to drop the Knight into
F6 and the Knight pays a visit to that
square there will be hell to pay for
black that's when the Checkmate threats
become real that's when the rubber hits
the road
okay so Knight E4 is definitely a
dangerous idea so let's kind of like
take it easy and let's go Rick moving
over to d8 you know black saying hey I'm
kind of far I'm not fussed about what's
happening and then the night will come
to E4 and then black has to answer this
knight jump and
you know you're looking at retreating
moves or maybe moving a night to the
center of the board anything to cover
the F6 Square
oh I mean
is is this critical
so one detail I want to bring up in
reference to 94. let's pull up an
analysis board and just sample a couple
moves here if black blazer kd8 and white
plays Queen H3 which isn't necessarily
the best move it's important to point
out that or sorry not you're obviously
here Bishop
you have to say that you have to set a
checkmate
so cb94 for example Bishop E5 there's a
beautiful Checkmate pattern that evil
bar shooting up and it's because of
Queen h8
it's because of Queen h8 what a
checkmate
I know that is gorgeous uh that will
give you a satisfaction if you get that
on the board but it won't happen
unfortunately these players are just too
good they will have spotted this
what Fabiano will not miss Maiden two
come on I mean you're giving way too
much credit to these players and they
regularly mismade them too
come on
oh my bad thank you it's like just like
the restaurant
only only half human so in a position
like this black would presumably play a
move like 95 I suppose The Bishop's
hanging here so perhaps first uh black
would take on F1 and what I've been
trying to establish is whether or not
white has a mate from this position so
I've been testing out ridiculous ideas
like Queen H7 and queen G7 and this
comes really within a millimeter of
checkmating unfortunately when you
sacrifice this many pieces you give your
opponent the possibility of sacking a
lot of them back and still maintaining a
material advantage which is a classic
case here F6 and if you take on F6 When
the Smoke Clears Black's gonna have an
extra Knight on B6 that's not a not an
option for white
yeah that is unfortunate but it is so
close I mean I'm also looking at ways to
sacrifice material and is it I mean
I mean you could almost do weird and
wacky moves like put the queen I put the
Knight on F6 I mean you have to debug it
out at the right time
and then
oh it's everything is coming within a
whisker
it really is and if you're not prepared
which Wesley isn't he's got an hour five
minutes and look at carwana's clock hour
53 minutes this is still on caruana's
laptop so just a terrifying Sensation
that Wesley must be experiencing right
now and you've got to test each of these
lines to make sure that you don't get
checkmated so we'll go back to the live
board here
um as Queen F3 is on the board
just terrifying preparation for Fabiano
caruana I just love the fact that he
played a scotch he took a risk and in
the early going it seems to be paying
off
yeah and uh so we're pretty hopeful for
Fabi but I was just looking from the
black side of things I mean is it
possible to defend against the Knight
coming to E4 I mean just kind of be calm
and go yeah Knight come to D7 cover the
F6 Square the reason I was a little bit
afraid about the night coming to D5 is
that it's unstable the night is unstable
on D5 it you know a piece can capture on
C4 and kick it away and you don't want
your Defenders to be kicked back from
important squares
that's that's exactly right so we talked
about White's prospects the good news
for black I think is that as we just
analyzed even if white gets a knight to
E4 and queen H7 I think the upshot of
the conversation we just had is that
white does not have a forced mate in
that position that gives black a little
bit more time than it appears he has so
I would seriously consider a
quote-unquote slow move like Rook a to
d8 if I'm Wesley I'm trying to get my
pieces into the center and orchestrate
some sort of a sacrifice on D2 but in
order to fuel the fire of the attack you
need more pieces so Rook 88 is a move
very much in Wesley's style he's so calm
even in the face of mortal Danger
yeah well he will have to have nerves of
Steel here because he is going to be
facing an onslaught in the next concert
oh very good like that one interrupted
you with that point that's what kind of
a commentator I am
it was it was a good one so uh feel free
to interrupt me anytime and okay
so whilst this one is all fire on the
board can we take a look at Magnus
Carlson against uh naughty back because
that one looks a little bit more
tranquil shall we say but still I can
see it's gonna be brewing for a big
fight because the position is open and
when the position is open with no Pawns
in the middle of the board this means
that the energy transfers to the pieces
and it's all going to be about putting
those Rooks on open lines making your
pieces work in the best possible way and
we've seen that Magnus is like the
master of Harmony right he knows how to
put pressure and he knows knows how to
make things unpleasant for his opponent
and the big question for Naughty back
here is I mean what's he gonna do about
the PIN
yeah being pen against the Knight on C6
and what's he gonna do about the
prospect of the bishop coming out to
this juicy long diagonal The Rook
getting into C1 white is better here I
think the result of the opening is
Magnus in a satisfied manner gets up
from his chair to check out the other
games
I think Magnus has exactly the kind of
position that you want in exactly the
kind of position you want after a loss
you want to mitigate your risk you want
to avoid backsliding into two losses in
a row he's got a position already
basically for two results you'll be
maybe I'm overstating the case here but
if you rewind a couple of moves we just
had a completely different situation but
this move Bishop E2 to B5 moving the
bishop for the second time in the
opening was I think the key to the
kingdom for Magnus because it forces
noterbeck to release the tension in the
center and to help white prepare this D4
Pawn strike so we have a mass trade on
D4 and to answer your original question
how is black going to solve the pin well
Bishop D7 to me looks like the most
tempting move but Magnus doesn't have to
react to that he can just continue
developing and to continue accumulating
the pressure by putting the Rook on C1
ASAP
yeah that's what I was afraid of you
know the bishop coming to the light the
sky as you highlighted and in this type
of position I mean is it possible that
nordebec can fall back on perhaps giving
away material but liquidating a lot of
the minor pieces and just saying hey
let's play an end game where you're one
Pawn up that would be the E3 Pawn ain't
that big of a deal
yes or am I just yes
okay I was just wondering whether that
was a pipe dream
because I if I were black I would be
just like okay let's get the king to
safety let's forget about a Pawn on just
say if there's Knight takes night porn
takes just forget about defending that
pawn that's not kind of crawl into a
small ball let's instead just play as
actively as I can and get pressure along
we'll just get counter play that way
so I agree I actually think Castle's
here is probably better than Bishop D7
just because you have your priorities
straight and as you're saying even after
the trade on C6 if I'm Notre back I'm
not necessarily giving up that pawn
voluntarily you can try to defend it but
what you do in these types of positions
a lot of the time you put upon on C5 for
example and in the time that it takes
for your opponent to pile up pressure on
that weak Pawn you use that time to get
your pieces onto ideal squares and set
yourself up properly let's say for a
pawn down end game in which perhaps you
generate significant peace activity so
definitely defensive options here for
Notre brick but the big choice right now
for him
um as you indicated is whether you want
to Castle immediately and allow a damage
of your Pawn structure or do you want to
play Bishop D7 someone more stubbornly
but that moves comes comes with a little
bit of risk because you're delaying
Castle in kingside
yeah
yeah I I have this Instinct for playing
actively so I I'm not going to be
playing Bishop D7 but then again this is
this is some of the things that we kind
of call the Magnus effect a lot of
people take a lot of negative decisions
like they defend their possible
weaknesses just because they're playing
World Champion or in fact anyone who
stronger voted than them and they're
afraid somehow to take them at their own
battle they're afraid to take the game
to something active or dynamic and
I don't think an order back will do that
he's off this new fresh generation where
they're simply unafraid of anything they
trust in themselves there's a lot of
hard work going on behind the scenes so
I'm predicting that castles will make
its appearance I'll be very surprised to
see Bishop D7
yeah and you mentioned the Magnus effect
and you mentioned how relatively
impervious the Young Generation is to
the Magnus effect you're absolutely
right I mean you see that uh in a lot of
the times that somebody like Magnus
faces somebody like Notre Beck
norterbeck defeating Magnus at the world
rapid Championship on route to becoming
the world rapid champion and as you said
the decisions just don't change as much
for these younger players based on who
they're playing that's how they've been
taught from a very early age and look at
that final stat you'll be abusator of
was born in 2004. you were pointing this
out uh before the show started the same
year that Magnus Carlsen already made
his debut in tata steel that is just a
mind Bender right there just thinking
about that
yeah I must admit that stat did make me
laugh because 2004 you know it doesn't
seem that long ago if you ask me but
apparently it was uh yeah that's just
crazy
born in 2004 and already playing on the
world's finest stage in The Wimbledon of
Chess and doing so with such ease and is
he twiddling with a piece he is what are
your thoughts on these uh peace
twiddling mm-hmm
do you think it's unethical somehow
because it can be destroyed okay he's
doing it out of Carlson's eye line but
uh
I mean it is a little bit and actually
Carson is doing it himself
um I kind of think it's a little bit
distracting
and I think it can be
I think it depends on how you do it I
mean Boris gelfund I think is the famous
peace twiddler and he just he actually
performs some acrobatics with his pieces
he if throws the Knight up into the air
and catches it and all of this uh he's
not actually looking he's looking at the
board as he's doing it but Magnus is
slow rolling it there's different styles
right Magnus kind of slow spinning the
pawn Notre back was fiddling a little
bit more nervously
yeah but I I mean is there some
psychological value to this I mean
presumably everyone is doing it because
it calms the nerves and the energy the
nervous energy that you're generating
just from being in this high pressure
environment gets transferred over to
that poor Pawn
um
I I don't know whether it should be
allowed
I I My Vibe is no
interesting
yeah
I think everything that that leaves the
board should be kept off the table in
fact the players should deposit it in a
bin minus the queen of course actually
they didn't even need it
no that wouldn't work because of course
you have promotion
it's interesting you point out the bin
at the Mechanics Institute chess club in
San Francisco where I basically grew up
uh there was a very old school that the
boards were carved into the table so the
squares were literally part of the
tables and next to each board there was
a an inset kind of box that extended
into the table where you put captured
pieces and both white and black had a
very elegant compartment where you would
store the pieces after the game and
after you've captured them so what
you're saying is actually not unheard of
and that's how things were done in the
old days love the Mechanics Institute I
have a lot of stories about it but you
know I'll be I'll be telling a lot of
them in in due course
uh cool I didn't actually know that and
I hear I was thinking that I had a nice
fresh idea but in fact no it's all been
seen before that sounds really good and
uh okay so definitely things heating up
in the game between Magnus and Nordy
back shall we move along and uh revisit
what are the other games
so someone who we haven't actually
checked up on is levona ronin against
Vincent kymer and I was I'm especially
excited by this pairing because I've
noticed that when these two play each
other the games are wild in a way that
games
I'm not ever wild I mean they're just up
the level completely I mean have they
managed to achieve it
well aronian kymer and that's right in
the middle of your screen as we check
out the bird's eye view briefly here and
man it's just very hard to focus my eyes
on one word in particular by the way
before I get to that notice that maxoulu
has indeed gone through with the peace
sacrifice Jordan has accepted it and
white has a monster up upon sitting on
C6 trouble brewing in your invent Forest
game but to get back to aronian kymer we
have a classic Roy Lopez battle and
you'll be compared to some of the other
games this might look boring but it's
actually very far from boring just
because it's more strategic and and more
positional this less tactical fireworks
that certainly does not mean that we
should expect a quick draw here or that
this is a yawn inducing position in fact
I think it's still well within the
bounds of Rue Lopez Theory both players
look at the time oh my gosh
and I guess kymer has taken a lot more
time than Roni in here I say five
yes I mean Ronin has more time than when
he started and A5 so it's a very much a
strategic battle and yeah like hey five
going for Queen side expansion meanwhile
of course aronian will focus his energy
on the king side just so relocating his
night perhaps maneuvering the other
night preparing for f that my vibe would
be prepared F4 get open that uh those
Pawn centers um another thing that I
could potentially do if I were playing
with white would be just sit on the
space that's actually one of my favorite
things to do in chess you know it's just
you're just like yep got got all the
space in the world so what I'm going to
do just move my pieces do nothing
committal and wait for black to
instigate any form of action and then
you react accordingly
um even better is when you actually
predict what your opponent is going to
do and you stop it that is the dream
I rarely get that in though
it is indeed and Iranian living the
dream they're sipping on whatever hot
beverage she has in his hand pondering
the situation we are aware that the
clock was jumping around there a little
bit we'll try to update you more
accurately uh very shortly on how much
time Lavon has they are now fully
accurate so Lavon he doesn't quite have
as much time as he started with but he's
only spent 15 minutes or so the chimer
is 50. so this move A5 very very
committal because you're essentially
inviting white to take on C6 and take on
B5 but I am totally on the same page
with you Yogi I don't think white should
do that I don't think white should yield
control of the center and I think Lavon
should slow roll it with a move like
Knight G3 or Knight to E3 or or H3 in
such positions nothing really happens
fast
yeah but that's yeah I'm on the same
page I love Knight E3 the Knight has a
lot of flexibility covers the central
squares also threatens to come in on F5
and uh I don't quite see what uh kymer
is doing you know he needs to he needs
to I don't know I feel like as black you
needed to be doing something you know it
could be something like G6 once you've
expanded as much as you can on the left
side G6 and move your Bishop to G7 just
to protect the king and then
it's
I don't know you know threatened to
perhaps break out with F5 but not really
wait and see it's all I can well I can
advocate
it's just one of those things right
where I think the next five seven moves
the players are gonna assemble their
pieces on you know whichever side of the
board they want to operate on we're
gonna see Knight G3 and maybe bishop E3
so they're sort of gathering together
the forces because you know that at one
point the center is going to open up no
tension in chess exists forever so I'm
either white or black will eventually
Flinch and release some of that tension
when tension is released in the center
files open on the sides of the board so
you could have an open C file when a
file opens the battle transitions from
the area of tension which was the center
to those sides of the board that have
new uh new tension the tension basically
shifts and we will see which side of the
board the tension will shift to very
rich strategic position here in Iranian
Heimer
yeah and we can see that levonaronian
has a four-time winner of Tata steel and
the latest one winning in 2014.
four-time winner that's nothing in
comparison to Magnus
eight-time winner
and also a funny fun fact is Anish Gary
is actually five time runner-up
wow that's I did not know that
yeah I didn't know that either until I
was researching the tournament I was
like oh Anish and uh meanwhile
so we take a bird's eye look at all the
other games because you know how I was
saying that nordybeck would no way Play
Bishop to D7 protecting the Knight
well I was wrong he did
so he
yeah well I kind of thought he would
take a an active approach but he hasn't
he's just developed his light Square
Bishop
a good move as it is and uh Let's uh
have a look at the wildest game
um actually there are so many crazy
games and the one that we haven't really
we haven't seen in a long time is Arjun
eragisi against England
because there the position was brewing
up for a lot of fun things and uh we
left the game when Eric Garcia had
played the mysterious Rook B1
well not the mysterious because it was
just very subtle
this settle the nuanced rugby one and
we've only had one pair of moves played
since then but but that pair of moves
has given us a lot of new information
about the approach that Ding has chosen
whatever approach he's chosen he has to
put a move on because he's already down
to 50 minutes and what's interesting is
that Arjun finally took a little bit of
time so ding's move Knight C6 to E5
might have been out of the bounds of
arjun's opening file he responded by
moving the bishop back and now ding has
just captured the pawn on C3 so he has
in a way Justified the placement of The
Rook but he's also opened up for himself
a very nice diagonal so Yogi I'm
assuming that White's gonna recapture on
C3 and then maybe black will bring the
queen up as we were discussing earlier
for defensive purposes now uh visually
this doesn't look like anything special
for white but that knight from D2 can
also swing over to E3 and these light
squares in the center I think that's
where a lot of the problems could really
lie for black
yeah and uh Eric icy does in fact
capture the pawn I was a little bit uh
thinking like why is he hesitating and
capturing the porn I mean did he have
other ideas of perhaps rerouting the
Knight to F1 to sit on E3 and then get
control of the F5 square and a ding
responding immediately with H5
supporting his Pawn in the middle
so not in the middle on G4
um
wow I'm surprised at that because that's
a very luxurious move I mean does he
have time I would have been developing
some pieces
but uh
I don't know can he afford this is what
you're saying can he afford to make more
weaknesses on the king side well I guess
he's saying that there's no imminent
danger to his King I think we're very
likely to see Knight dude at F1 here but
your old idea also King moving away to
H1 and then pushing up the F Pawn very
real possibility as well
yeah
yeah yeah I had forgotten about that
idea thank you for reminding me you're
very welcome I just had a reminder
it's a good good stuff uh okay so if it
does make its way on the board the king
but the King on H1 nice uh sophisticated
move
yeah I mean what can black do I mean
there is the idea of Knight D3
um there's also ideas of uh getting the
queen over to F6 to protect her King as
quickly as possible
I mean
but uh
going to put on the board after Queen F6
or after let's say King H1 Queen F6 or
King H1 Knight D3
it's a good question King H1 is a
double-edged move as you said because
you are freeing the F1 but you're also
weakening it so Queen F6 also comes with
the threats that Bishop takes F2 man
this is just such a rich position I
could not imagine having this with
either color if I wasn't just deeply
acquainted with the ideas
sure taking his time as our generic icy
finally for the first time this game
yovi is that much to ding's relief or as
you said earlier is that disconcerting
for Dame because he knows that he's
deviated from arjun's file it's it's a
lose-lose
yeah I have to say I mean I think ding
has disconcerted anyhow because you're
facing aragosi and who one of his main
strengths is that he's an incredibly
Dynamic player he's such a good
tactician he's so good with moving those
pieces forward propelling those attacks
so I it is not really the type of
position that uh ding would be feeling
comfortable in having said all that of
course you you have to do the job what's
in front of you and here it is just to
protect the kid King survive the next
few moves and just consolidate the
pieces so Dean probably won't be feeling
too much ahead and we have to also
remember that eragisi is such a talent
everyone I've spoken to has very high
words of praise for him you know he's
only 19 years old last year and the
challenges he just Blitz through the
field you know and it was really clear
that you know he shouldn't be have been
playing in the challenges he should have
been up there in the Masters and that's
where he is and I can remember when he
made his breakthrough in the gold money
Asian rapid on the champions tour last
uh two years ago
and but we hadn't even heard of him and
suddenly he came in and he went all the
way to the quarterfinals which was
unheard of at the time and now of course
everyone is familiar with the name
aragaisi and also everyone is familiar
with the name
pragnanda who actually defeated ding in
round four
yeah I mean we take some of these
players for granted we take their
Improvement curves for granted but if
you put this in a historical context
these Improvement curves particularly
for Eric I see they are historic they
are unprecedented you just never have
had players moving past the swamp of
2600 as fast as Arjun has and as fast as
Prague is Prague is almost 2700 but
Arjun has just been on honestly one of
the greatest uh Tournament winning
streaks that I have ever seen in my
chess career he won also some incredibly
strong open tournaments like the I think
the Abu Dhabi Masters and you know
anything online he's played well there
too you know all the the aim chess rapid
tournaments Just You Name It Whatever
format wherever the tournament was held
however it was held online or OTB Arjun
has been atop the tournament standings
of course he also played well uh in the
Tata steel rapid a couple of months ago
and here he Ponders his next move in
this incredibly complex position Edition
the English round is nowhere to be seen
he's been taking a long walk around the
tournaments agency trying to take his
mind off of this game like I don't want
to look at my game I want to look at Max
sudlu's game I want to look at anything
except this
yeah it's understandable you know
because whenever I'm playing in this
type of positions I'm always trying to
use that nervous energy to just
something constructive just walk it out
so that when you get to the board he's
back he's uh you're in full Focus mode
and that you can just concentrate what
needs to be done and here it's just
survive protect the king and after all
he is material up so if my math is right
and it's sometimes a bit shaky
but it is it's good
and uh once he does that he has good
piece play
that this game could go in so many
different directions in the next couple
of moves depending on whether Arjun goes
Knight F1 or King H1 so we will keep a
very close eye on this game but before
we move on we have a very important and
exciting announcement to make because
the fide World chefs Championship 2023
has just been announced and it will take
place in the city of Astana in
Kazakhstan from April 7th to May 1st of
this year a new world champion will be
crowned as Jana pamushi and dingly ren
will battle to seize the throne left
vacant by Magnus Carlson's withdrawal
mark your calendars ladies and gentlemen
this is coming right up starting April
7th and ending May 1st the world
championship 2023 has been announced
could we get any more exciting news Yogi
than this yeah that is the most exciting
news actually uh it's incredible I mean
I I knew that an amount announcement was
brewing but I actually didn't have any
predictions as to what country it would
be I actually thought it might be China
but I didn't quite know but uh Astana
Kazakhstan
this is a great venue it will be you
know
they've they've held a lot of
tournaments and also they're everything
they do is with the utmost of
professionalism so I can't wait
and uh yeah and there we see the bird's
eye view can we revisit the game between
Fabiana caruana and Wesley so
because there we saw
just saw fabi's last move and it's a
rick lift
and the ridge has moved itself and uh
what interesting last move also from
Wesley so if we rewind we left the
position
um two moves ago and we see the battle
taking shape because when we left it the
bishop wasn't A6 and we kind of came to
the conclusion that Wesley had one free
move and he's used that free move to
retreat the bishop to relocate it to a
more aggressive diagonal oh
oh I missed Rook B8 uh
so he spent two Tempe on sort of a
reconstruction remodeling of his
position but it's so interesting we were
talking mostly about Knight E4 he used
the E4 Square did Fabiano but he used it
for a rook lift as you pointed out Rook
to E4 makes a lot of sense actually now
that I think about it you want to get it
to H4 and you want to deliver a
Checkmate on h8 but how do you set that
up the point of Bishop C8 not only are
you potentially getting your Bishop to
F5 but from a defensive point of view
you're preventing the queen from
accessing this very important H3 square
and if white only gets two major pieces
on the H file then the bishop does a
great job of holding the fort and
defending the h8 square
yeah there's some ghosts in the air
Daniel because I can see that Rook
swinging over to H4 and okay it doesn't
work but it's there in the atmosphere is
the queen can actually come to F6
and uh plonk herself down a tray give
herself up in order to catch the king in
a mating net so it doesn't quite work
but
well I can see Knight takes Pawn instead
played
well this position is just a cracker
he is indeed who's gonna crash through
okay so so this is so wild so now I mean
I've been saying this a lot and I
completely unexpected turn of events for
me I fully expected this round to be
very calm positional grinds but instead
it's like the players have just
taken something in their coffee and just
come to the games pumped
yeah what did they do during the rest
day maybe some of them visited the some
of the great museums in Amsterdam the
reichs Museum of Van Gogh Museum Maybe
that gave them inspiration but you're
absolutely right this round has been a
barn burner as Fabiano with the scotch
something you don't say every day I mean
I was expecting an Italian or a Berlin
but no that was not the plan for Fabi
and Knight takes C4 is a sign that he's
not he doesn't necessarily believe in
his attack to the point where he will
throw everything to the wind and go
directly for checkmate and as we pointed
out that's because Rook H4 doesn't
actually threaten the immediate rookie
chain and I want to make another point
to piggyback off of uh very insightful
remark you just made white has this very
tempting idea of putting the queen onto
F6 sacrificing it and getting rid of the
bishop the problem with doing that
straight away if instead White had gone
Rook H4 if we could bring up an analysis
board let's say for the sake of argument
the plaque takes on B3 I don't think
that's the best move but the point is
that Queen F6 as good as it looks runs
into Checkmate in one you're weaken
you've opened up the e-file and it's
very hard to stop the move Queen E1 even
if White's Bishop wasn't on F1 Queen E1
would still be mate and two couple that
with the fact that Queen H3 is not
possible and it's hard to progress in a
position like this maybe there was
Knight E4 and so maybe black would have
played Bishop F5 in response to Rook H4
the evil bar is laughing at me obviously
I'm gonna pass the mic to you I'm tired
of getting laughed at here by that evil
part how do you play this position well
it's just not possible
yeah
no this is the thing when you play this
type of Chess I mean it's all going to
be an endurance
um not only about your chest progress
but also your nerves and what tends to
happen is when it's so sharp is that
someone cracks and you'll see a one move
blunder of the horrific kind actually
ones you cannot recover from and that
will just end the game and uh there we
see
Knight takes pawn and then the bishop
does in fact come out to F5
still position is amazingly complicated
I predict that The Rook will move over
to H4 and there is another way for white
to crash through and that would be to
put a rook on H7 and just sacrifice The
Rook for this all-powerful bishop on G7
that's that's also one way but again
it's a not so clear-cut
I just don't see well I don't see an
alternative to Rook H4 first of all I
mean maybe Fabi leaves The Rook on e4
but I don't under quite understand the
function of an exchange sacrifice I'm
very curious what Wesley has in mind
against stroke H4 we shouldn't ignore
the possibility of a check on G5 in some
cases that could force a queen trade
because the last thing you want to do
with white is Slide the cake over to D1
where it's gonna get massacred by a rook
on d8 so
I think there's a non-zero possibility I
mean we see this a good amount in high
level games where you have a super
chaotic middle game and then at some
point the players do play accurately and
you get sort of a mass trade the Queens
get off the board and before you know it
you get liquidation and potentially a
drawn end game not to be anti-climactic
here but we should acknowledge that that
is a possibility
yeah it can fizzle out into a draw but
yeah still there are ways to keep the
Queens on the board you know the Knight
can block the check that you pointed out
and again
still
everything to play for because like you
say you know both sides are highly
dependent on crashing through and as
you've pointed out on numerous occasions
the two Rooks just don't cut it against
this dark squared bishop and if this is
the case then this is a fantastic
defensive effort from Wesley and his
counter-attack will be deadly so oh
I'm I'm in two minds do you go all in
burn your Bridges or do you try to
initiate that Queen trade
oh
it's so hard to say what strategy
fabby's going about now I think Rook H4
Queen G5 check is very likely and I
think we're very likely to see a long
think by Fabiano in that position does
he want to keep the Queens on the board
or the end game could actually end up
being better for white even if the
Queens are off the board it's not like
the h-file attack Fizzles out you still
have ideas of let's say pushing the pawn
up to E6 so
I am just not envious of either player
here they have uh a very difficult task
of managing a position of this of this
magnitude
yeah oh what a crazy game and uh well
can we also revisit let's take a bird's
eye view and uh another game that you
know took our fancy quite early on
because it was just mad was the game
between Mark Parham and Jordan van
Forest
and
well
what happened there because when we left
it he had sacrificed Aram had sacrificed
the peace and Jordan was in trouble has
he managed to wriggle out of danger
not entirely but I actually think he has
improved his position to some extent
let's rewind a little bit after the
peace sacrifice which Jordan accepted as
we predicted Queen D4 was on the board
no way Jose says Jordan event Forest I'm
not touching that end game with a
10-foot Pole C6 by Parham and the eval
bar didn't love that move maybe taking
on C4 would have been better because the
move C6 actually allowed black to
re-sacrifice the Knight very common
defensive technique you sacked the
Knight back four two pawns okay first he
plays Rook d8 he chases the queen of
Anne he's not in a rush to recapture C6
it's not going anywhere and finally on
move 18 he takes it Parham in the
meantime completing his development so
we cannot dispute the white is better
here and White's better for many reasons
I think the main one the main two are
his better central control which
restricts Black's minor pieces and the
presence of the dark squared Bishop
which will entrench itself on this
lovely D4 square and put the heat on
Black's King side but the good news for
Jordan is that he's stable he doesn't
have any obvious weaknesses and Yogi the
biggest thing that worries me about
Parham is this Pawn on A5 that pawn I
mean the path is clear for that pawn and
you cannot fall asleep on it
no that uh Pawn is going to gain in
value the more pieces get traded off for
the time being I think it's should be
okay I mean I don't think parent will be
worried about it too much but uh this
does mean that he is uh in a very
committal situation he has to go forward
with his dark Square bishop and he has
to play on those dark squares
no trades and um
it's difficult to actually recommend a
plan other than just plonking the bishop
on D4 I
don't see anything else to do
no
um
I think the path is pretty clear for
both players here yeah and so well
that's actually a big relief for both
players because the way was very modeled
and it was a deep dark Forest now it's
clear and uh well both sides have their
advantages they've got their cons as
well and hay accounts running on A4
okay
now the big question is how far do you
let it up the board
yeah I'm the ultimate coward no I cannot
cannot live with it on a lot you know
live with it any further better to stop
it on a dark on a light Square so that
you control the dark Square
yeah and you can attack it with a later
Bishop D1 no this is actually a very
difficult dilemma because Rook A3 Rook
fa1 Bishop D1 yeah you can do that but
is it worth that many Tempe Bishop D4 as
we've been talking about looks very very
juicy as well so you could compromise
you could play Bishop D4 maybe after A3
then you're like okay that's enough
that's as far as I'm gonna let it go
maybe you don't compromise and maybe you
let it all the way to A2 I don't think
he's gonna do that though because if the
pawn reaches A2 you can't attack it with
your Bishops that's a very important
point that means that if black defends
that pawn twice that pawn is going to
remain alive as long as black keeps two
heavy pieces on the a file so I think
you're going to see a rook on A2 or on
A3 depending on how black handles this
position
yeah and he does put the bishop in the
center and the Knight will probably
relocate
to where to put it actually because you
kind of feel that if the Knight goes
away to D7 that the black king is
looking suspiciously devoid of any
defense so I I agree with you my
instinct was to put it on E8 first
same I think you have a passive circuit
but yeah
you always have to be thinking about
yeah I think so too
and also 97 looks clumsy it gets in the
way of The Rook so Knights goes to E8
and then let that Knight live a happy
life defending its own King we have this
expression on the tour which makes me
laugh it's like okay a night is a king's
best friend
mm-hmm I didn't know I didn't actually
know this uh until last year and then I
was like wow
like I think just to
yeah I mean the night is the most
underrated Defender I think people think
of the night as a short range piece they
think of the bishop as a good Defender
and the Carolina so game the bishop is a
star Defender but a knight on E8 like
that is it's safe and knights are good
at doing the job that they are assigned
you tell that night I want you to defend
G7 Knight is a king's best friend it's
going to sit loyally on E8 as long as
you needed to be there and nitrage is
good at defending particular weaknesses
so the big choice for Jordan is whether
he plays 98 immediately or is he push
the pawn one square further allowing
white potentially to ruin his Pawn
structure on the king side which I don't
think Parham is going to do because the
bishop is the pride of his position so
just a very rich situation Parham
definitely with the upper hand but
Jordan I think doing a good good job of
keeping practical chances alive now
before we go on our second break of the
day there's one more game that we need
to quickly look at we haven't looked at
it yet uh and that is the game between
gookesh and report which is already in
an end game so we are going to dive
straight into that game for a little
while
and we have a very interesting Pawn
structure in that game but largely a an
end game that looks balanced to me yovi
yeah
um yeah good cash and Richard report
supporters will have to forgive us
because this game looks very balanced as
you say I mean it looks like a very
typical grunfeld end game where black
has this uh Pawn Advance upon majority
on the queen side and is holding White's
full majority in the middle of the board
I think black is doing fine
um he has good pieces for his squares he
challenges the control over the c-line
um in fact if I were to prefer someone I
in fact would prefer black I would say
black is slightly better just on account
of all the long-term possibilities and
advantages you get from having that
outside past born
agreed completely and another thing you
should always test in these positions is
what happens if all the Rooks disappear
and if all the works disappear then the
magnitude the weight of Black's Pawn
majority obviously outweighs what white
has whatever chaos white has on the king
side because there's a very clear path
to creating a past bond with a6b5 and if
all that white has left are minor pieces
then you might not just that you might
not have the resources to both contain
the past pawn and let's say keep your
king side defended so I'm on the same
page not only has reports solved all of
the problems posed by gukesh in the
opening but he sits very pretty with an
hour 22 on this clock and a really
comfortable ending him I think he's
going to make a serious push to try to
win this end game Yogi yeah definitely
um actually Richard is uh known as a
creative player but he's also fantastic
in the end game in fact I would almost
say that it's better strength he's
actually stronger in the end game than
he is out of the opening or the in his
creativity because I've seen him just
display amazing technique when it comes
to the stage of the game you know just
grinding things out and uh he has
sometimes uh Richard a negative mind
frame but I think that this suits him in
the this type of
scam game and this type of stage because
he's just looking at what his opponent
does and he stops IT and again you know
he's not excited by the bigger picture
he's just simply looking at these mini
plans improving his pieces one by one
and I do remember that these two played
a very heartbreaking game on the chat on
the tour and uh good cash was defending
a rook against uh Richard's rook and
Bishop and we thought it was just a draw
in the bag and then Richard won
at the very last minute I mean it was
incredible and uh there we can see
gakash move his Rook to the open line
um what do we think about kukash's play
so far and own the tournament overall
it's been a little bit lackluster I mean
again everything has to be spoken with a
grain of salt here because we're only
four rounds in agukesh of course coming
off a a ridiculous performance at the
Olympiad a couple months ago where he
started eight out of eight but sometimes
when a young player has a performance
like that we build up chess fans like to
build up unreasonable expectations why
isn't he four out of four in this
tournament you know he's languishing at
the bottom of the tournament standing oh
he's made some draws he has had a slow
start but his opponents are incredibly
strong and bukesh at age 16. let me
repeat that h16 making his first
appearance in tata 2023 he's actually
the only player in the masters section
who for whom this is the first Tata
appearance so let's give gukesh you know
a little bit of a pass so far he's
Gathering experience he's stabilizing at
his rating and sometimes there are some
Growing Pains associated with being a
new player at this level
yeah and it's also it's not really his
fault that he's been the victim of two
brilliances you know I mean first of all
he played ding you know and ding played
a superb game and of course who can
forget uh Anish Gary's amazing novelty
in the regos in in game two I mean that
was just incredible and I don't I I
wouldn't really
I don't really fault him for stumbling
there because it was a very fresh idea
it was a sharp position and yeah okay he
he made a mistake and that happened to
cost him the game and uh he's managed to
stabilize since then two draws very
combative drawers as well and one thing
that really impressed me about gukesh is
that uh I mean he gave an interview
after Bill
and he said that uh he knew he knows
that in this type of situation the most
important thing is to not change the
personality uh if you're inclined to
attack your opponent go for the king
stick to your true nature don't change
just because you're losing in the
tournament or you're winning in the
tournament just stay true to your colors
especially if you're a younger player
who's trying to gain experience you
don't want to do anything too drastic as
you're saying just because you lost one
game and of course losing to Anish
gearing in that fashion there's
absolutely no shame in that and there is
also no shame in continuing to fill our
coffee cups and continuing to enjoy this
lovely fifth round of Tata steel 2023 we
hope you are enjoying the coverage
ladies and gentlemen and as we look at
the pensive expression on Richard
reports Facebook you can't even see his
face he's got his hands over his head
just a beautiful view right there of
gukesh against the report folks we will
have more coverage and more action for
you from the 2023 Tata steel when we
return in just a couple of minutes
[Music]
foreign
dude it's impossible to not hear you
just breathing super loudly okay fine I
will hold my breath for three minutes
all right let's go okay let's go right
now just clock up right here almost
there and you did it
what can you do for three minutes my
wife says not a lot but I can plank keep
that big butt down dude nice
two one you did it wow I feel better oh
yeah oh you were timing me yeah you were
in there for 30. oh man let's play some
chess and get some dinner let's do it
time lapse yeah okay you bring a clock
oh I left my clock at home dude you
idiot I told you to bring it let's just
go get something to eat okay
download the new chess.com clock app so
you can time yourself playing chess or
whatever other dumb stuff you and your
friends do
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
steel chest 2023 not a very recognizable
player on the camera in front of us yovi
I don't know why our camera operator is
just panning out to random audience
members
long hair don't care
um yeah of course that is world champion
Magnus Carlson who is chasing his ninth
tatter steel title that actually sounds
incredibly insane I say out loud he's
won the tournament eight times
like hello God level and uh he's looking
to break his 2900 rating he made that
announcement when uh last year I think
and uh of course it was a bit difficult
actually to achieve and he's kind of
publicly said later on that he's relaxed
on that goal and that his whole aim is
actually just to get better and better
and uh talking about getting better and
better I mean if we just to have a quick
look at the state of play right now we
see what on Earth has happened because
when we left it the position was
relatively calm I mean but the position
has taken a turn for the unpredictable
how did we get here like Magnus is
exchanged down
this game has had so many
Transformations both strategic and
tactical first you had the Strategic
transformation where black white
demolishes black center and gets this
positional advantage and we were
expecting a slow burn you know middle
game end game where Carlson's gonna put
on his normal squeeze but no let's
rewind three moves Notre back playing
Bishop F6 here and like any normal human
Carlson plays Rook B1 in the game
continues no he doesn't he plays Bishop
to A3 sacrificing the exchange for
essentially one reason only of course of
course he's getting rid of the dark
squared Bishop but mainly the bishop on
A3 slices Off The f8 Square preventing
black from castling kingside Carlson is
hoping to keep this King in the center
where it's a stable Target it is not a
stable Target no Rebecca goes the other
way says you're not letting me go King
side no problem I'm gonna go to the
queen side and Carlson immediately
marshalling his forces with the move
Rook C1 ignoring the possibility of
Queen takes G7 which it occurred to me
would have opened up the G5 on maybe
given black some attacking chances
instead Carlson is going to focus all of
his efforts on the queen side and on
pressuring the Knight on C6 what a wild
position yo it's like every game
I don't know what the players have had
for breakfast or in their coffee as you
say
I don't know they're definitely drinking
something and uh I'm in okay I mean it's
a position that is very easy to get
excited about but let's be a bit
cold-blooded here I mean is this enough
for the exchange so I mean madness's
last move makes a lot of sense you know
lining up The Rook against the queen and
king and uh let's have a look if like
the king just side steps away from
trouble puts itself on B8 soon to be
headed to the corner of the board and
what does Magnus have up his sleeve I
mean is it enough for instance
yeah there you go
and uh now I was kind of wondering
whether Magnus should hedge his bets and
actually capture the pawn or whether he
should just go all in and put the Knight
on D4 as you mentioned earlier
let's pop an announce board here yeah I
was just what's your intuition say
my intuition is basically hedge your
bets
don't take big risks I mean it depends
on the mood but most of the time I'm
just like okay I'll capture some pawns
you know disrupt the pawn structure
there on the king side and after all you
can fight against Black's activity Rook
activity by putting the queen on a
well-timed square to guard against
Bishop h3s in fact maybe bishop H3 is no
longer a threat
so yeah I mean the problem with Knight
to D4 is that you know if we were to
rewind one move
what happens next I mean I don't quite
see where white is going with this
because roccosa to C8 and yeah okay
maybe the black king gets opened but
there aren't a whole lot of minor pieces
or pieces full stop to attack the black
king
so
can't get it up here um
no certainly not and the key will just
hide itself away on A8 and then it will
use all the you know all its forces the
Queen the two Rooks whatever it can to
protect it and then when you when the
tide has uh finally turned then it'll be
black who will be winning that so
on a practical level I would say grab
the pawn
but that's because
I like to play intuitively
I agree what about you Daniel oh okay
but with one caveat the one thing I
couldn't take my eyes off after Queen
takes G7 is this possibility of Rook HD
G8 and this sets a nasty little trap you
might say what is black doing just
taking more pawns and then there's Rook
takes G2 check
and if King takes G2 you run into a very
pretty Discovery against White's Queen
Bishop H3 and The Queen Is Lost so
after Rook G8 white would have to find
alternate arrangements for the queen but
the queen could really get tossed around
here if you play Queen F6 there's maybe
a rook G6 so maybe this is the kind of
thing that Magnus was worried about
because
um I don't know he's taking his time
he's not grabbing that pawn immediately
perhaps you could take the pawn on H7
here and continue gobbling just gobble
the other Pawn but now well you've got
to watch for that Bishop H3 move we
pointed out earlier maybe black will try
to get the bishop over not to C5 no
Bishops don't move like that but over to
D5 so it it's it's a position that's
virtually impossible for a human to
evaluate and when a position's
impossible to evaluate Yogi in my
experience it generally means the
evaluation is 0.0 and I think that
theory is proven here as you see the Evo
bar is just like what are you talking
about this is as equal as it gets but
yeah I would say I would say
Nursery yeah I have to I have to say I
would also hasten um I would taste into
ad about grabbing pawns I would grab one
Pawn but I perhaps wouldn't be grabbing
um grabby that's a that's a word
um
and take on H7 because I'm actually I'm
doing Black's job for them you know the
whole point of having Rooks is to put
them on open lines and by grabbing both
their G pawn and H Pawn then basically
you're opening those lines and uh yeah
improving the quality of the Rooks so I
would grab one and then not the other
one but uh yeah on the board
yeah went ahead and prepare for that
Queen to be kicked around yeah I I would
bet my house that Magnus would not fall
for that trick you know that lovely
trick that you you highlighted
I would as well maybe we'll both end up
without homes
yeah
but I yeah it's going to be interesting
so it hang on let's be kind of concrete
about this so if the Rook comes and
attacks the queen
let's take a vote should he capture on
H7 my instinct was like no no no no
don't do that but uh
is that uh is it possible to be so
greedy because in this day and age
people just say hang on don't play by
principles play by concrete calculation
so can you do it Rook hd8 Queen taste
porn and then say
I loved your idea by the way of playing
Bishop E6 and Bishop D5 that was
terrifying yeah there's a lot of
possible Bishop Maneuvers now there is a
good Russian expression uh as as we
examine Rook hd8 that is suitable here
which is having said a you have to say B
and it obviously means that once you've
engaged in something risky you know
there's a sun cost effect you might as
well continue in the same line after
Rook G8 Queen takes H7
the other move which worries me on
White's behalf is Bishop E6 a bishop D7
to G4 what does it accomplish well it
obviously threatens to take the Knight
using the pin on the G file now you
might say well this is not a problem the
Knight is the D4 square but you can see
the eval bar shooting all the way down
why because now the queen gets tossed
around further but the problem isn't
that the queen is attacked is that white
suddenly loses the pawn on H2 that's so
easy to forget about and Knight takes C6
check doesn't do anything black just
recaptures with the pawn and then a
beautiful mate to boot after Queen E4
bang bang and bang the bishop on G4
blocks the king's Escape so this could
get white could fall off a cliff here in
the span of two moves yovi so that's a
counter argument uh against taking on H7
the argument for taking on H7 is that if
you're already there as I said you might
as well get your money's worth
yeah we have that saying too in in the
UK in for the penny in for the pound
exactly and uh I I love it okay so uh
yeah so how do you react to the bishop
coming yeah what are you actually doing
I mean to not lose exactly
I don't know Queen drops back to E4
natural one
yeah and then they also have moves like
uh Bishop takes Knight Let's uh remind
ourselves of that uh checks captures and
threats and then after Pawn takes then
we can come back to E4 ah that is
actually a very nice point because if
black plays F5 here
what is the point about five the point
is to dislodge the queen so that you can
take on F3 but here you have the check
on B4 this is a very important internet
so it allows you to move the Knight away
and then Rook 8 shade is is not as
effective because white is the time to
defend the pawn on H2 speak of the devil
notabeck has just played Rook hdga not a
lot of time on his clock so I love the
fact that he played that move quickly
that takes some guts to do against the
world champion comes back to our
conversation about young players just
not fearing the top guys I think 10
years ago somebody in Notre back shoes
would have taken 20 minutes and try to
work out all the details but the Uzbek
Grand Master he trusts his intuition as
he gets up from the board when an alpha
move right there and let's rewind back
to the live position after Rook HD
yeah and we're gonna see whether Magnus
captures that pawn on age seven and
talking about Alpha moves did you catch
any of Magnus carlsen's uh Alpha moves
at the world Blitz Championship I mean
the one that Springs to mind was when he
turned up two and a half minutes late I
mean it wasn't his fault he's got 30
seconds left on his clock and he just
starts adjusting his pieces I mean how
cool is that unbelievable flustered
so I have 30 seconds I'll start with 20
who cares
and then he crushes Cavalier crushes him
yeah I I was a bit surprised anyway
anyway it was uh it was a moment of
Chess history and afterwards I remember
the Norwegian TV grilled him on that
they were like what is that all about
and uh yeah Magnus this one yeah I just
wanted to mess with his mind
and so he did I mean it was a one-sided
game and my coach many many years ago I
had a game where my opponent came 58
minutes late in the in the US the rule
is if you come an hour late you forfeit
the game so I was already basically
tallying up my first point I was about
to sign the score sheet my opponent
comes running in this is the first round
of a tournament and I got totally
destroyed I got whites off the board and
afterward my opponent said well there's
an old Soviet you know if your opponent
comes an hour late you just wait an hour
on the first move because it's actually
psychologically very difficult in many
cases to play with an extra hour on the
clock because you feel like you have to
win easily but there's just something
very disconcerting about it so he said
in the old days the opponent came 30
minutes late you would just take
whatever amount of time on the first
move to level up the playing field and
make it easier on yourself because you
moderate the expectations in any case
Cavalia didn't do that because that was
a Blitz game
wow I never heard that piece of advice
before I have heard or stories about
bronstein who used to take ages to make
moves and once he spent 22 minutes uh
playing for the Soviet Union uh on his
opening move and his teammates were like
what are you doing why are you doing
this in front of me
I mean he was very unpopular
it's a complicated position you've got
20 options got to consider the candidate
moves
yes okay imagine that yeah I can mean
yeah what other position do you have the
option to move pawns or your pawns
forward
um yeah absolutely and uh yeah Magnus
considering whether to grab that pawn
we kind of come to the conclusion that
he he should get greedy he should be
brave but it is a very dramatic decision
to make because somehow you feel like it
is fighting against the um principles of
the board you know
basically open up lines for the Rooks
in
the possibility of mags losing two games
in a row is a discussion that has been
opened after he sacrificed the exchange
this is not just the three result game
this is like aggressively a three result
game where a single mistake
by either side but more so by white I
think the cost of a mistake uh something
that was also taught to me who loses
more in the event of a mistake okay
black has the extra exchange so it
almost seems like it's safer to be black
here and Carlson he's already writing a
loss against Gary his confidence might
have been shaken just a little bit and
this is not what he wants to get I
changed my tune Yogi he started off
really well risk-free position but that
exchange sacrifice I don't think he's
gotten what he's looking for I think he
was thinking of mating black in romantic
fashion but a hunter has kind of become
the hunted here
yeah and uh I have to say yeah
Magnus losing two games in a row
have we ever seen that before has that
ever happened in tournament history
I have a feeling he did and he came back
and he won some
in a row he probably did but that's
about as frequent as like a Haley's
Comet sighting
yeah once every 75 years
um
but I know it was once like six years
foreign
I was into astronomy when I was a kid
and then at this point everyone's going
to tell me no you're wrong it is not 75
years but anyway
um okay so let's go back and uh let's
have a Wonder around the boards because
we are now in the Midway Point play is
really heating up and the position that
I'm most fascinated about is uh Eric icy
against ding Loren because when we left
it it was just again an insane position
open King it wasn't very clear who was
attacking who and uh Arjun had
sacrificed the pawn
but had the initiative I mean how is the
situation now well go to that board in a
second I will just quickly point out
that the carwana cell game has indeed
it's fizzled out into an end game it's a
very complicated end game so it ain't
just a draw but um the Queens are off
the board so it's safe to say neither
side will get checkmated and uh over on
the top right Anish has a slight
Advantage I think against Prague we will
examine those end games in two course
but I am on the same page we have to go
to the arag icy ding game because this
game just continues to get more and more
tense with every move H3 your idea from
earlier trying to smash into Black's
protective Pawn cover it's not a very
safe protective Pawn cover because in
the event of GH3 Queen H5 there is the
threat of Queen takes G6 I think that's
out of the question UV I think black has
to try to keep this Pawn alive and the
only way that I see for black to do that
is to lift the queen up to G5 but the
queen isn't the best defender because of
how vulnerable it is and queen G5 well
it runs into h before it runs into some
F4 ideas of white moves the king there's
even some cute tactics related to taking
twice on G4 and forking on H6 the
problem there is that the bishop and the
queen are going to be connected so it
doesn't quite work immediately what do
you think Arjun has in mind against
Queen G5
uh I have to say I I think Queen G5 is
the best defensive move yeah Queen some
uh great attackers but they're also
fantastic fantastic Defenders primarily
because they're so powerful
um I wouldn't be so worried if I were
black with uh the pawn attacking the
queen with H4 because then the tension
has disappeared in the position and then
I think the queen can just drop back one
square to F6 and providing it doesn't
hang anything and it doesn't and I think
it's it's fine and then he can go about
just uh kicking back White's Knight or
from F5 and the moves that I would be
concerned about would be just keeping
the tension open I mean is it is it
possible to do that some like Bishops
attacking
yeah that's what I was thinking but then
I I suddenly forgot that there are two
players playing the game and yes the
queen is the queen queen coming to G4
was a nice defensive move but it's also
a nice counter-attacking move because
you do have ideas of H4 on the board and
if you can get that to work followed by
G3 that is going to be dangerous
oh and the reason H4 doesn't work
immediately I that move completely
escaped me is because if we bring up an
analysis board here there's the
beautiful queen takes G4 and again one
of the story lines of this game is that
Bishop on B3 constantly x-raying the F7
Bond H takes G3 bang and of course bang
goes the dynamite there's mate on G7 so
Queen G5 is kind of necessary and I
agree I think white needs to take this
opportunity to close off the king side
or once again the hunter will become the
hunt in and after Queen F6 you could
play Bishop C2 but I really would want
to keep the bishop on this diagonal so
maybe Queen C2 is a more harmonious way
of positioning White's pieces and the
game would calm down a little bit yovi
if they got this position in the sense
that the tension on the king side has
dried up a little bit and I think white
has full compensation for the pawn
beautiful Knight he still has this idea
of rerouting the other night potentially
to E3 and it's just hard for black to
move I mean Bishop E6 maybe but then
you've got to worry about the B7 Pawn so
if Arjun has done his due diligence then
not only has he examined the actual
moves but he should also be familiar
with the typical ideas in this early
middle game and that's really what
concerns me if I'm dingley run
yeah
um so I agree with you
I think there's so much dynamism in the
position and one thing I wanted to point
out was that Black's Knight on H7 what a
terrible piece I mean it's a great
defender but it's just standing there
doing nothing I mean it's completely
dominated by The Pawn on H4
and that is going to give compensation
for the pawn uh I agree with you Arjun
has to know the path to attack I mean he
can't have just planned this particular
opening without knowing what to do next
and it's something that I've been
working on with my coach you know I show
him these promising lines and he goes
yeah very good very good how are you
going to continue I'm like oh let me
consult my computer and he's like no no
no
you've got to have an answer right now
and then okay next time I'll come better
prepared totally Echo your point we've
all had experiences of really good
preparation then we hit the first move
outside the prep and you know I actually
forgot to understand the position we all
understand everything perfectly we've
got stockfish running in the background
the moment you switch the engine off
you're basically stuck at C but one
player who is most definitely not lost
at sea and feels himself right at home
amongst the elite is Arjun aragaisy this
is arjun's very first Elite top
tournament in classical and he is pumped
about it we have a really lovely
portrait to share with you where Arjun
Sheriff's thoughts on how he will
approach this brutal Master section
after running through the challengers
last year let's listen into Grand Master
Arjun era geisi
so it's definitely going to be a lot
stronger and a lot more challenging and
there was a lot of top players and this
is my first tournament playing amongst
the elite In classical so I look forward
and I'm very excited to be honest I
don't think it changes anything
particularly to me but it's nice to have
a Spectators watching chess
I am quite used to playing rapid Blitz
in general even the pandemic I used to
play a lot of Blitz online so
always used to and classical is
something that's been there since years
since basically when I started playing
chess so at the moment it's not so
difficult to adjust someone format to
another
oh like the fact that there's a so many
Spectators watching and and they
cheerful chefs not just for me but just
their vouchers and chess is getting more
attraction that feels great
see ladies and gentlemen I mean such a
professional so why is beyond his years
and obviously having totally stabilized
at a 2700 plus level playing in his very
first Elite tournament Yogi what stood
out to you about uh arjun's interview
just now
how calm and softly spoken he is I mean
he's he comes across as so humble and
yet we know how dangerous he is over the
chessboard and he talks a lot about how
he's able and he's confident in his
abilities to switch between classical
rapid and Blitz format and how he enjoys
them all and how he just loves the game
and then that's very very much clear and
so one thing that we know actually if he
told us during the Champions chess tour
um was that he actually has
um someone to help him a performance
expert to help him get ready mentally
for these type of tournaments and he has
a very good family Network they're
they're helping him they're motivating
him if he's down they just say a few
words to him and he immediately can pick
himself up and you do need that strong
Network behind you if you're going to
reach the top levels
it takes a village I mean you don't
succeed at this level without a vast
support network that includes friends
and coaches and it's important to point
out that arjun's performance in the
Challenger section last year came
without Spectators because of the
lockdown uh restrictions this time our
Spectators we see them in the screen in
front of us and of course Arjun also has
tens if not hundreds of thousands of
fans watching back home in India
watching his every move and cheering him
on the chess environment in India is
just so wholesome it's so fun to watch
how many fans there are of this new crop
of Indian Talent nihal Arjun gukash two
of them playing in this tournament such
an exciting time to be a fan of uh of
young Indian players so they've got such
a bright future love art love me some
art generic icy and he's putting the
heat on dangly Wren here in the early
going of this game
yeah he certainly is putting ding under
pressure and uh going back to your point
about India I mean it's just
experiencing such a significant chess
boom I mean it's completely unheard of I
mean every week or so it appears that
there's a new Indian Grandmaster I think
we have 76 at the minute and and if you
compare that to how the situation
situation was a few years ago I mean
it's a massive explosion in chess and
having played in the Olympiad last year
and today it was absolutely shocking and
overwhelming
um emotionally actually how many chess
supporters there were I mean the
Olympiad was just full of people coming
to visit and just coming to chair on the
superstars and just loving the game
never seen anything quite like it and it
was very very special
wow that must have been the trip of left
and was it your first time in India
it was my second time in India but uh it
was the first time experiencing a chess
like this you know where we were like
Superstars and we would come out and
they were like autograph autograph and
they knew who I was and they knew who
everyone was and they asked me how I did
and they had thoughts on my game I mean
it was incredible I I love that actually
that chess is working its way up in the
national rankings and we also saw I
think
um
Arjun recently got a huge sponsorship
deal right I think he did yeah that that
rings the bell for me as well
yeah I wasn't sure which one got the
sponsorship deal but I think it was Era
guys he got one million dollars so I
mean huge amount of money and for the
next three years and this will of course
level up his game even more
it will indeed not have had a bad deal
at all and as ding continues to ponder
this punishingly complex situation let's
swing back to the bird's eye view and
you know our job as commentators is
obviously to look at the most
interesting games we also have to look
at the most significant games and one
game that we've uh kind of let sail for
a couple of moves is Prague against
Geary so there's crazy stuff happening
in Van Forest game Magnus continues to
ponder the situation after Rook HGH
that's top left of your screen but you
always shall we take a dip into the
Geary pool and just see if he actually
has any winning chances in that end game
yeah and uh first of all just indulge me
I just wanted to know we left an offer
in the late stages of the opening how
did the game continue
so there was a you called it first of
all let's let's go to that game and
Rewind uh the tape 10 moves or so after
Knight takes D4 Geary did indeed play
Queen D7 great call by you Prague
trading the Knights moving his Queen up
trading the Bishops getting his Rook
into the game but the reason that trade
favored black is because of that f file
so Geary starts piling up the pieces and
threatening naichi for Brock thought
great time to get the Queens off the
board and of course that diminishes
Black's attacking chances on the f file
but what it does not diminish is Black's
positional Advantage Gary getting his
Knight to a beautiful Square
and securing the Knight with a classic
G7 G5 but not for attacking purposes but
uh to prevent to take the sting out of
f4 and now the Knight has moved back to
C6 attacking this new weakness that
Prague has created on A5
uh this is not the most Pleasant end
game that I've seen I think black might
be a tiny bit better but Anish giri
showing his willingness to repeat moves
Sophie as I say that
oh this is the modern way of playing
chess you repeat the position twice and
then you play something different you
know you keep them hanging but uh I have
to say I prefer Black's position because
just taking a look at that pawn
structure I'm looking at the pawn on A5
I'm thinking this could be a liability
and the reason I'm saying this I'm being
very very bold is because I'm kind of
getting flashbacks to a particular
opening that I'm very familiar with with
the caracon main line and often you'll
see white have a Pawn on H5 and this
Pawn on H5 in this case A5 it's either a
hero or it's just a villain I mean it's
either gonna cost white the game because
it's a liability it's a weakness it will
tie down a rook you don't necessarily
want a rope to find Singapore
or it would be a lovely clamp in which
case you know white will get C4 B4 B5
and the ability to create a pass Pawn on
the a line so I'm kind of intrigued
about this very small detail
it looks like I'm just like quibbling
over over little things but it's I find
it fascinating and my understanding is
especially when it comes to these type
of endings is like you've got to be
careful you with Pawn pushes you've got
to judge them correctly can you back
them up because if you can't they're
just weak yeah and you mentioned little
things but little things combine to make
big things and in these types of end
games with symmetrical material you have
to focus on the little things so Prague
with a very interesting dilemma here
there is a case to be made for just
playing Rook D4 immediately and saving
time the time control is generous but
there are only 20 moves in and Prague
with less than 40 minutes but there's an
equally strong case to be made I think
for a move like Knight C1 and D3 I think
if I can get the knights off the board
it'll be harder for black black won't
have the Machinery to attack the A5 Pawn
quite as easily and you mentioned hero
or villain one way in which the pawn
could be a hero is that it halts the
progress of the beep on it fixes the
weakness much like the pawn on H5 and
the Karo Khan weakens the G7 Pawn so
with the Knights off the board I think
the pawn might become a strength but
Prague kind of looking up into the skies
Beth Harmon style let's see what he's
going to decide and speaking of Prague
prog's confidence has been amazing he
just defeated dingley ran with the black
pieces uh we've got a great little
segment here as Prague shares his
thoughts on His Brilliant win against
England in the last round let's listen
in
I think we both were making
um some mistakes uh during
the second time control
um yeah we both were down two seconds
and I don't think my technique was good
but okay it's it's not uh it's not all
easy to find the correct moves in the
same game because there are so many
options and uh it's not
um easy to calculate everything yeah I
think he just missed uh I don't know
what he missed maybe after D5
um
um that after D5 I have 90 Sun maybe he
missed that one
um but I think already I'm I'm kind of
uh taking over there
um but yeah after 40th month I was
clearly better this King G6 King Hy was
quite important but after that yeah I
was getting throughout meaning
okay prognananda ladies and gentlemen
sharing his thoughts on that win against
staying you'll be beating ding of the
black pieces at his age at his
experience level I mean talk about
Talent talk about grit talk about
confidence Prague espouses all of these
skills and a lot more so exciting to
watch as he makes his way to 2700 isn't
he
yeah that's just a question of time I
mean it's certainly gonna happen and
what I love about this video is that
you know it to me if you were just to
look at him right here right now you
would not be able to tell whether he's
won or lost
and uh I I just admire that composure as
someone who gets very excited and gets
very nervous at times you know the fact
that he's able just to say okay no big
emotions when he beats Ding and just to
kind of accept that this is a tournament
of 13 Rounds there's no place for big
emotions instead it's just to take
things as it comes and I also like the
fact that he later said that he was
going to try football for the first time
well and uh
this is European here that's kind of
unheard of because everyone has played
football at one point in their lives but
yeah Prague way to go love it there we
can see a picture of the players playing
football and the free day and then we
see ding who apparently uh scored a
penalty actually uh I heard that the
score was 3-3
and magma scored two good two goals and
ding took the penalty uh very impressive
wow look at that let me see
oh
yeah
I'm mesmerized I'm just anytime I see
these top players on like the sports
field I'm like wow you know it's like
that feeling when you like are in second
or third grade and you see your teacher
at the grocery store and you're like you
know Mrs Seligman buys groceries she's
not always in the classroom kind of the
same effect here I think people in the
track can relate to that you see dingley
around on the soccer field scoring some
goals these flares are multi-talented
yeah they are multi-talented
and I'm glad that you called your
teacher by Mrs or Miss because they're
annoyed they do not they call them by
their first names and I think that
there's something wrong there really
okay yeah I remember something funny
yeah go ahead
no because you remember that Joy you
felt when you've discovered your
teacher's first name you know it was
like you've discovered a secret and uh
the Norwegians
the wages are not down for that they
don't like the formality
that's interesting although yeah I
remember my fourth grade PE teacher uh
one of my classmates called him Jason by
his first name and he was not having he
said if you do that again you're kicked
out of the kicked out of the class so
interesting uh change in approach
and we will see what approach
prognananda takes in this position but
it's a good time to get into football
the players are not in Wake On day to
day they are in the beautiful city of
Amsterdam Amsterdam playing from the
Johann Cruyff Arena the home of the IX
football team I'm going to pretend that
I knew what that team was before you
mentioned it before the show I'm gonna
pretend to be a knowledgeable European
because I want people to keep watching
the show
yeah I I must admit I I just knew the
name and that was it and uh the Johann
cries arena is where they're playing
from but Magnus is a big football fan uh
of course you know he I think during the
first round he went or maybe before the
tournament started he went to see iax
play in the stadium and of course who
can forget that Magnus is fantastic at
Fantasy Football and uh he was
at the top of the leaderboard I can
remember that I don't think he finished
at the top I think he came second or
third that is impressive considering the
whole wide world is playing fantasy
football poker football basketball
Sports I mean Magnus he has so many
interests in so many talents and
speaking of talents and games let's go
back to the bird's eye view I am pretty
hell-bent on traveling to a particular
game I'm gonna put you on the spot here
which game do you think is catching my
eye
um
I was if I would say that is the game oh
hang on a second well Magnus and Abdus
that caught my eye for a split second
but it's between it's a toss-up between
Arjun eragisi and dingler in those two
games are really doing something for me
but uh was I right I kind of cheated so
that's second in command Arjun against
Diggs since we looked at that uh pretty
recently I'm actually looking at the van
Forest game
because you have a situation that's to
the right side of your screen where the
Rook on E1 is x-raying the queen on e4
so I'm actually just wondering if white
has a forced win in that position so
shall we take a quick look and yeah
definitely on that game
absolutely
and uh it's not often that you see a
black Pawn on A3 either so everything is
happening here so okay let's work it out
so as you pointed out the bishop can
move and attack the queen and uh skewer
the queen and Bishop
oh but everything is going on so hang on
a second resources does it happen you do
have Queen takes oh I'm getting bogged
down in in the analysis
Bishop H5
ah you want to take this H5
yeah there's the bishop takes uh C4
that's option I'm trying to because when
I have these complicated positions I try
to run through the whole checks captures
and attacks and uh first of all I was
drawn to Bishop F6
but then I kind of saw Queen takes pawn
and I'm gonna put that one on the back
burner for now and then I'm like hey the
bishop can actually capture the pawn on
C4
you know pulling up for grabs the issue
there I think is Queen takes her let's
bring up an analysis board to examine
the possible candidate moves Bishop C4 I
think the problem is Queen takes E1 and
if you think about this position that
Knight is the hero and that a pawn moves
up to A2 so given what Max Zulu had
earlier I feel like this wouldn't appeal
to him but my burning question is how
black escapes after Bishop H5 because in
the event of Queen D3 the queen has
trapped and it's not the end of the
story you could argue that black could
play A2 but with only a rook for the
queen white absolutely has to be winning
and also note that after CD white can
always play C4 and just really control
that promotion square with two of his
pieces so if Bishop H5 happens it
appears to me that black has to take on
G2 and bail out into a piece down end
game
this has to be lost for black it's not
completely lost the Knight could get
back into the action but you'll be at
the very least I think this gives white
great winning chances am I am I missing
something there
let's rewind because the position is
just insanely complex because we can't
forget about the possibility of using
Hydra there on the A-line
um so Bishop H5
I'm sorry I do like my fairy tales and
Greek myths and Roman myths or whatever
okay so the first thing that I'm
thinking of is could you do something
funky like A2 that's uh
and then try to
yeah it's a bit weird
and wonderful
if you promote I take take and go walk
to E1 so you have to take on e4 yeah and
then Rook A1 and then Rook B8 not the
end of the story just yet you're
threatening Rook B1
butts butts but but what can I do with
white here
gosh this is this is just a mind you
know what this is oh
that word has come to mind so many times
and I've been like I was I almost said
it I actually almost that would have
been the end of my commentating group
and I came pretty close to letting it
slip by accident
I don't see a move oh you have to block
the B file probably with Bishop to B6
you have to just stick that Bishop right
right in the rook's face
Rook A6 get out of here no I'm getting
rid of Hydra on A2 right here no more
Hydra I slayed that I slayed the Dragon
yeah
and what do you make of this position
totally winning probably not but
definitely we're talking about two
results here
yeah we're all talking to your results I
mean the queen is such a powerful piece
that yeah
she will have a good shot at massaging a
victory that
um okay so that was quite a fascinating
line where white was just like riding on
the edge with some only moves I mean is
there any reason any way that we can
kind of refine this idea of pushing well
it's quite a brutal idea of pushing the
a pawn
yeah I mean that's the big question
let's rewind back to the live position
here for a moment just to update
everybody we are discussing the move
Bishop to H5 and the reason the bishop
should stay on this diagonal is because
what Bishop takes C4 we already examined
that gives black a good version of the
queen sack if you play Bishop to D1
instead you're giving the queen an
escape Square on B1 so H5 is actually
the only score on this diagonal that
enables white to keep control of all of
the Queen's potential Escape squares I
think that if black is to sacrifice the
Queen the only way to do it you know is
just to push A2 because Queen takes C1
ends up losing a Tempo compared to that
line maybe you could also stick the
queen on D3 and then play A2 but we've
already been through that line if the
pawn disappears from C4 white has the
possibility of C4 and one more thing
just this has been a burning thought
since you mentioned Hydra you know what
the real reference is in my mind when
the word is mentioned it's do you
remember the chess computer Hydra that
faced Michael Adams in 2005 yeah ring a
bell
it does that was a white wash for poor
Mickey yeah I don't think anybody
remembers that the young members of the
chat there was a match between Mickey
Adams and the super computer which was
built specifically for the occasion of
the match and then disassembled what was
called Hydra I was obsessed with that
match I mean as a impressionable
ten-year-old who was just finding out
how good chess computers could be it's
like Michael Adams I mean he's top of
the top and he's just getting hammered
by this engine it's a crazy crazy match
definitely not Michael Adams best
showing but I think that really marked
the start Yogi after deep blue of
engines unfortunately showing us how
mortal we are
yeah definitely and now we use them as
training buddies so I guess we've got
the last laugh they they play their own
little 1000 game tournaments
um yeah so oh so fascinating
A2 Bishop H5
we're going to see it because uh your uh
Parham is going to get there by a
process of elimination and yeah we're
probably gonna see
A2 you know unless he's gonna flick in
Queen D3 but yeah I mean somehow are the
Whites pieces are perfectly placed to
deal with this apron just one of Life's
a Happy coincidences
it is indeed and you're right process of
elimination I don't think there are any
other appealing moves if you toss out
Bishop takes C4 so we will keep you
posted on parham's Choice when he makes
it and he should make it pretty soon
he's got 27 minutes on the clock now
before we update you on some of our
other fascinating battles here in round
five of Tata steel we wanted to remind
you of something very important because
the wait is over and after a two-year
Hiatus the pro chess league is back the
2023 season begins with a qualifier week
starting February the 1st with 16 teams
advancing into the main season as BCL
participants include weak players like
Magnus Carlson dingliran John neponishi
Fabi Karo and viel and Anish that's
basically it so we could not be more
excited for the League's return and with
over 100 G's on the line it's looking
like the 2023 season will be one for the
history books use x-glam PCL exclamation
mark PCL all one word in the chat to
learn all about a do not miss the
comeback season of the pro chess League
All right so back to the games we go
yovi now that that's out of the way
we've got the PCO we got Tata steel the
best time to be a chess band we are
gonna go on a short break first so we
hope you're enjoying our coverage ladies
and gentlemen of round five of Tata
steel and we will be back with more
action from Magnus and Geary and other
players on the other side of this short
break
[Music]
your subscription makes shows like this
possible which is why our twitch
subscribers will never see ads on
chess.com
connectyourchess.com account and Twitch
account at go.chess.com connect accounts
and bang boom voila you're done a
hundred percent ad-free Bliss
forevermore whether you're following our
events on site or on stream type the
command connect in the chat and thank
you for helping bring these shows to
life
foreign
[Music]
questions
foreign
[Music]
and a beautiful view there welcome back
to Johan Cruyff arena in Amsterdam where
the players are contesting the fifth
round of Tata steel the tournament moved
to Amsterdam for one day giving
Spectators in the Dutch capital a chance
to view these players live we hope
you're enjoying our coverage GM
danielski and I am Ivanka Huska bringing
you coverage of Tata steel chess 2023
and I'm gonna put it very bluntly yovi
if you're not enjoying the games in this
round I'm not going to talk about the
commentary but you're not enjoying the
games then chess is probably the wrong
game for you
I mean I totally agree with that I mean
we ask for excitement we ask for chess
to be a spectator sport and the players
they are delivering I mean there are no
tame draws here there are fireworks on
every single board and wow it's
unbelievable I mean I don't know what
the players had for breakfast but I'm
loving it I love this change of tempo
and I I feel like Chas is the real
winner here I'm gonna go cheesy there
Ned most certainly is I think that
captures it and uh Abdus tutor I was
trying to capture magnus's Knight on F3
so as a quick update we had Rook hd8
Magnus saying I'm not touching the king
side there with a 10-foot pole moving
back to B2 to which notibrec responds
Bishop G4 looks like a blunder because
if Bishop takes C6 but notice the back
rank black would simply play Queen takes
C6 you can't recapture because Rook D1
is mate in two so I'll show that on the
analysis board Bishop C6 Queen C6 Rook
C6 and whoop this is that was not my
best one but this is one of notorbeck's
best mates and so Magnus moves the
Knight back from F3 to E1
occupying a defensive post that I think
can be compared to
um Jordan van forest's night that could
have been on E8 it's sort of a similar
type of situation where you're guarding
the G2 Pawn what do you make of this
yeah it's uh incredibly complicated I
agree with Magnus you need to retreat
that Knight you need to protect the king
at all costs and now the tempo has
changed a little bit the ball is back in
Black's Court black has to deal with
threat of Bishop takes Knight
and again the position is open it's
crazy it's not easy to do so I think
there's only one move I mean you either
run away with your king put it in the
corner which frankly I don't like or
instead I would move my rug on to the
sixth row and try to develop
horizontally
develop I love and I meant to say well
you're also sort of developing your Rook
I'm gonna I'm Gonna Save You There Eric
G6 it looks pretty elegant right because
you're I love moves that are both
defensive and attacking in nature and
you're potentially preparing to double
Rooks although I would be very cautious
about that because you're putting your
eggs in one basket and white could wait
for black to do all of that and then
just kind of crush the ant with your
foot and just play G3 and say you know
what have you been investing your time
into so King A8 Rook G6 both of those
are possible Queen B6 another move to
consider creating an x-ray against
White's Queen man I don't envy
notorbeck's Tasker he's probably better
objectively but with 25 minutes on the
clock how hard is it to choose a
candidate move in a position this
complex when you know that a single
mistake could turn the tables
yeah I mean the price of an error is
very high in this position for both
sides I hasten to add and uh it's just a
full-blooded fight and the choice is
insurmountable I mean I mean which one
of those moves do you prefer I mean
again you've highlighted up Queen B6
could be met by Bishop C5
um the more I'm looking at either you
sound the retreat with the bishop which
frankly no one likes to do or
hang a little bit Yeah there's this move
too Queen E5 by the way
is that worth examining because or do
the tactics work yes they do if Bishop
takes C6 you take the queen first and
you recapture Blackwood kill for a queen
trade here
yeah that's uh number one rule of
Defense when your opponent is attacking
you trade off Queens where you can
um I have to say six times out of ten it
works which is what I think quite good
odds
especially against Magnus I like Queen
E5 I'm going to predict 25. the more I
look at it the more I feel like that's a
A very wise move given uh the fact that
you're entering time pressure we are
only on move 19 that is a mind-boggling
thought because of how much has happened
in this game we haven't even made 20
moves
so any moves and uh actually the players
are short on time in that case you know
24 minutes to make 21 moves and still uh
you have to handle those complications
I mean we are going to look at a time
scramble at the end
but uh the good news for Naughty Beck is
that the action is happening right now
and if he can defuse it within the next
five moves or so then he can look
forward to to doing whatever he has to
do in an endgame
you're exactly right I think and the
important thing to understand about that
is that really the climax is going to
last another three or four moves so
Notre back
could potentially take 10 minutes here
if you can ensure an end game he can get
a position that's easy to play then he
won't mind having that position even
with eight or ten minutes on the clock
it's not like he's a world rapid
Champion it's not like he's good at
blitz so he's totally not able to handle
you know time pressure situations now
really quickly I just wanted to pull up
an announcement and actually examine
this queen E5 move because white doesn't
have to trade Queens white can move the
queen to one of these two squares on the
B file let's not talk about Queen B4
but if you play Queen B1 you're running
into more annoying moves like Bishop F5
so I actually think that white should
probably take on C6 and get into the end
game and basically say yeah I've
abandoned my hopes of checkmating the
black king but at the same time you've
got a pawn for the exchange you've got a
nice Bishop this isn't all bad for white
but Magnus would hate having a two
result position like this I think he's
got to bite the bullet though if black
plays Queen E5
I I agree and I just wanted to ask you a
question could you get greedy
[Music]
if the Rook comes down to D1 I'm
thinking well you know the Rook comes to
C1
um defend
oh
living on the first rank that's me
anything pursuit of a porn I'll take it
I'm gonna pursue your minor pieces here
oh but somehow the bishop A3 and the
bishop circles around to B4 so you're
holding on
but all of that is a moot point by the
way because Notre break has just made a
movement it's not 25.
yeah
um okay he hasn't played Queen E5 what
has he okay so he's has initiated a set
of Trades but he's paid to D1 okay
yeah I think a very similar move in
spirit to Queen E5 rather than getting
the Rooks the Queen's off the board he's
getting the Rooks off the word forcibly
white does not want to get checkmated on
E1 and once the Rooks are off the board
white really can't generate all that
many chances against Black's King with
the remaining pieces that he has Rook D1
is the top engine move so that is an
excellent choice
mm-hmm I it's it's a very brave Choice
as well because the more I look at it
the more I'm thinking that nordeback has
said that he's prepared to give even
more material because say for instance
white word just to capture works the
bishop on D1 that's loose
um unprotected and the first move that
comes to mind you probably spotted that
the pawn Grabber me says well
and attack the H7 phone at the same time
situation
yeah
I mean once you take H7 you've basically
got a four on one on the king side so at
that point White's probably okay with
the queen trade another Fork idea is to
take and go Queen to D2 running Bishop
D6 but the problem is that the Rook
swings to d8 simultaneously defending
both the bishop and the square so I
agree with you
I think Queen B1 is the better Fork the
more effective fork and neuterbeck
probably invested some time in into
thinking of a response in that precise
position
yeah and one thing I have to say about
these juniors are they are so good at
counter-attacking so I often a common
calculation error is simply to think I
attack a piece they have to move it and
most of the time these kids are like no
I am going to counter-attack and uh you
know yes you you don't have to move the
bishop it just occurred to me you can
actually counter attack with Queen B6
and so the game is still is still kind
of continuing
what a chaotic position there I think
you made a brilliant Point okay we got
to bring up an announcement again just
because this is such an important line
right we want to understand the world
champions game so let's dig in take
Stakes Queen B1 apart from Queen B6
there's also Queen A5
but your idea is just to aim at the
bishop
by the way Carlson has just taken on D1
Moment of Truth it are we gonna see
Queen B1
and how does he wheel his way out of
this situation
takes takes
what if I take
[Laughter]
um I think you have to probably
centralize your rig
somewhere yeah d8 is as good as Square
as any I probably discover in hindsight
that there is a better Square for The
Rook but you know it's analysis board
no I mean I do love your idea I also
have Queen A5
that is such a great tactical idea
check here and if you take the bishop
black takes White's bishop and with
every minor piece that disappears from
the board Black's winning chances
increase exponentially because two on
one on the king side if you can trade
queens and one more pair of miners the
game is over like black will just create
a past spawn and promote it because the
minor pieces are just never capable of
dealing with a rook in these situations
so
LV Magnus is Towing the line here he's
grabbing his head he's very very close
to he's one mistake away from losing
this game
and he's clearly unhappy with his Vision
I mean if you read his body language he
knows that he's taken
a big risk he's gambled and he might be
losing this rare this gamble um okay
this
I mean okay so he can't get greedy with
Queen B1 and Order Beck has a coolly
calculated that out
um what other moves to play then
well if you're not playing Queen B1
you're not playing Queen D2 I suppose
you could make a slow move and Carlson
when he defends he he often I think this
is what distinguishes him from other
players he'll find an opportunity to
play a slow roll kind of move and and
he's very objective right he comes to
terms very quickly with the reality if
he's worse and that that's what makes
him so hard to beat among other things
so maybe a move like Queen C1 get the
bishop out but try to make sure that
your Bishop is protected and your first
rank is protected that comes to mind
even a move like G3 to create some Luft
that should not be ruled out either but
with 25 minutes on the clock this is the
worst kind of position to have in time
pressure where you've got a vast choice
of moves you know you're worse and like
I said you know you're one mistake away
from losing
no uh on the subjects of protection I
have noticed the top players are
obsessed with protecting their pieces
you know the ideal formation would be
like for instance in this type of
position that white knight belongs on F4
put it on F4 where it's defended by its
own pawn and the dream for these super
Grand Masters is to have every single
one of their pieces protecting each
other
um
it wasn't until I sat in on the
champions tour or listened to everyone's
uh streams I realized that it's all
about over protection they're not
interested they're not interested in
Wild complications when the position is
like this
just protect your pieces and then that
means that you can actually play a lot
of moves just off the cuff
yeah that's a that's a great Point
people often say that top players don't
really follow chess principles anymore I
think that's not entirely accurate I
just think the principles they still
exist but it's like we've switched from
Newton's Laws which are easy to
understand to the theory of relativity
which still has its principles and rules
that are followed it's just the rules
are so much more complex and one of
those rules as you're saying is that
overprotection turns out to be very very
important to set yourself up for Success
when the game becomes tactical so we
could see a slow move like Bishop F1 to
bring the bishop on to a safer square or
H3 or Knight D3 a lot of choices for the
world champion as he continues to ponder
a very difficult position that he's in
and try to avoid two losses in a row
shall we dip back into the bird's eye
view
yeah definitely you know now you
mentioned Bishop F1 for Magnus I think
it's gonna happen on the board that's a
Magnus move I've ever seen one yeah
um okay so yeah so can we take a look at
the game we haven't caught up in a while
um it's between Fabi and Wesley the
All-American match up because we did
leave it when it was incredibly crazy
middle game that fizzled out into an
in-game and uh how is this one because
it's not often that you see two double
Pawns in the center of the board
oh yeah in fact there's four double
pawns on the board I completely forgot
whose Pond structure is worse that's
like a battle of you know an old two old
clunker cars racing down the racetrack
the pawn structures not the highlight of
both sides positions okay so who's
playing for a winner I think is a
worthwhile question to start with it
could be nobody
but I think it's actually black because
Wesley carwana with the implicit draw
for in response to King G80 would have
definitely gone back to D4
but instead Wesley goes the other way
playing for a win and the point is that
if you play the scary looking Rook H7
you could just take on E5
and maybe white should go for activity
with Rook F1 but I can see how this
could be a little bit unpleasant for
white at this point he'll be down a pawn
yeah I can also see that um so that's
why I was thinking desperate times call
for desperate measures is this a
situation where white should just put
the Rook all the way over to h8 so
rather than allow him to capture the
pawn
give a check
on age eight
sack The Exchange yeah I'm feeling
reckless in this precise minute and once
the king comes back now yeah my idea was
yeah like something like this if I could
possibly organize it or maybe even Rook
A8 was an idea that I had
but I mean is it is no maybe that that's
I'm getting my pieces tangled up so
don't put another book on it perhaps I
like your idea of repeating the position
maybe this is the way to a draw
yeah I mean problem The Rook H7 I'll
take it and when when the situation
Fizzles out my King has this beautiful
shape Square on B7 and I why does
drawing chances hear no doubt about it
but I don't think the situation is that
desperate I think it's a little bit
desperate you need to go for a lot of
activity if you want to hold the draw
here but you got to find the compromise
and I think that's what Bobby's doing
Rook H7 is on the board back we go to
the live board and he follows up with a
move I really like E4 setting a trap
Rook D7 you'll be your move Rook hate
let's Checkmate so black has to keep D7
available for the king and that he does
by playing Rook d8 I think Rook F1 Rook
D7 and Rook back to H1 is a possible way
for the game to end if I had to make a
prediction I think it's going to end
exactly in that way
okay
yeah that that's a neat way of repeating
the position
um is it possible that Fabi can play for
more
because yes okay he's down upon
but my eyes are distracted over to the
queen side I'm thinking hey that King
could actually make its way to A4 A5
grab a pawn and A6 after oh you know
hello and then you're gonna you've got
yeah exactly I've passed Acorn there
um
is this something to think about because
after all you can play Rook F1 at
leisure
yeah and you've got a Time Advantage the
problem is it's move 35 and we've got a
big time Edition on move 40. so I
wouldn't make a decision solely based on
the time situation Rook F1 is on the
board
so for now he refrains from King B3 I
think that is a very interesting idea
though and the position probably remains
dynamically equal but Abby might not be
willing to take this kind of risk uh at
still a relatively early point in the
tournament
yeah I was just thinking it's quite a
relevant idea as well because uh um
Wesley could be thinking about trading
Rooks so he could say hang on I don't
want a repetition he could decide to go
Rook F6 in which case after a trade of
Rooks King B3 King A4
is quite relevant and then okay now the
Rook has come to D7 here we go are we
gonna see our first result of the day
this is this is the moment of truth I
think if Abby wants to play for a win
we're gonna see King B3 we're gonna see
G5 we're gonna see a move that keeps the
tension but I just don't see it and I'm
going to call for Rook fh1
yeah
new haircut Fabby might not be crazy
risk-taking Fabby
it's been a very tense game what can you
say
um you use a lot of nervous energy going
through the sharp opening like that so I
would not be surprised if the players
are just like okay
take a deep breath agree a draw move on
to the next game there's still plenty
more rounds where it came from I'm sorry
I think about something else but I I
want to let you finish your thought
first
yes what I was laughing about as carwana
goes for a G5 he does it he's like I
don't want that draw just yet I'm Gonna
Make You Suffer suffer and work for it
Wesley declined the draw two moves
earlier and Fabby says too late my
friend it's my turn to play for a win I
was just laughing that Carlson did in
fact Play the movie Bishop F1 so you
were absolutely right
but now when you mentioned it I was like
that is the move how could I have not
have seen that one Bishop F1 I ever
protect everything yeah
we caught it Dave Daniel
we did and sometimes you see a move and
you yeah you just know that Magnus is
going to play that exact move because
it's so you know congruent with his
style
um as we can go back to the bird's eye
view I think we've given this position
the attention that it has deserved Fabi
will continue pushing for the win here
and uh we also called it in the backseat
live on Forest game they do indeed have
that exact position with an extra Queen
for white and a technically winning
position for Parham on the strength of
some incredible opening preparation but
the Arjun ding game that has also
transformed radically but yeah I'll give
you the final word on where we go next
yeah can we revisit uh the origin ding
game because that one was cray-cray
um
and it still looks
absolutely insane as well but it was
Tamer I would
hasten to say
hmm no I've changed my opinion though I
mean it's still still mad it's crazy
just a different kind of crazy
yeah I would even say it's a little bit
more dangerous now for black
because I'm just saying this because
white has uh two bad boys the Rooks who
are threatening to spring into action
you know the root can plant itself on
the center of the board the Queen can
move herself on C2 and start looking at
the black king oh
uh ding has to try to very carefully I
mean how did we get here
well we had a bunch of Transformations
H3 was met with A4 get off that diagonal
Arjun says no I am not getting off the
diagonal I'm just opening the B file
then D5 happened and this leads to a
trade Bishop D5 Bishop F5 EF attacking
the Knight take the bishop take the
Knight so material is currently
now sorry black is the one up a pawn and
you would be forgiven for thinking that
black is better because of the pressure
on F2 but the pressure on F2 is a bit of
a dead end right I mean White's
defending that pawn safely H4 is not a
threat because the bishop controls that
square and I actually love your
suggestion Queen C2 I think attacking
the pawn could be the key to the kingdom
for white
uh
yeah I think it's
it's a very natural move
and the thing is though you do have to
be really concrete about this position
because every move will count timing is
everything as uh Bobby Fisher said and
so the queen comes to C2 then you have
to defend you
um the first move that comes to my mind
is to sort of lift The Rook up to F6 or
F5 yeah I like that and uh double The
Works try to counter attack
uh this is not a position for black to
curl up in a ball he has to start uh
putting the pressure on Arjun
oh I apologize
um these moves are HG and Knight F6 have
been played as well
um and that actually lends even more
Point Credence to the queen C280 because
now
the Knight blocks the Rogue so after
Queen C2 you're almost out of options
for how to defend the G6 Pawn
yeah you're gonna have to
step up with the King
it was a very scary thing to do unless
you can swing the queen across to G5
what's the guy if
there I feel like it's a bit risky
because she can get chased around like
there's no tomorrow and the first point
I would say is Rook takes Pawn that the
first thing I would look at that's a
dream seventh rank
um okay but then you know attack is the
best form of Defense captured with a Can
you capture with the the pawn
yeah on yeah Knight takes G4 I'll play
Knight probably still Knight F3 honestly
to block the f file
I mean clearly we're not talking about
whether white is better we're talking
about the extent of White's advantage in
the event are really shooting up in this
type of position to somewhere around
plus two white is probably winning with
best play but it is still very much a
three result game I think that much
is totally clear Queen C2 though might
be the only way for white to cement his
initiative and keep the Flames burning
so will Arjun find Queen C2 will he go
for something else
well that remains to be seen
a live position after Knight F6 crazy
stuff yovi
yeah absolutely
gosh I know I feel like a broken record
but I'm just absolutely astounded by how
many games have become so sharp
um it's just round five you know the
guys had a rest day they were meant to
chill and it seems that they've uh
just come back to today's round just
invigorated
and just something in the step the more
nervous the players are the sharper the
position the better for us and uh
another thing that would be good for us
is to listen in on dingly Ren uh sharing
some thoughts we have a very nice
portrait of dingley around the Chinese
number one whose first appearance as
wake at Wake On Zay was actually as a
second of his compatriot Grandmaster
Wang Hao yet now of course he is a world
champion Contender and the star of
Chinese chess let's listen in to The
Classy the ever classy Beast thingly
wren
yeah I feel I feel good I feel excited
to get back here
I remember the first time I was there I
was helping one Hall I just sometimes I
got some snakes or drinks here in the
park in the playing Hall so it's it's
very special feeling
when I'm playing a very strong
tournament
I always want to try my best and did not
hide anything yes it's totally changed
the not only my games but also the games
itself I I say no the engines can
completely evaluate the positions that
work correctly evaluated positions it
means if we want to beat the opponent
with the same level we need to work hard
and to try to stay the very small
advantages
interesting insights there from Chinese
number one dingley ran he's over 2 800
and what a treat Yogi to be able to hear
on demand the players just talking about
what they view as important in chess and
how they've changed their play which was
really the centerpiece of that interview
yeah I mean certainly remarkable times
and I loved how uh ding addressed the
fact that these days it's not about
refuting your opponent's openings it's
simply about securing that small
advantage and just outwitting them by
small steps and that is absolutely
fascinating and of course we know that
Ding will be a contender for the world
championship and the beginning of April
so uh it's exciting times for Ding and
he actually spoke in one of his
interviews about the pressure that he
will be facing when the whole world will
be just observing this one match every
game that he plays is gonna be
scrutinized everything he does will be
analyzed and uh how he's been preparing
for this amount of uh scrutiny that he's
gonna get uh it's going to be intense
I'm also one thing I know about ding is
that he rarely comes with a second I'm
sure he's working with many seconds in
China but he rarely brings a second
to the tournament
and wow I was I always found that a bit
baffling actually because you do want
someone there just to Jive off just to
provide a good mood and uh often you'll
see Magnus with his father with uh Peter
Heine and Nielsen you'll see a niche
with his seconds they spend a lot of
time together but ding no no one and uh
I'm in total admiration at that that
he's so self-sufficient and focused
enough to basically do everything by
himself
yeah I mean he's experienced problems
with with travel you know he he has not
had an easy go of it and to handle it
with as much grace as he is he doesn't
complain he just you know accepts the
situation and plays his absolute best
chance just never lets himself get
affected by a bad performance and he's
maintained 2800 now for a while so
dingly rent don't miss the world
championship coming your way from Astana
Kazakhstan uh from April to the start of
May Jana pamushi will get a chance to
redeem himself after a crushing loss
against Magnus in the last World
Championship okay as Arjun Ponders his
next move in this very complicated
position let's take ourselves back to
the bird's eye view and perhaps we could
do a little quick summary of each board
before we choose an export to focus on
so you'll be I guess I'll take the top
and then maybe you could take some of
the bottom boards we've got Magnus
against some distators not much has
changed their Magnus kind of playing it
slowly with H3 Notre Beck clearly
playing for a win and over on on the
right top right we have prog against
Geary progress ensconced a rook on P6 I
would bet that that will be our first
result I think that's going to be a draw
I just don't see either side squeezing
any realistic chances out of that
position now what catches your bottom
boards
I agree with you that
um the bottom boards
um I would also say the same in the game
against kukash against Richard that
seems to me very level although having
said all that good cash does seem to
have secured a small Advantage you know
he's attacking the pawn on B4 he has a
good in-game Pawn on H6 but still I
think draws the likely result and uh
we've kind of called it when it came to
Parham and Van Forrest we predicted
absolutely everything and Parham will be
trying to massage an advantage a win
from the game he does have the queen
against rook and Knight and he also has
a passport for his efforts and then
finally we are in levonne aronian
against Vincent kaimer and we see a very
beautiful Pawn structure there a nice
diagonal
um what do you think of that position
let's take a quick a quick look at that
one I think it's been a while since
we've uh looked at it let's give Lavon
and Vincent a little bit of love so this
was a rue Lopez sort of a main line
where Lopez
um that has morphed into a very rich
haunt structure the a file has opened
and black controls it and it's always
important to control the only open file
on the boards that's black Spain
Advantage the problem is that black has
a lot of minuses in his position the B4
Pawn is incredibly weak the Bishops are
far from their best days White's pieces
are active and there's really nothing on
the a file yeah you can play Queen A2
but apart from giving the B4 Pawn up
what is it exactly that you are trying
to gain from infiltrating down the a
file white is definitely better yovi
it's hard to say by how much but I think
the eval bar is giving us an accurate
picture plus one plus 1.5 Lavon of the
clear advantage on the clock and on the
board
yeah I agree and I also wanted to point
out what has the potential of creating a
passport by orchestrating a c4c5 pawn
break and uh certainly not relevant in
this particular position but a an idea
to bear in mind
absolutely especially if the queen moves
away another positional idea is to maybe
get this Knight around ultimately to C2
I think that is White's plan to attack
Black's biggest weakness and if you get
the Knight on C2 you can also rest
control of the a file from Black's
clutches with the Rook to A1 kylo 1
seems very comfortable he's happy here
he's enjoying himself
yeah yeah exactly that is a Trademark
Sign from Lavon that he is happy he's in
control yeah I have to say Vincent has
sent me a slightly nervous
um he's kind of played a very solid
openings in the games beforehand and
it's his very first time playing at uh
this Elite this tournament the Tata
steel so maybe he's
somewhat cautious
yeah yeah I would totally agree with
that assessment and uh you know we're
spoiled by Arjun and players like that
we should you know I should understand
that when you're playing for the first
time in a tournament like this I've
heard a lot of interviews with young
players they are nervous right they do a
good job of hiding it everybody's
professional in this event but you don't
just Waltz in into a tournament where
you have Magnus and Wesley you're always
worried Yogi and I've had that
experience in the U.S championship and
that's like five times weaker than this
tournament what if I'm gonna be in bad
form what if what if I'm gonna lose all
of my games that's a possibility when
you're playing beasts of this caliber as
Lavon drops his Bishop back to B1 makes
space for the knight sets up a battery
is in control
yeah absolutely and uh it's it's very
nice that you mentioned how everyone is
struggling with those type of anxiety
that kind of feeling because everything
that you said just then I felt it myself
you know whenever I played a super
strong tournament I've always thought oh
my God what happens if this is a
tournament where I lose all my games do
terribly they'll never invite me back
and uh it's nice to see that it's
running through the top player's Minds
as well and uh I think it's very good to
be honest and open about Chess and about
the emotions that you're feeling because
too often we see these top players and
we just see this bravado we see like yes
yes you know I'm amazing I'm wonderful
it all goes so easily and what resonates
with me is the struggles that people
have you know and Lavon is certainly one
he's kind of lost his a few I think 50
points
maybe not 50 points but he's lost his
rating
2022 wasn't his best year but uh it's
good to see him back in the action I
mean I thought his game against Magnus
was very resourceful in the first round
I felt like he found some great ideas so
it was it's nice it's nice to see him
come back and of course he's like the
oldest player in the tournament which
really I wish they would stop saying
that because he's not that old but uh
it's nice to see him fighting and I know
something about Lavon is that he's
extremely fit when uh when he played in
the Gibraltar tournaments we'd often see
him in the morning just literally
running up the hill Running Up That Rock
he was walking so fast and he's in good
shape
wow I mean that's a obviously crucially
important especially uh when you're you
know one of the older participants Lavon
is he's in great shape physically he's
still in great shape tactically he's had
some off performances but he doesn't let
that hurt his confidence we have that
beautiful graphic up which showed
lavon's Great Performances through the
years and and that's what experience
really does for you I think experience
is most important when you're not
playing as well or when you're writing
an offs off uh segment of your career
when everything's going well you're
confident just inherently when you have
a couple of tournaments that start
getting under your skin that's where you
remind yourself hey in 2007 I played
well I've been playing incredibly well
for 15 years I'm not gonna let four or
five months of mediocre play affect my
confidence and you know that's what
makes experience so important in chess
we have a result ladies and gentlemen as
we predicted Wesley and Fabiano have
indeed drawn their game Fabi went for it
with G5 but then quickly thought better
of it and decided to repeat moves with
Rook hate and Rook H7 totally fair
result and what a combative game Yogi
yeah I know we kind of predicted it
would be a draw right from the start but
then what a path they took first of all
that'd be surprising Wesley with the
scotch and then the game got so
complicated and of course it fizzled out
to a draw but still you know the players
really fought every move I cannot fault
them at all I think it was a perfectly
played game of chess
it really was it was great opening prep
by Fabi he did everything to unsettle
Wesley he succeeded but Wesley took his
time at the right moment and as usual
Wesley just you know you can almost
never get him into a situation where he
where he's truly uncomfortable he is a
jack of all trades and he's just as good
in these wild tactical positions as he
is in the kinds of positions he he might
prefer a draw is our first result of the
day
and Lavon aronian well he's squeezing a
big advantage against Vincent kymer
let's get ourselves back to the bird's
eye view
yeah and
checking out the bird's eye view I can
see the evaluation bar is all the way in
White's favor in the game between Parham
and Jordan and we left it and we thought
Jordan had a winning position it seems
that
the computer and uh did I say Jordan was
Parham had a winning position right
yeah and it seems like pardon is making
arm is making smooth work of it
yeah he's he's won the pawn and F7 he
can he just played G3 in that position
we don't have to uh specifically analyze
I think if he plays G3 he's up a queen
and a pawn for a rook and a piece it's
not over I mean black has some chances
to to stir up a miracle against White's
King but provided that Parham doesn't
blunder and he's got plenty of time he
should finish this game off smoothly
this very well might be our second
result of the day in the meantime in the
world champions game stuff continues to
happen do you think we should take a
little dive into Magnus carlsenland
yeah because there is a big trap on the
board it will not happen I bet my house
on it
for the second time I point out yeah
[Laughter]
that should white capture that Bishop
that would be such a big mistake because
after Knight takes Bishop Knight takes
night check King will have to run to the
corner oh my uh computer's glitching it
won't let me
no
[Laughter]
okay
and uh yeah okay that's the end of that
but that will absolutely not happen but
it's certainly a point to be aware of
and it will certainly be causing
nordebec some excitement
and the question is how is Magnus gonna
handle this combination of Rook Bishop
Knight that's kind of making their way
towards the white king
yeah I mean this is why the world
champion is sitting on the board and not
the commentator but the one encouraging
thing I could point out is that black as
far as I can tell does not have an
immediate threat norderbeck puts the
bishop here to put pressure on the G2
Pawn he's not threatening Checkmate is
not threatening Bishop takes G2 because
if Bishop takes G2 and again that 91 is
really the unsung hero of White's
defensive construction so Magnus could
take the opportunity to play a move such
as Queen to D4 set up the threat at
Bishop D6 try to deflect The Rook from
the open G file although you have to be
careful what you wish for because if the
Rook moves on to d8 that might not be
much better with the Rook infiltrating
D1
man Magnus has to find a slow move like
that like Queen D4 Bishop B4 but he's
down to 12 minutes he's got 18 moves to
play oh are we gonna get an entertaining
finale in this game Queen D4 on the
board
he's done it yeah um
instantly I was surprised at that so wow
okay the queen will move
where is he gonna go and that's another
decision that Magnus has to spend some
time on and he just doesn't have a lot
of it left
yeah you have to be careful because you
do have ideas of Queen A5 In the Airs
you pointed out attacking the bishop and
Knight
so knowing Magnus it will be somewhere
where it's protected
maybe H4 to make contact with the Rook
yep that is very attractive
there's also Queen F4 to establish a pin
on the night
and also to threat okay he's played
Queen H4
okay nice move
so Rook D1
I don't think works Knight can take the
bishop
yeah
what does that mean that means another
back either has to play what I think
he's gonna play which is Bishop to D5
you can make another Intermezzo and move
the Knight back to G6 that's a very
engine-like move
I think as he nods his head there that
he's gonna go Bishop D5 and guess what
he wants to take on A2 and say look I've
got I'm gonna have connected passers on
the queen side and just because the
Queens are still on the board does not
mean that he cannot eventually just set
these Pawns in motion
and he's getting ready to make the move
I I love your bishop move I mean but in
the Spirit of Harmony could you drop the
bishop back to C6
with the idea that you just say yes you
can grab material but my Rook will come
down to the first row tag the Knight
I might have a check on h8 though that
could force The Rook back
so here I'll show this on the analysis
board Rook do you want almost wins but I
give this check
and it's not the end of the world but
maybe I can plant my queen on F6 and
look up at you pleadingly and beg for a
repetition there
yeah and uh well the key question is is
nordie Beck happy with the draw
because we've seen this time and time
again a lot of magnus's opponents
they're slightly better or they're much
better and they go draw against the
world champion I'll take that
and the game ends
if I was in Notre back shoes I I'm like
not just taking the repetition I'm
taking it faster than I took the draw
which gave me my third tree I'm grabbing
it from the sky
but that's what makes Notre back into
such a promising young Talent he just I
feel like those thoughts aren't even
entering his head I don't think he's
even thinking of it as I've got this
potential achievement I can draw Magnus
he knows the drill he's done it before
and he treats this like any other game
there we go Bishop D5 is on the board
you cooled it
so okay big moment on the boards I mean
you cannot defend that pawn on A2 so
Magnus just has to go horn hunting
himself grabbed the pawn on H7
unless I'm missing something of course I
must think about counter attacks like
the bishop coming to
E7 see if the bishop can switch Tack and
plant herself on a better diagonal oh
maybe something like this but
well I think black can take on E2 but I
can always use the F bond to support the
knight in the future with F6
Knight can drop back to G6 black is I
guess options here
and it's just he's so solid how is white
actually going to generate specific
attacking chances if you take H7 maybe
white has to start pushing his King side
pawns and throw caution to the wind the
OV but this Magnus is teetering on the
brink here
yeah
it's it's a very difficult race to call
isn't it whose King is going to be
safest once the pawn starts rolling
um
uh I wouldn't write off Magnus though
because Magnus is Magnus he often pulls
out these houdini-like escapes
and he just has this incredible ability
to coordinate the pieces together put
them on the right squares the right
diagonals
and it's not over until it's over us and
he said I mean I really like the
interview that Anish did after his
victory against uh Magnus where he just
says you know he felt like he had to be
on point at all times he could not relax
and he didn't think he was going to win
until Magnus gave him his hand and
resignation
and honestly to piggyback off of that
point one of the things that makes
anisha's win as impressive as it was is
how smooth it was because Magnus is one
of the greatest Defenders of all time he
never loses games uh in one-sided
fashion like that and it just felt like
Yuri dominated in wire to wire fashion
he got into a better end game I guess
barely ever had you know a tangible
chance to hold the fort so it was an
uncharacteristic loss and an amazing one
for Anish
and once again Magnus Carlson is staring
down the barrel of what would be his
second loss in a row it would put him at
-1 which just doesn't add up in your
head for Magnus to be
minus one in any tournament ever
yeah
um no I I mean it's a rare sight to see
and there we can see the standings and
Niche and Noddy back both on three
points out of four uh incredible start
for both players
such a tense game
and uh Magnus in full Focus one of the
things I have noticed about Magnus is
that to him chess is a form of
meditation like when he's in trouble
when he feels the heat that is when his
extra gear kicks in and he's able to
generate all kinds of Miracles I
remember once seeing him draw a game
three pawns down
most mere mortals would have resigned it
but no not Magnus he seemed to just kick
in something special and get Motoring
there is a book waiting to be written
about magnus's crazy comebacks I mean
that is just low hanging fruit that you
could pick off
uh a message to all potential aspiring
chess authors but right now the
low-hanging fruit lies on A2 notabeck is
about to pick it off and if he wins the
game he lands himself on a very handsome
four points out of five that would be
really one of the most impressive Tata
steel starts I've I've ever seen racking
up wins like this in this field is uh
just crazy absolutely crazy and as
Magnus Ponders his next move he's
dropped down to five minutes We Are
Gonna Keep a very close eye on this game
we will bring you the action as it
unfolds but once again our job is to
give you a sense of how all of the games
are going so let's go back to the bird's
eye view I don't mind going back to the
Magnus game even but at the very least
let's give people a chance to look at
the positions
Magnus takes on H7 by the way as you
said
yeah he took on A7 and we have that
full-fledged race happening it's going
to get sharp it's going to get
complicated and what's even spicier is
that the players don't have too much
time on the clock
um can we revisit the Arjun erag I see
dingler end match up because
now there's an immediate threat on the
board and there you see Arjun is
threatening to play Rick takes bishop
and that already sends my pulse is
racing and of course ding ding will see
it
but we do have that air of anticipation
in the air will he spot it will he not
how will he cope with that threat
yeah
um yeah how will he cope with that
threat that is quite a pertinent
question because the queen performs two
duties there she protects her King she
also protects the G6 Pawn
so she will have to move herself up
probably to have sex
man but there she can get uh chased
around
with moves like Bishop H4 Bishop E5
let's go to that game uh for for a
little while objectively it appears that
Arjun has given up his Advantage he had
a big Advantage but we have to realize
you know in the time pressure situation
take the eval bar with a grain of salt I
mean things can really change multiple
times in a game when the position is
this complex Queen F6 is on the board
dang saying I ain't giving away my
Bishop on B6 tossing the ball back into
arjun's court and the crazy thing is
that Bishop H4 might run into well not
really I was thinking of a queen sack
but I forgot the G6 hangs with Chuck
so in the event of Bishop H4
you maybe keep your queen on the sixth
Rank and The Rook is actually virtually
trapped there as well there's so many
moving Parts in this position geez
Louise how do you keep track of
everything
yeah not easy thing to do and uh also
one thing to note is that the bishop the
white Bishop can't pick off the pawn on
C7 because Bishop takes Pawn would be
deadly that would be very unfortunate
man oh man now Queen to E4
I will say is apparently the best move
but it's a hard move to play because
yeah you centralize your queen but
you're not creating any threats and
Arjun has just had the initiative for
the last 10 moves so suddenly to switch
into this sort of more defensive mode we
know how hard that can be to change your
mentality in a game at the drop of a hat
this is getting scary all of a sudden
yovi for Arjun
yeah it is very scary because uh
counter-attack is a very dangerous thing
to handle especially when you've had the
initiative the whole game when your
opponent has been on the back foot it's
very difficult to adapt to a situation
where your advantage just fizzled out
and it's your opponent who is now in
charge and often to get that initiative
you've had to take big risks you've had
to compromise your position and in this
particular situation is White's king is
not that safe either and black has very
active pieces
and also background problems are
potentially in White's future white has
the Luft Square on H2 but the Knight
controls it very easy to miss in a Time
scramble easy to just assume that you
don't have to worry about that you've
got to worry about everything if you're
Argent aragaisy and if you're not
playing Queen E4 and you're not taking
on C7 and you the exchange stack on B6
doesn't do anything it only brings on
the background problems
then what do you do you can just sense
the anxiety kind of building up and the
clock dwindling down tough stuff for
Arjun and Dink oh the guy's a beast just
the way he survives preparation
initiative it doesn't matter doesn't get
too high with the highs doesn't get too
low with the lows
yeah and uh there you can see him
completely composed and you also have to
remind ourselves that going into the
rest day he had lost to pragnananda so
he had one whole day just to brew on
that fact to brew on that emotion
perhaps he used it to his advantage to
you know maybe on the football football
field he managed to get rid of some of
that frustration and uh yeah
such an incredible position very
complicated so sharp
anything can go anything can happen here
yeah Queen F6 is the last move Arjun
continues
to ponder his response this just looking
at this from
the side scares me I can't even imagine
sitting at the board right now
if you're Argent he looks like he's
about to make a move but
he hasn't made a decision just yet
yeah not an easy position to call
actually it's difficult to suggest a
move like you've said quite a few times
yeah
it's them it's them playing not us this
is why they're there and what oh whoa no
no no no no no this I
I ruled this one out I said that this
one was not possible so did I hey
well he's living on the edge this is
crazy stuff okay so the first move we
have to look at Bishop takes born the
king must hide in the corner run to H1
and okay five
coming to a theater near you Rook F5
threatens an exchange Tech followed by
potentially a mating attack with Queen
H4 Knight E3 oh and that's just
Checkmate what does white do after Rook
F5
Arjun must have an idea the queen must
come to the assistance okay so come here
Save the Day here
okay Rook F5 already on the board Queen
E4 Rook takes F3 if you play GF you
still lose check here this isn't mate
but it basically made you have to give
up your queen you lose
so apparently you have to give a check
here
then
only move
oh my God look at this line Queen H4
is this Checkmate no it is not because
of Queen F3
and now black has the insane Bishop to
E1
slicing off the rook and setting up a
mate thread on F1 and now are you ready
for the craziest part
the reason that you have to give that
check on D5 is because white has the
counter resource Bishop E5 check
forcing the knights off of G4 and now
you force The Rook trade and black is
better in the resulting position I
totally calculated that entirely on my
own of course I saw all of that of
course immediately never in doubt
um oh my Lance oh wait wait wait wait
wait wait so this is the only path to
safety for Arjun is look so for saying
to me so Rook F5 you have to defend the
only way to defend is move the queen ah
does it matter Queen E4 Queen D3 is
there a difference no apparently Queen
D1 and queen E4 are both possible
but I mean you it's seeing Queen E4 to
me isn't the problem it's a pretty
obvious move to bring the queen into the
defense the insane part is playing Queen
D5 check and I'm really worried that
Arjun is gonna play Queen E4 but then
take on F3
and miss that Bishop E1 ends the game in
that position on the spot because you
don't have that check on E5 to distract
the knight from G4
oh my gosh this could be crazy what a
turnaround we're seeing
okay
he has to move the queen to defend the
night that is absolutely false but you
know what Daniel I think that what's
going to happen is he will find that
check he's played it we'll get to this
position yeah okay so this bit's so far
so good easy stuff
but I think he's gonna realize closer to
the critical position and then he's
going to go oh I have to throw in that
check and then he'll find it but maybe
he might not have seen it when he
grabbed that pawn all the way back and
it's just one of life's happy accidents
while Arjun fans across the world are
holding their breath right now
yeah I'm holding my breath I'm just a
spectator I mean this is incredible
stuff I mean dean could be on the verge
of victory
One path
that's that was mind-blowing can we can
we show that line again
immense yes we can and let me show it
without Queen D5 just to illustrate why
it's winning
and here you'll be Bishop F2 that you
want I mean talk about easy to miss
can't take the queen because of a mate
threat you can try to defend F1 but even
if you could defend a phone which
actually you can't there's also a fork
threat on F2 and remember with the King
on h8 in this exact position white has
Bishop C7 to E5 check deflecting the
Knight so that you can then trade Rooks
with Rook B8 Rook B8 here allows Knight
F2 check that's why you need to
sacrifice your Bishop oh my gosh now
first of all ding doesn't have to play
Rook takes F3 so that move is not forced
but do you think he's going to resist
the temptation I don't think so I think
we're gonna see Rick takes
no that's just too tempting you gotta
open that box I mean
I would be just ABS absolutely in
ordering if he did not capture that
night
uh he's gonna do it
oh my gosh man I don't know what else to
do
it
I will have my
I know I will I was just gonna say if
Arjun calculated all this as the only
path to safety you know he's calculated
the queen to D5 man I'm just gonna like
say I'm not worthy he is just God level
and chess that is an incredible defense
and such a deep variation
but wow there is I hate to be the bear
about Tidings but even if he executes
all of those moves perfectly that
resulting end game I won't play those
moves through again but that two pieces
for a rook end game actually still
offers black very decent winning chances
I think that's about a 50 50 position
between a draw and a win for black so
that's what makes Rook takes F3 so
appealing for ding even if he sees
White's best defense he still earns
himself a risk-free end game with great
winning chances
yep uh
I I would just play Rook takes F3 I
don't have the restraint I'm just gonna
do it I see it is good I won a part of
that action you know all chess players
are artists at some level and yeah you
see such a beautiful shot and you can't
help it but uh there we see Arjun he's
poised he's in deep concentration he
knows that he's on shaky to ground and
wow
and uh
I mean what could be the other
Alternatives though because
you know I'm sure this is also running
through Dean's head he could be thinking
yeah this is very tempting this is great
but is there something simple that keeps
control for instance if the bishop does
retreat you are threatening Knight F2
which is like a woohoo exactly
and and I would say there are two
buckets of ideas the first tries to
exploit the back rank the second tries
to exploit the F2 Square so as you said
the bishop could move back you could
combine you could play Bishop D4
Queen takes is not possible because at
the end there's Rock F1 Knight takes
isn't possible because there's a fork on
F2 so Bishop D4 even just Bishop to C5 a
quiet move
the problem though I think is that white
can slide his own Bishop down to G3
controlling both the F2 square but also
this very important H4 Square
so I think ding is just double triple
checking ding might actually not even
see the move Queen D5 check he might be
under the impression that Rook takes F3
wins on the spot I I just want to see
him take on F3 I can't wait to find out
if Arjun sees Queen D5
yeah I I can't wait to see that one
either I was just also like wondering
whether there were any other fancy
footwork moves that black could do I was
even considering like something like
Bishop E1 with ideas that if the Rook
takes obviously Knight F2 and if the
queen takes then I was thinking Rook
takes uh Knight
because somehow Blaster but I don't
think it works
I guess I take your rook in that case
and just tuck my king away G1
that's a beautiful idea there's nothing
there yeah
if it worked that would be spectacular
but it doesn't therefore it would be a
blunder the margin between genius and
idiocy is quite fine it is notoriously
thin we've all experienced that margin
uh in a game where you go from thinking
you're a genius to thinking it's more
the opposite end of the of the spectrum
there uh pretty quickly
all right dang time to make a decision
here he doesn't have much time left
remember that 50 minutes are added after
move 40 is made white makes move 40 he
gets 50 minutes black makes his 40th
move and also gets 50 additional minutes
but not a lot of time left here if the
clocks are accurate there it is
on the board drum roll ladies and
gentlemen Queen D5 check the only move
to stay alive here goes Arjun yeah are
you not entertained because I am I'm so
happy we stayed on this game we are
gonna go to Magnus okay folks I I can
hear the grumblings
um even though there's a delay but we
just have to wait for arjun's move
yeah we absolutely do because here is a
critical moment he has to find Queen D5
check
if he does he's still alive if he
doesn't then he is dead in the water oh
and Arjun well he's got less than one
minute on the clock he's thinking though
that's a great sign he's thinking that
means he is aware that there is an
alternative to Queen takes F3 that gives
me hope for Arjun
yeah 45 seconds Gotta Move Gotta Move
gotta move it then you got nine moves to
make with no time
it doesn't look flustered that also
gives me hope because if he was like
moving his head from side to side in
panic that would not be a good sign
either
um
Queen D5
I'm like literally holding my breath now
oh yeah I'm looking at the camera
make that move Arjun put the queen on D5
you gotta do it 13 seconds 12 seconds
still still watching he's still calm
he's still I know we can't handle this
five he might have a little bit more
time than that
oh
lost on time but I think it's something
maybe like two minutes
okay
we are aware that there are give Ivanka
a heart attack there but uh okay
I was literally just on the edge of my
seat chess can do this to you goodness
watch whether you're a player you're a
spectator whether you're watching online
in person doesn't matter everyone is
like holding their breaths and uh
I mean
yeah this is the one of the Beauties
about about watching chess somehow are
there it becomes all about the chest it
doesn't become about the person like
every single one of us wants Arjun to
find that move and he's done it and he's
done it oh what a man awesome stuff the
game will continue now let me clarify
again after that whole line happens and
I'm going to show this one more time
then I propose we go right to magnus's
game what's going to happen is the
following sequence king h8 queen takes
F3 check on H4 wind blocks Bishop blocks
the rook and now the reason you
deflected the king onto h8 Bishop E5
check black has to take or else there is
a devastating Rook check on G7
black takes white trades the Rooks Rook
B8 black liquidates queen trade and Rook
trade I mean the engine it was pointing
out that King G8 is the best the best
way to orchestrate The Rook we're gonna
get an end game like this where
obviously
um or not dig played a different move he
didn't do it he played Rook F7
let's rewind he's gone Rook F7
and he's
oh
and there's just no Bishop check on E5
if Arjun takes on F3 oh my lands
yeah oh Bishop d8 is the only move
and he started again
no he's found it
well he doesn't even know what's going
on
no I I was gonna say I mean things are
really wild here because it just feels
the queen needs to move
somewhere you have moves like Bishop E1
what about Bishop B1 now
just forget your Queen's under attack
oh Mike this is Bishop E1 I can take
your Rook on F3 and you don't have Queen
H4 because The Bishop's guarding that
square
but try this on for size you'll be Queen
F4 the bishop comes back to C7 defending
H2 and attacking the queen there could
be a three-time repetition here
this is insane only move Bishop C7 and
he's gonna play there's just nothing
else to do otherwise if you take on F7
you emerge down a piece he's done it
again
margin is a hero no matter how this game
ends and so is ding
yeah
I could not have predicted that this
game would end in a threefold repetition
I mean is there any way for ding just to
keep the game alive move the queen
the random Square I'm in E3
um F6 well if you play Queen E3 I mean
at that point I can already take your
Rook with a pawn and I'm up in exchange
I think that a repetition of moves here
is likely Rook F7 might have been a
mistake from ding which allows this
beautiful defensive repetition so ding
is going to make a decision I also know
that people are itching to see what's
happening in the world champions game so
maybe we could take a dive into magnus's
position we will keep you posted on ding
when he makes a decision as to whether
to repeat but don't be surprised if he
does that game might end in a draw
what's going on here
we got a proverbial race the a pawn is
marching up the board the H Pawn is
gonna start copying and uh all the while
both Kings have to be kept safe
guys
this is what we thought would happen
yeah
so and black is much better
I agree I mean black has The Rook white
has the bishop by Nature should be
better but I'm looking at the king
safety and I'm thinking that
White's King is just that little bit
more safer
but if I came to that conclusion I don't
know
but I guess the Devil's Advocate point
of view is that black has this check on
DC what you're saying is that white can
just block that check with G3 or even F4
so there's no mate threats but I'm just
a tour of has to be so careful about
where he puts his Rook it's easy to play
a move like okay one and forget that
that Bishop is x-raying The Rook so
where is he going to go with this Rook
is the immediate question he's got to
answer
well hang on a second
can that Rook not be chased into
perpetuate until Forever Until kingdom
comes
oh so what you're saying is Rook F1 I'll
play Queen
yeah or maybe yeah and then I think
you'll have to go Rook B1 to keep that
Rook alive
now there is Rook takes Knight you can
give your exchange back and force a
queen end game where you could argue
that your Pawn is a little bit further
Advanced and that might give you winning
chances but I would not blame notabeck
for even a second if he decides to
acquiesce to the repetition here
no I I wouldn't blame as well especially
when you take into consideration that
the players don't have so much time on
the clocks either
The Rook
you know even if they only have five
minutes I mean that's
incredibly tough to sit down and work
out every single check every single Pawn
advance I mean I can certainly see a
situation and there we see a check
from Naughty back F4 instantly from the
world champion and now there's a big
threat of Knight takes Knight and the
board but now Rook takes Knight I think
Rook takes Knight gives black a
risk-free queen end game with winning
chances he has done it that was the only
way to keep winning chances alive this
is amazing Knight takes Bishop Pawn
takes Knight is forced and then
notrebrecht collects two pawns at the
same time he takes on F4 then he takes
on D4
oh my gosh black might be winning here I
mean that a pawn the path is basically
clear White's biggest chance is to find
a Perpetual of some sort
but I don't I don't see this working out
for Magnus
yeah this is a very tough end game I
mean especially because when it comes to
Queen engines I see we we see him
Advance the pawn queen takes pawn and uh
Magnus playing accurately as ever
preparing H4 the thing is though white
does have a runner in the age Pawn
so black can't just push the a pawn to
Kingdom come and be super happy about
everything he still has to be careful
and my feeling is that this isn't maybe
enough to hold the draw
I mean it does involve a lot of
groveling
you're not you're not convinced
you think it's going to be a win for an
order back
well what it does what Wade has to
decide on a broad level is what is the
balance of attacking moves to
defensivism when I say attacking moves
that obviously mean pushing the pawn so
does white play H4 now or does white try
to park his Queen on the best defensive
Square which is probably A2 you can't
prevent A4 but you can make it difficult
to play A3 but I think if you're Magnus
with two minutes on the clock you just
play H4 quickly and he just did exactly
that H4 is on the board
motorbeck is going to play A4 and we're
going to get an old school Pawn race
here here we go again
[Laughter]
situation where the pawns will both
reach their destination so A4 come on H5
get going get Motoring
I mean
maybe H5 is too slow
maybe now is the time to stop that pawn
from advancing to A3
Park the queen on A2 do as you suggested
and then
carry on with the H Pawn wow it would be
nice if you could hop on the United
Airlines flight from H4 to h8 All in One
Go
but here's the big moment for Magnus
you're absolutely right is H5 too slow
H5 A3 H6 you could get a situation where
the h-man is somehow liquidated for the
a pawn
but that's a draw I don't think black's
King will have enough protective cover
in that resulting position to to allow
black to push the b-pawn that's what
Magnus wants I think
to trade these Pawns
yeah and that would be a dream for him
it would make his uh defensive task a
lot easier but
no those pawns are going to remain on
the board I 100 guarantee that
just I also have to remember that
nordybeck can actually keep an eye on
the H porn himself
you can decide that two are better than
one and can you it can also kind of go
B5 at the same time
and use his King
yeah he certainly can 40 seconds for the
world champion with two moves until time
control once time control is made I can
assure you that they will use each and
every one of those 50 additional minutes
to try to make heads or tails of this
end game
but in the meantime it's time for
magnets to move I think he's gonna go H5
I think he's closing his eyes and
praying basically
yeah I'm not so sure he's very accurate
Queen goes to A2
and uh that pawn is prevented from
moving further
by the way dingley Ren accepting the
repetition we see them on camera there
discussing their game
it's a draw by repetition
Arjun eragisi he was maybe winning but
yovi the real story was his defensive
efforts in the end of that game just six
crazy engine moves in a rows all you
need to save the game against England
and he did it yeah they they put on a
show for us I mean what an exhibition
well they went out with a bang didn't
they and uh they certainly played with
my nerves but I'm very thankful for it
and uh in the meantime talking about
nerve-wracking it's still a
nerve-wracking situation for the world
champion against abdusatorov because he
finds himself in a queen and Pauline
game it's a race and uh if we take a
look at the placings of the Queens we
see the black queen is right back and
slap in the Mig at the middle and that
is the perfect
scenario for a queen to be and let's not
forget that Abdus autof is one extra
Pawn up
you know bad news
you changed my mind about this position
I was originally thinking it's almost
hopeless but now I realize that I
actually think white can force the trade
of the Apon for the H Pawn first of all
black has to be able to play a three so
Queen B4 we could bring up an L sport
here real quickly I think the game is
going to go like this queen B4 H5 A3 H6
and you might say oh I win with Queen B2
check but no white takes and promotes
just in time with check and that's a
good version of that resulting end game
where white has quote unquote the
initiative so maybe there's a better way
to do this with a move like Queen D6 but
the upshot is still the same white just
shoves that pawn down to age seven
and at the end of the day you're going
to get this position with that extra
beep on and if Magnus can reach this
successfully with 50 minutes on the
clock we're going to see a long game
this might be an eight nine hour game
but something tells me the world
champion is going to hold his own if
they reach this particular Pawn balance
yeah I agree I've seen a lot of Queen
and pawn end games from the world
champion and he's superb at them
um yeah it's also not very easy for
black to support his passport because I
my immediate thought was well why not
play B5 but if you play B5 then you you
have the problem of Queen takes porn and
you can't get happy and push your a pawn
one square further because the queen
will come to f8 and pick up that pawn so
yeah
somehow not easy to kind of
orchestrate the advance of that pawn and
at the same time defend your F7 Pawn
and keep an eye on the H Pawn
um seems to be mission impossible for
the queen
man this is a frustrating sensation
Notre back with F5
okay very interesting move he might be
trying to shatter the white king safety
with F4 and if you can remove the G3
Pawn then obviously black will have two
additional types of ideas the first of
course is a fork with uh attacking the
king and the H Pawn the second is to use
checks to get your queen forcibly onto
an ideal square and I think this makes
it even more necessary for white to push
this Pawn as quickly as he can H5 seems
to be a certainty
in this position
yeah I mean what has one Trump in the
position gotta run with it and he does
the queen comes
is he gonna play F4
yeah
absolutely why not although this is F4
slightly risky be on account of G4
there I feel like black plays F3 and
you've got a new demon to fight if
you're Magnus
yeah
it's by
I don't know
but then okay he moves his Queen to the
edge attacking age Pawn
uh yeah but the queen is quite passive
there also you can take on A4 now if
you're Magnus
you absolutely will do that I had
completely forgotten about the existence
of that porn I was so focused on the H
Pawn
Queen takes porn
but uh they've reached the critical move
41 so they will be getting extra time on
the clock and yes this is good technique
from the world champion you know he's
simply going to take his time establish
what is his best chance get to grips
with a position understand it and then
nope it doesn't well I think I think he
knows that this is as good as it gets
right you're not gonna get a better
version than this end game so we are
going to see notorbeck try to grind this
out for
a couple of hours I mean even the world
champion gets tired so it's a classic as
I call it a 50 50 position this is just
a a very classic example of an end game
where there's two results possible
unless black blunder is the screen
always possible but not likely
I I would rate White's drawing chances
as higher than Black's winning chances
by maybe 20 so maybe more like 70 30.
yes I am influenced by who is handling
the white pieces here
yeah I I think that white is definitely
going to draw this
I don't think that there's any way that
the black queen can park herself
somewhere where she can protect the F5
Pawn escort the B Pawn
and uh protect the king from Perpetual
checks I think it's just not gonna
happen and uh
well I'm notoriously bad with my or
optimistic with my statistics
so yeah I mean the thing is though and
this is the beauty of the classical time
control they have 50 minutes now for the
next 20 moves and they will use that
time and they have
all the energy in the world to figure
out what is the best move what are the
best defenses they can work out the
subtleties and
that's it you know we're not going to
see a Time scramble where nerves are
fraying people are panicking nope it's
just cool calm relaxed chess
and uh in terms of quality it's good in
terms of uh Scrappy it's not so good
because I must admit I quite like the
scraps I would like it when mistakes get
made on both sides but uh okay
oh that was very exciting deep breath
and Magnus gets up from the chair you
often see the players on move 40 going
back for some candy or some coffee they
need a little bit of sugar but you can
see the time control there uh once
Black's clock hits zero make sure that
you know that doesn't mean black loose
is on time when the clock hits zero 50
more minutes are going to be added
automatically to the clock so he doesn't
have one minute he has 51 minutes and
then you have another time Edition
um after another 20 moves are made so
right now Notre back has to focus on
trying to find the best move when you
hit 20 minutes or so then you start
thinking about the clock situation once
again but I think this is a perfect
segue for us to transition back to the
bird's eye view because we have some
other very exciting games we have some
games which have not reached the time
control just yet and the gookish game is
interesting
what is going on in that game I think
we're about to see a draw in ghukesh
against report
yeah
certainly looks like it
but it's a very quirky draw judging by
the pawn structure it's not every day I
see
three porn Islands two yeah set double
pawns Bishop versus knight a Pawn on H6
is that good porn bad porn I don't know
and the Night Comes and attacks them and
attacks the bishop and so the first
question I would be asking why can't
white get greedy and capture the porn I
mean how does that trade work
if you take on G5 I think black pushes
B3 but I'll make a proposal the best way
to enjoy end games is with a little bit
of coffee so I am going to vote coffee
break bathroom break and then when we
come back since a lot of the games have
made time control we can settle down a
little bit so we will return to the go
cash
report end game on the other side but
before we do we want to remind you that
the officialchess.com Discord server has
been revamped a fresh new look lots of
new features and more join us at
go.chess.com Discord and make sure to
connect your chess.com account to earn
unique player and stay in the loop use x
Glam Discord in chat for more
information well we hope you're enjoying
our coverage of round five here at the
Tata steel chess tournament 2023 we will
be back with more action for magnus's
game and others as games on the other
side of this short break
oh he's I was here I was I was lost oh
okay well hey
let's go oh no there is
unreal no first try eight in a row nine
in a row baby let's go
let's go let's go I gotta oh cool I got
a little achievement thing I honestly
really enjoyed that that was really cool
become a chess.com Community streamer at
go.chess.com start streaming
[Music]
foreign
all right
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
s
for this cozy coastal town the holiday
season isn't over
in fact the most wonderful time of the
year has really just begun and Checkmate
abdusitara played a brilliant game he is
a monster
once again vikon Zay starts the new year
as the center of the chess Universe this
year as host of the 85th taught to steal
chess tournament
a magnet for the best players in the
game some recognize the Masters field of
2023 as its strongest in recent memory
of course it helps when eight-time Tata
steel chess champion Magnus Carlson is
back Magnus is a beast doesn't give up
we know the kind of comebacks that he's
capable of in the position
the world's number one looks to further
cement his legacy in this event and the
game's history
chasing Magnus will be amongst the best
in chess several have been crowned
Champion here before some have even
shocked the world in doing so
and don't leave out those poised to
capture their first Tata title Anish is
taking down the world champion
is in absolute shock
although winter Tata steel chess is also
known as the place new stars come to
bloom
Magnus one here is a teenager this
year's event has its fair share of young
players on the rise each hoping to
follow in Carlson's footsteps a huge win
for prognananda against ding the ren the
Dutch refer to Tata steel as The
Wimbledon of chess for 85 years in
running this tournament continues to be
steeped in Prestige and Legacy and does
so again in this welcoming Little Dutch
town by the sea
mind Brendan it's the 85th edition of
the Tata steel chess tournament and it
starts right now
foreign
football stadium in Amsterdam where the
players are contesting the fifth round
of the Tata steel chess tournament 2023
and the games have entered their fifth
hour we've got a couple of fascinating
end games going on I am Ivanka houska GM
Daniel nerdinsky chopping it up for you
today
oh my goodness siwanka we can take a
deep breath finally time control has
been made in most actually all of the
games in 50 minutes have been added to
their clocks it's time to reevaluate the
situations two games have already ended
in draws we've got fascinating chess yet
to be played as we look at the standings
yeah you kind of mentioned
taking a deep breath and there we can
see the standings and each giri three
points out of four and Order back also
in the lead with him and I think that's
such the right emotion for this
particular point in the game because you
cannot underestimate all that pent up
nervous energy the players will have had
to use and had to just grit through or
get through rather
um just to get to move 40 and now that
the nerves are cleared the fog Has
Lifted we can see that the players are
in end games and talking about end game
uh we wanted to head over to the prag
versus Geary game and here to me this
looks like a very balanced in-game I
mean if I were a betting person I would
just say draw no problems move on but uh
I do think that white needs to be
slightly careful because if white gets
too ambitious and for instance does
nothing then there is a past Pawn on the
board on D4 and that can be supported by
the black king so I think now is the
right time for Prague just to just call
it a day push the B Pawn forward and try
to liquidate on the queen side
yeah something a little disturbing is
happening here in the sense that Prague
has been pushing in the last six seven
moves really without any risk and with
his last move King F5 anishikiri
demonstrates that he is not willing to
just sit idly by and defend you know a
one-on-two rook end game if you wanted
to do that you could have essentially
forced to draw with D3 but I do think
that he is entertaining at least the
remote Prospect of playing for a win
here if he can squeeze his King let's
say to D3 so totally on the same page if
you're Prague you're looking for a way
just to immediately liquidate and maybe
the safest way to do that
is to start with the move Rook to B6
and trade the a pawn for the B Pawn and
basically try to get behind Black's Pawn
before it's too late and then use your
past a pawn to tie down blackstroke
you'll get a mutually assured
destruction kind of situation where both
Rooks are behind each other's pawns and
neither side can make progress because
of course the g-pawn Deep freezes the
the f and g pawns for white
how was that summary that make any sense
no it made a perfect sense no I totally
understood that but um I had also
completely forgotten that uh praggers
are Pawn up so actually playing B5 would
actually be returning the pawn so it's
much more natural to put the Rook on B6
but still I mean one has to be very bold
to make such moves because there is D3
in the air and D3 this time can be
supported by the king marching to E4
and pawn two squares away from queening
it's gonna send shivers down your spine
it is indeed and let's pull up an
analysis board here to forecast how we
think this game might go so let's say
Rook B6 happens
black probably shouldn't wait any longer
and perhaps should play D3
okay white takes on A6 D2 Rook D6 tempo
for Tempo I mean that's close black
should take the pawn white Gets behind
the pawn black defends it with the King
y pushes A6 black Gets behind the pawn
and actually white is almost in zoo song
but but fortunately you have your share
of King moves you can play King G1 to G2
and my question is what if black tries
to get the same position with white to
move oh here there's King F1
because here you can give a check oh or
you even have Rook to E6
look at this idea
and if rookie won then he won
but you have D2 right and then I check
you on F6 and come back to E2 and
suddenly white is winning chances again
oh that is ridiculous
but that is why black doesn't want to
play with fire
yeah
that was a lovely line he showed that
and yeah I mean you can repeat the
position a few times
and he says yes absolutely I'll have a
bit of that
um
it's
I mean could could black after Rook B6
just go I'm gonna be a Slayer and go
King E4 yeah I'll take A6
you can take E6 A6 sorry and I'll take
B4 and I'll go back to music
yeah and then I was wondering whether
the king could kind of make its way to
C3 I mean I do realize that this would
be a niche playing for the win
yeah no I actually really liking E4
um
practically I mean it's it almost seems
like he's struggling suffering
okay can we put that up on the board
sure
it came gets goes Rogue so you capture
the pawn I captured the pawn Happy Days
you get behind you follow the Rook
principles get that Rook behind the past
pawn and the King comes now to D3
hmm
you know what I can try here is Rook to
G4 weird looking move oh Rook to G6
sorry
yeah
and my idea you're probably gonna move
the King right
yeah
I'll take it
you okay then I have to get behind your
passport
gosh I have no idea who's playing for a
win here I'll go
here
oh and there's the Evo bar yeah yeah
I thought I'd get behind the pawn
but I guess black just pushes oh and
Rook takes a five is now
yes but I mean it might not be enough
because after all you have two passes
you could
and also Rook D4 is the bigger problem
actually now I look at it yes it is I
have to move my king up
but now you wrote
yeah or even King C2 can be considered
but then you get into three result
territory because white is the connected
passers there
wow if that's too wild that's too
complicated we like simple chess so we
do yeah
but this has gotten very gnarly all of a
sudden for Prague who has 47 minutes he
just started eating into the second time
control but you've seen games like this
go
out of control this is how you lose
positions that you play for two results
you get a little over ambitious you get
a little too comfortable and this move
King F5 is such a clear signal to me
that Anish giri is already thinking
about playing for a win here Prague has
to be very careful for five or six moves
if you know
he wants to have a good evening tonight
and uh Prague actually in one interview
mentioned that in last year's uh Masters
tournament he started off really well 50
and he was very happy with that but then
he proceeded to have a nightmare middle
of the tournament and he only ended up
with five and a half points out of 13.
some a score that he was dissatisfied
with and the fact that he mentioned it
means that it is playing on his mind
just a little bit
oh it it most certainly is and any any
time you have an opportunity to even
draw someone like a niche I mean that's
a big achievement and when you start
feeling that feeling that you you're
messing it up you're getting it out of
control I've experienced that you know
many times where I think I have it in
the bag against the super GM suddenly I
start having to work a lot harder for
that draw your throat closes up you know
your hands get sweaty and and that is
the process you have to avoid you have
to stay objective stay calm and
calculate dispassionately as if this is
just a chess.com puzzle
um
very very difficult to do and there we
see a result big result Maxwell manages
his first win in the Masters Tournament
against Jordan van forest and there we
see the player shake hands big smile for
the Iranian player and uh both players
seem to be in good spirits
yeah
despite one player winning and one
losing I agree yeah no I mean I mean
Jordan didn't seem too fussed about it
he didn't storm out he just uh calmly
shook his opponent's hand and the two
players talked a little bit and then
left and down there we see people
watching the chess and it's so nice to
see people watching Chess at tournaments
I mean this is something that I feel has
been phased phased out in a lot of
tournaments I mean a lot of high level
events they're just no spectators
and that's one of the saddest things
because one of my fondest childhood
memories is going to these high-level
tournaments uh following the analysis
and uh just getting a taste of the whole
atmosphere of these great players
playing and I remember how they used to
have these big demo boards and they
would come and show these and uh all
these variations that they saw and I was
like wow these people are just geniuses
you know I had yeah
it's an important part of growing up
with chess and I I think it's a Pity
that it's being lost so it's really
heartwarming to see that there are
people watching the show and watching
the chess on site and they're there in
Amsterdam in the Johan crufts Arena and
it's great that they also showcase
showcasing the Netherlands and
showcasing important tourist features
and of course it's the home of iax
Football Club
it is indeed and I totally Echo your
sentiment about Spectators
um I remember in 2008 I was in Moscow
and the first time I visited a super
tournament was uh when I went to see the
tall Memorial
uh which was an annual annual super
tournament kramnik was playing leko was
playing and I remember standing in the
in the hall
and watching I got to watch the Players
analyze which was even more fun than
watching them play because I stood right
next to kramnik and I remember you know
coming over to my mom and just saying I
was just pointing and I was just saying
that that's Vladimir kramnik she's I
know who that is and I was like no you
don't understand that is Vladimir
kramnik and I just kept repeating it I
was I was so in awe of actually seeing
these top players and some of the
younger people watching might not relate
to this because nowadays we have the
privilege of being virtually close to a
ton of top players who could tune in any
hour of the day and watch a super GMS
Like Jesse Cara Nakamura Crush everybody
on stream but back then just seeing
these players filled me with so much
inspiration and little did I know that
seven years later I'd be facing Vladimir
kramnik over the board in a classical
game
um and also in a rapid game so just uh
that was that was such a good moment
Okay so we've got the Geary game on the
screen here we have a result
we do have an another result and uh
another draw this time between cash and
report and uh the players are analyzing
they're discussing the lines and I have
to say I do love this particular moment
when players are going through the
variations together because this is one
of the special things about Chess and it
sounds really cheesy but once you played
a game with someone you feel a bond you
feel this bond of friendship that you've
done something special together and
especially if the game's been hard for
it it's been close and you're both of
you trying to work out where one could
have improved it becomes almost like
this sense of unity between the two of
you
at the risk of getting too philosophical
I think you make a great point and I
think some of my friendliest
conversations have been with an opponent
after the game because you the way I've
heard this described is as two authors
that have authored a work of art where
you both had an equal part to plan it so
yes you were competitors yes you were at
each other's throats for the whole game
but you struggled with the same problems
you did it from opposite sides but it
was still the same questions that had to
be answered and the same challenges that
had to be surmounted so I love this as
well just seeing the players share their
opinions kind of an old school fashion
not just running to their hotel rooms
and plugging in the game onto stockfish
but now they set up the pieces it's
dinner time in Amsterdam and another
hard fat draw leaving us with three
ongoing games
yeah and uh on the subject of analysis I
remember two friends of mine had played
this very interesting game and they
analyzed the game afterwards and they
were both on the same wavelengths that
whites have played a great game and they
were like yeah you know it was an
amazing achievement and they both went
back to their respective rooms plugged
in the computer and then there was there
was like this Collective kind of ah when
they realized that white hadn't played a
great attacking game in fact White had
landed a rook at some point like it
literally it was like a knight takes
rook and they'd just not seen it and
this is this is what happens you know
somehow I find chess kind bizarre in
that kind of sense that you can both be
on the same wavelet you can both miss
the same obvious things or you can both
be there matching each other along the
way of playing superb chess
yeah I find that moment so interesting
when I think I've calculated a line
that's so outlandish there's no way my
opponent barked up the same tree and
then you talk after the game and they
did bark up exactly that tree you know
you find that you calculated the same
lines so totally echoing your point
there about being in the same wavelength
with your opponent speaking of
wavelength we should probably check what
wavelength Magnus Carlson is on there's
three games left all of them are in an
end game now aronian Yogi is still plus
1.5 he's got winning chances in the end
game but I'm thinking we should maybe
let them play a couple more moves until
the Smoke Clears there what do you say
we check back into the world champions
game and see how noterbeck's winning
attempt is progressing
yeah definitely because uh it was a bit
of a tall ask for nordibeck last time we
we left this position because Magnus had
set up a great defense and uh as we know
Magnus is the in-game magician
and well we have progress the B Pawn has
advanced two squares
um double-edged sword because it does
mean that the black king doesn't have so
much cover but on the other hand
pushing a pawn that's got to count for
something
when we try to assess positions like
this I think it's important to try to
understand what the good and bad
scenarios look like for each player so
obviously the only way the black is
going to win this game well there's two
ways black and force a queen trade so
Queen F4 would hasten White's defeat the
second way is that black can promote the
pawn now we take the opposite side if
the game ends in a draw how would we
describe the subsequent you know 2025
moves well the only way that white could
force the Drives By Perpetual check so
that's what the battle is going to
revolve around can black continue
pushing his Pawn while keeping the king
relatively sheltered and you can't keep
thinking totally sheltered but what you
can try to do what you often see in
these types of Queen end games is the
king essentially making a bad dash for
the other side of the board and then
trying to use the pawn as an umbrella
imagine a black king on B4 B3 the queen
can be used as an umbrella and soak in
the pawn can white keep the black king
confined to the back couple of rows
where the king doesn't quite have as
much protective cover well we'll see
yeah that is a big question and uh
Magnus has to come up with an answer
because after all his Queen is being
attacked and is very important as you
mentioned he must Dodge any checks that
allows nordebec to exchange of Queens
um
it's it's a tricky kind of situation
here for him because if Magnus does put
his Queen say for instance on A6 I mean
the first move that will come to mind
would be black would then centralize and
improve the queen
by moving her to D4
and then as you mentioned you know you
try to establish a path for the king to
run I've I've I often find that it's
very helpful to visualize a place for it
to hide so you like like you mentioned
B3 would be in my mind I would also
perhaps think of hiding the King on G4
should the white king try to run away to
the Santa or to the queen side
hmm so as long as I have that Vision in
my head I I have a plan
yeah and you need a vision in Queen and
games because you you can't calculate
your way into when there's way too many
options the decision tree is is way too
fast so you're basically operating on
the basis of Target positions you're
aiming for a general type of position
rather than for something specific to
confirm your point Queen A6 I think even
Queen C5 might be uh a little bit more
accurate than Queen D4 just to keep the
B5 Square controls and that's exactly
what white does not want Magnus he's
just put his Queen in front of the pawn
he's saying you can't force a queen
trade and you can't push the pawn away
notabeck's next step is to dislodge to
force the Queen off of B4 and I think
the best way to do that is to inch the
king up to B6 and then slide the queen
over to C5 he was back Prodigy he is
making serious progress here
and there he goes uh and the he goes and
the king is gonna move to B6 and then
there's a big threat of Queen C5 on the
board and what's worrying for Magnus is
he doesn't have any disruptor checks
actually he doesn't have a square to
wait with the King now I look at it like
if the king steps up to F3 I mean you
have to worry about potential Queen E4
checks
um
what else
well King G2 loses on the spot Queen E4
works and you can count that you know
I'll let the chat count themselves but
black is in the Box black stops the pawn
with his King
and the two pawns the black has are too
far apart from each other that's what we
call trousers in Russian chess
terminology
uh two pass pawns on either side of the
board Unstoppable by the lone King
oh I I never knew that expression I'm
gonna put that in my repertoire I like
it nice yeah
it is very nice
um I actually am very seriously worried
for Magnus
I am too um he's
I mean ideally he would actually like
the Queens to trade places you know have
the White Queen be on E5 and The Black
Queen on B4 but nope that's not
happening it's so
okay okay okay so you can step up King
F3
yeah
King B6 yeah and then
white hasn't done a single thing what
about if you put your queen all the way
to see to f8
I think that's what you have to do I
think you have to make a Mad Dash for
the eighth rank to be able to give the
side checks but as we clarified a little
bit earlier it's you can't give
Perpetual in a position like this
because the black king has way too many
Pathways and can use the pawn as
protective cover so for example if we
bring up a board Queen f8 let's say I go
King B6
now you can't check B8 you can check d8
I go King C5
you give another check your checks have
already run out because Queen f8 runs
into an interposition with check
which is why white skin is on a terrible
spot it's constantly walking into these
uh interposition checks
Carlson with G4 he's traded the pawn
yeah he's traded the pawn and I've just
put the table base up and it says
yeah yeah well it makes sense that black
is winning but
and I think it's because White's King is
so terribly placed that is why you are
advised as far as I know in these end
games to keep your king as far away from
the opposing sides Queen and pawn
precisely because
of the possibility that Black Blocks a
check with a check
yeah
yeah oh my gosh this is insane
that means
if naughty back plays this perfectly and
wins
Agnes is going to suffer his second
defeat in a row that is Sensational
stuff and Magnus will lose with the
black pieces
again absolutely unbelievable
goodness me and uh yeah you're right
yeah yes yeah
and uh yeah you don't know which color
Magnus it I'm just kidding
by the way since I think you know since
his loss against Hans demon
his first loss of the white piece that
is with the white pieces yeah
yeah
Goodness Me
it's been a it's been an intense round
and full of surprises and full of some
fabulous complicated tactical games
so
but okay let's run through the technique
then so I mean the white king is badly
placed and it's just a question of
white has to find a place actually to
put the king
and then
the king would presume the white the
black king will presumably run up to the
B1 square and then
assist the pawn in promoting
yeah and there's going to be a a an arc
to the send game I think we're gonna
follow the same pattern again and again
where white gives a series of checks
then white runs out of checks he has to
make a move to improve the placement of
his Queen black pushes the pawn rinse
and repeat white makes another series of
checks check check again white runs out
of checks whatever Queen C6 black hides
rinse and repeat Queen F3 check King B2
black pushes the pawn again now when the
pawn reaches B3 or so you have to be
careful about not hemming in your king
and allowing us some sort of a Perpetual
pattern those patterns do exist but the
queen 95 Yogi is just on an amazing I
mean look at that square it's dominating
every file and every diagonal and once
the pawn reaches B2 then the game is
over white will be on his last legs and
at that point the win is just a
straightforward matter of putting your
queen on the best square and sliding the
king uh to the side of the pawn
Magnus is lost I I just don't see
any realistic chances in the long run
here yeah Magnus can squeeze this out
for another 30 moves but us Notre back
blunder is a pattern of some sort
this is going to be another zero in the
tournament cross stable for the world
champion shocking yeah absolutely
shocking
yeah it is absolutely surprising it's
Sensational I mean it's unheard of at
the same time and the one thing I did
want to mention is take a look at the
black king and the white king they're
opposite each other this is a nice rule
to have in the back of your mind when
you're playing king and queen end games
and you are the aggressor put your king
opposite is counterparts that is the
best Square for it
primarily because a check can be met
with a counter check
that's a great Point yeah money advice
there Kings facing each other you've got
the possibility of a queen trade and
just to take a step back here and remind
everybody of the storyline in this game
Carlson and otterbeck have played in
Rapid defeated Magnus in the world rapid
Championship two years ago this is their
first classical game and it's a matchup
of the generations because Notre Beck
was born in 2004 as we pointed out
earlier Queen Jade on the board by the
way the year that Carlson made his Tata
steel debut now that's just I can repeat
that fact time and again and it's just
as crazy every time
I'm a little bit uncomfortable with that
fact
Tanya because you know we can let's face
it we can all remember what we well not
we can all but I can remember what I was
doing in 2004. I know which Olympiad I
played in
and so just to think that this is
naughty back uh this is the one he was
born
was it the cowboy Olympia sorry to cut
you off there it was it was the cowfield
nice very good Olympiad
and uh it was a great one it was one of
my favorites I have to say it was uh
full of surprising uh surprises I got my
I am Norm there as well
now the most you know what the most
tilting fact about having this with
weight is it's not even the fact that
motorbike is winning it's the fact that
he has 42 minutes on his clock so if
you're Magnus you know that you can't
even hypothetically get into a situation
where yeah you know black has two
minutes he has to dodge and Meander with
his king that's when you miss skewers
and you miss stalematrix and you miss
all sorts of stuff with 42 minutes not
Rebecca can always just take a 20 minute
think if he wants to make sure he's
going to the right spot with his king
that's what I think gives white almost
no hope
but um just I mean
I'm just rewinding and thinking back to
the previous moves
where did Magnus go wrong what was his
losing blunder I mean we saw him take
great risks but we thought hey it was uh
navigable but here is it totally lost I
mean was it earlier on where he could
have perhaps
made a better defensive move in the king
and queen ending or was it much earlier
in the complications before time travel
I think it was much earlier I think I
think it was as far back well first of
all the exchange sacrifice I think in
retrospect in 2020 hindsight we're
obviously going to criticize that and
and I think analysts are going to
criticize that idea especially given
that Magnus had lost the previous game
he was trying to manage his risk but you
can understand what Magnus is going
through he wanted to knock Notre back
out of the park he wanted a confidence
booster and instead he's about to get a
second loss in a row so I think the
exchange sack set him up for failure it
forced him to play Super accurate and
then he made maybe two or three more
inaccuracies in the 20s
and motorbike has just played a perfect
technical game
I mean he hasn't made a single mistake
in the last 15 moves as he was
background Master crazy
he's I mean we've we've gone on and on
about how insanely talented he is
um for me thinking back as well I was
thinking perhaps that key F4 move
um which allowed Nordic to trade into
this favorable Queen important ending
and I remember you were just like whoa
how can he play this and uh yeah turns
out that it was a very difficult uh
in-game that he would fall into
indeed it was and as notorbeck continues
to convert this end game Magnus doesn't
even want to look at the board he's Le
oh I was going to say he's not in a
chair he is in his chair this is I'm
afraid that expression Magnus makes
before he resigns the game so
he might not be long for this board as
he stares in disgust at the position
folks we will take one more quick break
the game is about to enter their sixth
hour and when we return he was back
Phenom continues to try to push for a
shocking Sensational win against Magnus
Carlson here at the 2023 how to steal we
will be right back
[Music]
foreign
that comes to your mind uh the musical
and of course the board game fantastic
okay it's just a sport absolutely very
competitive known worldwide a battle of
wits to the highest degree I imagine
this is the best interview I've ever
given howdy sir I'm doing great are you
an important phone call
okay that's not the first time I've had
people hang up for me thank you
it's chess a sport intellectually yes
okay
kind of like the same type of sport
physically that NASCAR is okay does that
make sense I've actually never heard
that comparison as a guy who's been in
chess my whole life that's a great
comparison hi sir do you play chess
oh speak French okay on poisson
hey that guy was walking on passant
[Applause]
chess
like the gates yes I can beat you and
say okay
[Music]
foreign
the world champion is on the ropes here
in round five of Tata steel chess 2023
you can just feel the consternation the
frustration on Magnus Carlson's
expression as he is about to drop two
games in a row for the first time and
God knows how many years and you will
most likely drop this game at the hands
of the Uzbek Grandmaster Notre back
abdusitor of who will move to Four
Points out of five and unbelievable
start if if Notre back can display some
accurate technique and finish this game
off Yogi
yeah and it certainly looks like he is
headed that way because like you said
unfortunately for the world champion the
technique is pretty simple it's just to
dash up to the B-Line with the King once
it gets checked use the queen as cover
and Advance the B Pawn the plan is as
simple as that and it doesn't matter
whether it takes 60 moves or whether it
takes 10 moves the result unfortunately
is not in doubt the only minuscule
chance that nordibeck has is if he puts
his Queen in the wrong spot and white is
able to secure a Perpetual check
but that's a tough ask that is that is
you have to basically sell set that up
cooperatively and unless notepad Runners
at the pawn or walks into a stalemate
trick he's got 40 minutes on the clock
so the most important thing is for him
to take his time to proceed methodically
and meticulously don't get pinned don't
get skewered just be calm and be careful
and that is exactly what he's done all
game long Magnus has taken a long time
on this move trying to work out any
chance at all can he put his Queen on a
tricky square but we know what the
answer to that is yovi yeah
unfortunately it's not yes
I mean I actually felt that that thing
was more to for the world champion to
gather his thoughts just to collect
himself just to see whether it was
possible to do the job in hand which is
to secure the draw I mean there was also
this moment of realization on the camera
where the world champion just was
thinking where did I go wrong where did
it or just go turn from a drawing
position to a losing position and uh
well there was a lot of regret on the
world champions face but uh now
looking at his body language I see that
yeah he's not feeling too optimistic
either
um
is this difficult to make a suggestion
especially when you know what Black's
plan is going to be and how simple it
will be
it's impossible and Magnus is by the way
down to 20 minutes so he doesn't have
forever uh to procrastinate now this is
one of those end games
where at first of all motorbike is
looking at Magnus like when are you
gonna resign boy but Magnus could resign
it at any moment okay it's just one of
those things where it depends on how
long he wants to suffer here it depends
on whether he Bears out an inkling of
Hope as to notorbeck blundering but just
looking at his body language I I don't
think he is
it's not often you see someone
eyeballing Magnus Carlsen and uh he's
not
he's not looking away is he I I mean
the game is over
as someone who knows he's got it in the
bag
and he's enjoying his moment and
looking at the clock looking at Magnus
another position
yeah when are you gonna resign son
that's the unspoken words uttered by no
Rebecca versus Death Stare there
and he is enjoying every second of this
sipping on his drink I always like to
point out that when somebody
drinks water during a game that
generally means they're satisfied with
their position it means they have the
mental capacity to focus on their
beverage and their snack
and The Spectators anything but the
board because he has it all figured out
and uh he's kind of doing that Beth
Harmon thing you know he's like looking
he's calculating lines he's envisioned
the resulting positions the ones where
he can push forward and he's like yup
yep it's good and he can barely believe
his luck and Magnus
well
he's he's just a man who's desperately
trying to find a solution here and so he
steps up with the King
um can you have three
yep and uh taking a look at the table
base I can see that the path is still
relatively clear you know he can
noribbeck can step up with the black
king he can give a check on C3 the
things he cannot do for instance he and
it's a bit of a ridiculous move is
actually just moved the king to a square
like A6 or C6 then it would turn into a
draw but why would you go backwards or
sideways when you can go forwards
King B5 is is the obvious move to me
because there's still no checks now
there's another thing which you have to
figure out and perhaps okay forget it
King D5 is on the board he's gonna play
this perfectly I was gonna ask Queen C3
check and B3 with the King on B6 that
could get dicey with white delivering
all these back range checks it's
probably was still winning but you can
do this whenever you want just King B5
and now you're ready to play Queen C3
and B3 and zigzag Meander the king all
the way back around behind the pawn the
path is so clear it's laid out with
beautifully paved roads and you just got
a road going straight to the straight
through the forest here
yeah and there's signposts along the way
so it's all pretty pretty clear-cut I
mean like there is one there was one
trick in the position that I can see
um say for instance a miracle happens
and uh the queen uh maybe you could set
this up so the king will find itself on
B3 and the queen uh will be on B1
okay yeah
so there you go and then Queen B1 check
and uh yeah okay let's forget that Queen
B2 is possible you do not want to play
King sea yeah
oh that would be that would be bad I
would I would quit chess if I did
something I would literally if I lost a
Magnus like this I would get up from the
board and right then and there with
other games still going I would announce
my retirement
yeah
but you couldn't though because you're
playing Tata and you have to show up the
next day yeah
[Laughter]
but you could do like the the famous uh
interviewed by Ivan sokoloff that was
great where he said if he survives the
night he will live to 10 000 years
oh that is a great phrase
I mean yeah the Heartbreak the chest
chest is like that
speaking of Ivan sagalov he played his
role in the development of Notre back
into the Beast that he now is the
Utterback part of the Olympiad winning
Uzbek team
um at the Chennai Olympiad an
unbelievable Cinderella run by a team
that did not have at the time uh a
single player over 2700 but of course
Notre back was still 26 something
something he was 2700 in his heart and
Yvonne sokolov was the chief trainer the
coach of that Olympiad team he did a lot
of work with this new crop of young
Uzbek Talent which is just growing more
impressive really by the day by the win
and otterbeck isn't the only once in
darav and uh vohidov and Wahid of and
any eat of I mean you've got like five
or six incredibly talented GM's
headlined of course by Notre Beck
himself
yeah
um I mean yvon sokolov did a massive job
with a used back in team he really
guided them the talent was already there
in place and uh he gave instructions and
one thing that did make me chuckle is
that they asked him can this is the team
can we go to the Bermuda party he found
circle of who as far as I remember
always went to the Bermuda parties when
he was playing said no
you can have time for distractions after
the event now you're not going to go to
the Bermuda party and you're going to
focus on the chess and I also like this
Clash of old school versus new school
you know he bought with him lots of
fresh ideas and the youngsters were all
running his ideas with the engines and
so he was just that guiding influence
and say you know giving giving like
positivity giving some constructive
thoughts and uh that's all you need at
times someone who puts you in a good
mood someone who can inspire you and you
could just see that the uzbeks created a
huge sensation by winning the Olympiad I
mean everyone thought sorry sorry Dania
the Americans had it in the bag but
things didn't quite gel for them
no no I mean team team us just didn't
didn't have its greatest run I mean they
did okay but obviously anything except
gold medal is essentially disappointment
for this All-Star team
but team Uzbekistan I mean that's really
when a lot of people that's when the
rubber hit the road and I think a lot of
Chess fans really started to understand
that notorack is a world champion
Contender he's not just going to be a
quote-unquote run-of-the-mill super GM
that's an oxymoron I know but with every
passing tournament I think he is making
a very strong case that it's not just
Ali Raza farusia from this new
generation who's got a chance to one day
sit Atop The Mount Olympus of Chess
noterbeck is right up there in the
equation and another look there at
Magnus he just keeps looking at him
world champion
uh he's gonna get up oh he's taking a
deep breath it's very good to study the
nerves and
he's good you must remember never to
lose focus it's not over until you get
the handshake from Magnus
and that's such an easy thing to forget
because at this point you must be riding
High when you know you've got it in the
bag you know you're going to win and you
can see he's suppressing smile he's
working hard
just to keep the composure and Magnus
moves his King to G2 just just check
check on the third Rank and go P3 and
that's it
just Queen E2 check is easy I think or
queen E4 check doesn't matter if it
Force the white king onto a square such
that Queen E3 comes with checks so that
you can then play B3 and do the zigzag
thing Magnus will probably my estimate
would be maybe another five or six moves
and another Brick's not going to keep
him waiting I mean noterbeck knows what
the winning plan is I love the
confidence right I would probably be
taking seven minutes on every move but
underberg knows that he's got this in
the bag and there's no need to
procrastinate
yeah
yeah I I there is no need to
procrastinate but it is a good idea not
to rush I mean that was something I was
taught by one of my first coaches he
said to me when it comes to the end game
you can hurry never rush and uh don't
play the moves instantly and this is
something I'm actually attempted to do a
lot of the time the emotion gets too
much and the excitement is there and I
just lash out with the move and I
haven't calculated it properly I haven't
taken my time to be cautious and there
we go we need you on the board we need
to it's happening
yeah yeah yeah Magnus is going to move
his King I would imagine forward to G3
Notre back is going to step back with
this queen and once the pawn lands on B3
I think that is going to be the
threshold once that threshold is crossed
that's where I think we're going to see
the handshake
oh
it's humidity
no he hasn't but I thought we were going
to see a result and uh speaking of
results
yes
giri their game ended in a hard-fought
draw
well let's give ourselves a little
credit we called it they went down the
exact path we had analyzed if we rewind
a little bit as we see the players there
amicably discussing the game and setting
up the pieces they liquidated the beep
on for the a pawn
Anisha decided not to go King E4 that
might have been a chance to torture
Prague a little bit further I think frog
must have been very relieved to CD3 and
they got a situation where neither side
is able to make any progress
another peaceful results and a good
result for Anisha leads the tournament
right now and holds the draw with the
black pieces solid
yeah very solid but uh he is the
tournament leader but not for long
because if we were to go back to there
we see the players the score Sheet's
still talking and uh
we've seen another check King has moved
up the board and
this is fascinating
Queen up to E3 goes Notre back oh he's
playing fast prediction
I'm speaking to my prediction once the
pawn hits B3 I think he's gonna resign
okay I was gonna say B2
I I don't know somehow I feel that
Magnus is a never give up and look he's
got a bathroom up yes but this is a good
sign this means that he's willing to
play a long long game
if you gotta go you got to go I actually
think he might be ooh there's an Arbiter
there not sure what he's doing or maybe
Magnus checking out the results on the
other boards as well anything to
distract himself from this position
Notre back double checking there you
called it you'll be noticed that he's
taking right around a minute two minutes
a lot of young players they get very
excited and they play in five seconds
that's what you want to avoid B3 is on
the board
and this game is wrapping up at a
furious pace
yep and uh look how measured he is I
just love the composure that he has when
he makes those moves with his hands
and in
deep breath
Ness back
he and his
he gonna resign though that's the big
question
not her back just you know drinking that
water enjoying himself immensely let me
tell you he is euphoric right now on the
inside
because he knows how the game is gonna
end there's not an inkling of Doubt left
well
Never Say Never it's not over until
until it's over I was gonna say the
other the other quote but I won't say
that one I know which one you're
referring to so yeah
[Laughter]
to keep commentating please thank you
very much uh yes
Okay so
what is Magnus going to do if he doesn't
resign
I just make a spike check
no check the King on B8 you know
can't even check along the diagonals I
mean that's the only move you can do
um
he is he's looking at Magnus to the
progressive air of impatience like first
it was I got you now it's like really
Riley I mean are we really are you
really holding me back from going to
Tarantella oh no they're in Amsterdam
Tarantella is the pizza the only
Pizzeria in wake and say it's the
player's favorite restaurant
so if I'm Notre back I'm starting to
think about pizza
and nothing tastes better than pizza
after beating the world champion as if
presumably they have to go back to their
hotels in vike
oh maybe there's a train to catch or
there's a car ready to
furry them to their destination so maybe
they are gonna have dinner at Tarantella
maybe it's a bit late Actually it's
seven
before you're so late
well seven six hour difference from the
East Coast so it's 7 P.M there right now
yep yeah I think uh
you know that's a perfect time for
dinner and it's funny the first time I
visited vikon say I played a qualifier
for
out of steel I didn't qualify spoiler
alert but when we landed the organizer
was warning us and warning us about how
far Wake On Zay is from Amsterdam as it
is you know I hate to say it it's
grueling it's a 30 minute train ride and
I was gonna say in America we drive 30
minutes to get our groceries so you're
not gonna scare me with that
[Laughter]
30 minute train ride is quite
significant
um but I I agree with you I live in
Norway now and it's it can be like
to the nearest city it will be
three hours drive oh wow
that's that's quite a distance it is and
uh you kind of don't grasp how remote it
is until you actually be in there but uh
yeah 30 minutes Drive I also wouldn't be
phased by it but uh I've been also been
very swayed by the Nordic culture
because here it's all about early
dinners not about late dinners at all so
yeah seven eight p.m by 10 p.m all the
restaurants are closed
yeah I mean it's the same here I think
it's similar to to America 9 p.m is
where like 90 of restaurants close here
okay we have a Splat check on the board
the king is going to zigzag up instantly
now yes but now this is the crucial
question to decide an issue between
Dania and myself when will Magnus resign
when the pawn is on B3 or B2
that's where we're betting right
I bet B3 you say B2 now maybe it'll be
in the middle it'll be the exact moment
that Notre back is pushing that pawn
Magnus stops the clock when the pawn is
on B two and a half
oh then then it's a draw
I look forward
to seeing that occur
it's terrifying how bored motorbeck
seems as it's like just another day in
the office you know you're beating world
champion with black and a queen end game
and he's about to go King C3 and King C2
and that's the whole point then you can
block all of the checks with your queen
yeah
and uh it's it's a great technique you
know put the black king opposite is
counterparts and White's King is so
badly placed that counter checks are
Rife in the position and here comes oh
somehow I'm thinking that to he will
resign now it's on the worst Square on
the board I mean and again that's why in
books on end games they often recommend
putting your king in the opposite corner
precisely to prevent the scenario
unfolding here if the white King was on
A8 there would actually be some drawing
chances because white could basically
check with abandon now I mean if you
give any check you're gonna have to
abandon the game
because black is going to interpose with
a check as we've been
indicating throughout this end game
another spy check by Magnus
and where is he gonna go King D2 there's
our answer
and okay
88 check probably
yeah it's as good as check as anything
uh the king will just move to C2
and then hardly any checks left on the
board
I even like Queen D3 in response
maybe then Queen A5 check
now but nothing works then pc1 I mean
literally any path you take is going to
lead to an exhaustion of the checks the
checks being exhausted
and uh how will he handle say for
instance the queen does find its way on
A5 and the king is on C2 I mean one
defensive technique is simply to pin the
pawn so you don't have any good checks
you just put your queen in say A4 and
you say you can't advance that way
yeah so I think that's why the simple
approach for Notre back
um and if we could pull up an analysis
board here this might happen let's say
queen D7 check happens
now Queen D3 here is the best move
but you can play King C2 and what you're
saying is that white can try to cling to
the game with Queen A4 I think the
simplest is just to put the king in
front of the pawn looks a little
counter-intuitive right like why would
you block the pawn but this is an
intermediate step I'm afraid you might
be right I think you might have to push
this Pawn to B2 and demonstrate this
technique then
you bring your queen like on a square
like D3 you step back to C2 and you
zigzag your king eventually White's
gonna run out of checks it's just an
inevitability
yeah all right back live forward
yeah but uh those are the kind of two
defensive
um techniques that I know and also the
white king isn't well placed I was
thinking for some stalemating tricks
nothing happening there and uh the queen
comes to age eight threatening Queen B2
is gonna happen
undoubtedly
either that or he's going to
give us some checks but there's no need
um
uh okay so I was looking at the table
base so King C1 wins King C2 wins King
D1 wins King E1 oh my God stepping in
the wrong direction that is going to
draw
[Laughter]
and uh a bad Square for the queen would
be Queen E1 and that makes a lot of
sense because Queen beats here is
threatened oh no yeah that definitely
one of what I think Notre back is
deciding between King C1 and King C2
it's important to point out that King C1
walks into Queen A1 check but that
doesn't help because then the king moves
up to C2 and the pawn is actually upon
in the king dominate The White Queen
when the White Queen Is At Close
Quarters with the king that's when it's
at its least effective
um yeah oh God Magnus is disgusted
he wants this game to end
and he he's really just thinking back to
his previous moves and trying to figure
out where did he go wrong he's using the
energy there he just knows that this is
a hopeless task in front of him he
cannot save the game and he's just
resigning himself to the fact that he
will lose his second game in a row King
moves to C2
there it is
Mr Cool
slice the king one square B2 is a big
threat
there's no rush on the clock but there's
also no rush on the board you're not at
risk of a 50 move rule you've got about
47 more moves and so that becomes an
issue so you're just you know moving
your King around until you find the
ideal construction between your king and
your queen that enables the pawn to inch
forward to B2 Magnus also with nine
minutes
but uh the 15 minute Edition after move
60 is going to be a totally moot point
yeah and I was wondering what's White's
best practical chance I was wondering
whether the queen could come to A1
and uh whether for instance if black
managed to push the pawn to B2 there was
any chance of a perpetual and the answer
is no so even the most obvious move on
on the boards are going to win it for
black
yes they are and we've entered the sixth
hour of play here in tata Steelers
Carlson continues to give a series of
speight checks
um resignation is coming but I think
you're getting proven right if Magnus
hasn't resigned yet that probably means
he wants to let the pawn reach P2 first
yeah maybe we're wrong maybe maybe the
pawn will Queen and that's right he'll
finally give up the ghost
so
what's the actual best move I would
imagine that it's Queen C3
Queen F5 check
and then Queen to D3
okay King D1 whoa
oh because there's no checks nope
no not at all because uh the queen will
intercept on the second row and give a
counter check
and uh
okay but the king is no longer guarding
the B Pawn so I guess the queen could
put herself
on the B-Line just
B8 B7
I'm trying to figure out to your earlier
point if the pawn reaches B2 is there
ever any construction where white can
continue giving Queen checks and black
somehow cannot maneuver the king to a
proper square and I'm thinking after
Queen B7 Queen D2 check King moves away
B2
is there anything available no I don't
think so
Queen eight shaped by Magnus
I think just Queen D2 checking B2 ends
the game
As Natural as can be
Queen D2 check
King has to step forward
B2 I mean is he maybe hoping to kind of
go Queen H7 and try to get the queen on
some awkward Square I mean but it is
wishful thinking ultimately
plays good chess doesn't even have to be
perfect I mean I'm just again looking at
the table base and I can see
virtually anything wins as long as he
doesn't put his King on the E line which
let's face it no one is going to do that
everyone is going to support their
passport
the reason that Magnus is continuing to
play I think consists in a line like
this so let's pull up an announce board
here Queen D2 Trek is very likely what's
going to happen B2 it's not immediately
over after Queen H7 like black has to
actually figure out a way to promote the
pawn
but I think the way to do that is to go
Queen CJ now careful Queen E1 would have
been Checkmate so you know that's
something you have to be cautious about
Magnus is going to continue checking and
checking and black has to finagle you
know some construction here it's still
not
that easy to do so so White's gonna kind
of keep waiting with his Queen
and in a situation like this actually
over this starts getting a little bit
more complicated than it looks because
any time the king moves away the queen
starts giving these diagonal checks so
there's a little bit of calculation
remaining to be done
yeah
that is true and
oh Magnus taking a sip of water
yeah there is still
play but it really is just about you can
even stumble upon the right
configuration with the king and queen
this is this is the whole beauty of
Black's position you don't have to win
in 20 moves you don't have to win in
five moves you can even take you 50
moves or win is a win
um it can be as Scrappy as you like it
can be bad technique but the result
is not really in doubt
um no
hmm I mean I can I can start to
understand what why I will be honest I
was kind of skeptical in the sense that
I I thought it was over over but now I'm
beginning to see that there is still
it still makes sense to not resign I'll
put it that way the result isn't in
question but I think it's admirable
actually that Magnus is putting himself
through the suffering and squeezing out
every last chance even if there are no
chances here that's what world champions
do right this is not something he's
forcing himself to do this is just who
he is as a player and as a person he
plays until the last drop of blood no
matter how miserable he is at the board
yeah they have a catchphrase
um he talks about it in the grind like a
grand master course that he did with
David Howe and they say you're not out
to win friends you're just out to save
every half point or squeeze a victory
from a point
and if it takes you eight hours to do it
so be it
um it's quite refreshing kind of
philosophy because I must admit there
comes a time when I'm just like okay
seven hours in I'm exhausted I just want
to go have my dinner I do not want to be
paying any more chess but uh Magnus
shows that he's not afraid of grinding
out those long end games playing out
those dead drawn positions or playing
out these technically lost positions
um
you know it's not over until nordebec
demonstrates the correct endgame
technique and so he's given a check King
has to move uh this is a dilemma do you
move up the board do you move down the
board
um should you put it
I think you moved down the board
yeah I'm I think so too because the
Queen the black queen could give some
checks on the third row and that would
in some situations nicely cover the
black king so I would probably put the
king H1 just
just just because they often say you
know just put the king in a corner just
tuck it out of Harm's Way
well yeah you should definitely try
because the king H1 does set up some
still made ideas if you imagine a queen
appearing on G3 so it doesn't hurt you
know it's definitely the best of the
best of the worst so to speak
but Magnus gonna take his last four
minutes
there is 15 more minutes added after the
next move is executed
but Notre back the last thing he needs
right now is 15 minutes I think he needs
the most there's probably some food and
a little bit of Celebration
but um
my dad would actually always say after I
would play a long game and I'd be I was
like my opponent didn't resign you know
it was such a long game you'd say on the
on the tournament cross table do they
record the amount of moves that each win
took and it would be a rhetorical
question of course the answer is no
um a win in 70 Moves a winning 30 moves
a win in seven hours or in three hours
it's all the same it's a point on the
cross table
in G3
King G3 um surprising Choice the first
move that comes to mind is beating and
hastens it that hastens it I mean he
wants to give up
because after B2 basically black can
check the the king with the queen and
simultaneously pave the way for
promotion so be too simply ends the game
on the spot and there he goes and
reaching out to touch the pawn
um yeah I was surprised by that uh move
from Magnus is like you say the queen
queen can block her any checks on the
third row with a counter check
that was a bad move by Magnus and I I
really don't see do not understand why
he played this long and then makes a
move that is literally equivalent to
capitulating I also don't understand why
Notre back is not playing B2 because B2
Queen H7 okay he just did
Queen C3 check if you go to the second
rank you allow the queen shred if you go
to the fourth rank the queen moves back
to B4 and the reason I'm saying this and
talking so much is to hide the fact that
you were proven right
in terms of where the pawn is going to
appear when white resigns
yes I I have this uncanny ability to get
random things correct
where is Magnus
he's he's out of there he had enough
he's getting ready to resign I think he
knows that King G3 is a big mistake and
there we see the spectators
oh they're getting ready for another
historic moment at if I can say Magnus
Carlsen has will be losing his second
game in a row
and uh yeah with the white pieces as
well that's extra painful I mean
normally you kind of talk when with
white draw with black
and here Magnus just took one too many
risks and I have to say I've been very
impressed by Abdus
he's handled everything perfectly
he really played this game like a true
champion
he he really has and you know do not be
fooled by his dispassionate expression
he must be euphoric he must be thrilled
and he deserves to be and that this will
Propel him to four out of five it's
still just the start of I mean we're not
at the halfway point it's not just the
start so he's already proven himself an
absolute beast but he's gonna have to
keep his foot on the gas pedal you don't
win a tournament by just beating Magnus
Carlson
just in error codes you win the
tournament by being consistent
throughout all 13 Rounds there we go
Magnus recording B2 and The Spectators
holding their breath
no a little sip of water
stealing himself before resigning
so I suppose
it is
to do
and no Queen H5 still King C2
yeah everything everything is a queen
king C2
cream of it
actually you can you can't play Queen H1
check because of Queen E1 oh oh that's
this last move was horrible I mean he he
really had to try to go back to the
first rank it wasn't totally over there
oh yeah I mean there was still some
chances to save the game but no not
after King G3 it is the final mistake
and uh Queen Queen H5 is your only
chance
and absolutely all credit to Notre back
Magnus did not play a bad game okay
Magnus actually played a very decent
game
in the exchange
he followed it up accurately for a while
an older back just playing a modern
brilliancy just all stages of the game
he handled with such deafness and such
Verve honestly I'm just so impressed
yeah me too I mean this Gamepad it all
you know it started off quietly it was a
nice strategical battle and their
magnets up the stakes and then we had
this insane time trouble and there we
see that uh noribbeck didn't Flinch and
he used every chance that was given to
him and I'm impressed by his Queen and
porn in-game technique because I
honestly thought that Magnus would save
it I thought that it was there was no
chance that nor do better it is
and we have a result and there we see
the players analyzing a sensational
moment Magnus Carlson losing his second
game in a row
and what's crazy is that the last time
that has happened great work by our team
was in 2015. that's eight years ago
ladies and gentlemen in Norway chess
2015. that feels like a different era
that was the last time that Magnus
Carlson lost two classical games in our
own now in tata steel 2023. Magnus is
going to have two points out of five and
a lot of coming back to do if he wants
to score in the top half of the
tournament cross table
and uh absolute the blinding result by
the usback I mean I've been so impressed
by him I I can't use enough superlatives
to talk about him and uh there we can
see the results of today's matchups so
we see a lot of draws the big news max
sudlu beating Jordan van Ferris and of
course the headline match Magnus Carlson
losing with the white pieces against the
Young nordebec abdusa tarov
clear first
yeah four points out of five
what a performance what a start from the
teenager
shell shock there's just a feeling of
shell shock when the world champion
loses but Abdus you know you just start
singing these young players Praises so
much but like you said I don't know of a
superlative that accurately captures the
rise of Notre back and the consistency
that he's displayed which is
uncharacteristic for someone who has
just recently made their way into Super
Grand Master land and the players have
gotten up from the board that is it
ladies and gentlemen Magnus loses that
leaves us with only one game remaining
here in round five
wow
okay and it's the aronian kymer game
yovi what do we make of this
yeah I mean a long long time ago it
feels completely like a different
lifetime it felt like LaVon aronian had
it in the bag very comfortable position
now something has gone wrong and I think
this position looks very even I mean I
don't even see a winning attempt for
white in fact I I do feel that
whites might have to proceed with care
in some lines
yeah you pointed out Bishop A4 during
the break if the Knight Strays too far
from D3 and the King too far from the
center
the only hypothetical way that white has
to break through
is to push C5 but the problem with
pushing C5 is are you opened this up too
early and like you said well it's got a
bunch of weaknesses too so if white
plays C5 let's take a quick look at this
after DC
Knight C5
don't go King D6 and walk into a fork
but just Bishop B6
Knight D3 Bishop B5 and even just taking
on D3 is the draw the Bishops are way
too active
yeah I mean but in this type of position
I I with the bishop pair and the
position opening up which favors the
bishoper
um yeah I I would be playing for the win
so this is what I mean about proceeding
with care I mean you shouldn't take too
many risks yes you might have been
winning earlier on maybe the advantage
was was slightly less but nope forget it
be realistic you have to play the
position that's on the board not the
history not the story and uh well
Vincent just shuffling the bishop
backwards and forwards
I mean that's all he can do for the time
being is just wait and see
for levonne aronian to react and uh
another thing that I was
and uh Lavon also maneuvering his Bishop
yeah well
I mean it's a small gain isn't it
he's stopped stabbing Bishop B8
Bishop yeah but the bishop does have the
G8 Square to
yeah working working F6 like yeah Ernie
can also play H4 but to your point you
don't want to do this in a wrong moment
and you know somehow give up the pawn of
course B4 like I said on it before but
what does H4 accomplish white can never
really go H5 because black controls that
square with the pawn and the bishop
so I don't see even a single way to
generate Intrigue and Heimer has time
he's about to make move 60 and get
another 15 minutes on the clock maybe
we'll see Lavon maneuvering his night
somewhere but where what's the target
Square for the night D4 to C6 would be
nice but the moment white comes even
close to that black slides the bishop
back to B6 and really the weakness of
the F4 Pawn really circumscribes White's
activity and White's ability to maneuver
in the way that he wants to
yeah it's
not easy at all with this bishop giving
a check
um
yeah
somehow I wasn't a big fan of uh Vincent
waiting with the bishop on F7 I felt
that he could have waited on maybe D7
but still his position is incredibly
solid
um the white king can't step forward
again because of check
um
the white king can run to the to the
side of the board but what's it doing
there
nothing no nothing nothing at all right
is a force field
and yeah
the only thing that I can see
is that maybe
and it's a big big ask maybe uh
white can sacrifice the pawn on C5
and just give it up kind of have some
kind of construction where
the bishop goes to C6 Pawn goes to C5
and then drop the Knight back at the
right minute and then come in with the
King to C4
or potential then yeah but then again
I've kind of again opened up the
position for the dark Square bishop and
you know White's position is also not
without its weaknesses I'm looking at
the pawn on F4
um yeah and it just feels like it
depends on a lot of ifs you know if y
can get the bishop to C6 if I can do
that this and that it's there's a
Winston Churchill quote I don't remember
how it goes I think it's the great ifs
accumulate and uh it's just there's too
many moving parts to put in place LeBron
does go H4 so he's gonna keep trying
he's not gonna give up the draw just yet
he's gonna make Vincent Heimer prove it
and we are going to take that
opportunity to take another break
because we are six and a half hours into
round five here at the Tata steel coming
your way from Amsterdam but first we
want to remind you of another very
exciting event Mark your Challengers
because bullet brawl Arenas are coming
back to your screens starting January
28th nine days from now title players
will compete in a two-hour arena with
twenty five hundred dollars on the line
yes 2 500. watch as your favorite
streamers battle it out in monthly books
for all arenas starting Saturday January
28th use x Glam brawl in the chat for
all the details bullet crawls Tata Steel
World Championship what more can you ask
if you are a chess fan well you can ask
for us to return soon and we will indeed
we will take a quick short break and we
will be back with coverage of the final
Tata Steel game on the other side of the
spring
foreign
[Music]
you know we all have nicknames
um Chicago is naturally where I'm born
and raised so that's how I got the name
I guess they call me the muscle I'm the
one with the passion I'm always looking
for a good fight you know evidently they
don't make a difference man that's
Checkmate coming up they don't matter
what we're trying to do is to let them
know hey we playing down here in Houston
Texas
and if you come down here help step in
trust me we're going to beat you you
better bring your game
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
welcome back to our coverage of Tata
steel chess 2023 there's one game left
in round five it is Lavon ronian against
Vincent kymer Lavon trying to squeeze a
win out for about 50 moves now but
Vincent is very very close to holding
this game he's just gotten an additional
boost of 15 minutes because move 60 has
been played as we review the time
control there I am Ivanka Huska GM
Daniel nerdinski bringing you coverage
of this very important fifth round where
the world champion has gone down for the
second time in a row we have gotten
everything we could ask for Yogi in this
round
yeah absolutely I mean we had mad
attacks we had complicated time
scrambles and we also had Sensational
results I mean who could have predicted
that Magnus Carlson would fall to the
young Uzbek with the white pieces I mean
that was abs absolutely unheard of it
was not present in my kind of scenario
of how things would play out but what
can we say I mean the uzbeki played a
fantastic game I've been so impressed
with him it was a nearly Flawless
performance in fact I'm saying nearly
flawless I think it was just flawless
well I like repeating the the uh quote
that I think was attributed to one of
Alexander alakyne's uh contemporaries
who said that alkyne uh had to be beaten
three times right once in the opening
once in the middle game once in the end
game and that certainly goes for Magnus
Carlson and he was beaten well he wasn't
really beaten in the opening behind us
had a small Advantage but he most
definitely was beaten in both the middle
game and the end game the way that Notre
back handled both a tactical position
and then a strategic game where the
Queen's postured for position and then
perfect play in the end game to get into
that Queen end game and then convert it
as if he does that kind of stuff for
breakfast is Sensational absolutely
sensational
yeah and uh just no other words for it
and what a result and well played I mean
I can only say Chapo to the Nordic he's
just brilliant and if he carries on
playing like this
well we're going to see someone who has
strong chances of winning and uh talking
about youngsters uh Vincent has made a
move he's relocated his Bishop you know
after all he's been given the chance to
improve the bishop yeah so he does and
uh where is White's night going nowhere
he's probably gonna go to H1 and then G3
but what's the point of that I mean
you're not really ever
going H5 he goes not age three
okay once night Chief five what what
then I mean black just keeps the bishop
on F7 obviously the opposite colored end
game is just an immediate draw maybe
this is lavon's way of essentially
forcing the draw he's not just going to
go back and forth for no reason
he might have a construction in mind but
I don't see it
I don't I don't see it either and uh
what about a situation where same
Bishops are on the board so I'm thinking
for instance if the Knight does arrive
to G5 and black decides to trade off
that Knight with his dark Square Bishop
is that a draw are we in dangerous
territory here it's a it's a great
question and you know 53 000 heard you
ask that question so just wanted to
quickly shout out our 33k viewers on
Twitch and 20K on YouTube but you're
asking the right question you always
have to consider what happens in the
event of every trade if same colored
Bishops I think white wins I think white
would win by dragging the king over to
D4 and then smashing through with C5
that's why like needs to keep his dark
scored Bishop at all costs it's
preventing white from playing C5
yeah a good point is always very
instructive to know which trades are
possible and which ones are not and now
I presume all that uh Vincent has to do
is just continue passing with this dark
Square Bishop how is white going to make
it inroad he steps back with his King
not a problem maybe bishop oh Bishop D7
there's Bishop takes D5 again Levon
certainly does not want to do anything
foolish
um he might just take the bishop and
offer a draw I mean at some point he's
just gonna say listen you know moving
back and forth just because you're up
upon and technically are better makes no
sense
so yeah he doesn't want to sit there for
no reason just as much as Vincent and
the question really is when is he going
to admit that his winning attempts have
failed
well we'll find out I think part of the
problem though is that White's poems on
the right
they're isolated they're those trousers
they don't protect each other so I mean
if I was thinking about your idea of
Bishop D7 which unfortunately doesn't
work but if you have a kind of scenario
where the Bishops do get traded off you
still can't press for a win because the
pawn on H4 and F4 are on dark squares
and black has the perfect attacking
peace for those pawns
um
it's I mean okay you came up with a nice
idea of Bishop D7 how about I refine it
and put the bishop on A6 oh and then go
to C8 and then go to E6
um I see
but I'm not quite sure what I'm doing
afterwards if you decline the trade so
let's let's forecast that
yeah Bishop B8 yeah ah but now I can
already play H5 so this is okay this I
think is the scenario that black has to
try to avoid because it's not that white
is winning here this might still be a
draw but this forces black to deal with
a new set of challenges and with 15
minutes now for the rest of the game
this is the last thing Vincent kymer
wants so how do you avoid this if you're
playing Black well probably you go for
your advice and maybe even take the
bishop
okay
because
why to us yes
um but wait one second wait one second
white doesn't have to offer a trade of
Bishops what happens if white just plays
H5 where Parks the bishop on C8 so
yeah just go H5 now I didn't realize
that I thought you have to play Bishop
E6 you're absolutely right you don't
ha
oh then
I think you can't really allow H6 maybe
you can allow h
maybe bishop G7
oh gosh but this feels very flimsy now
white can create another weakness
I have probably still a fortress but
this is not ideal for Vincent can he
avoid this scenario
yeah uh so if we rewind and put the
bishop back on C8 so you have a move so
I don't think you can stop the bishop
actually you cannot stop them you're not
getting to see eight there watching this
planet you can try to stop H5 though you
can get this Construction
yeah right now you've got to be careful
tonight
oh gosh
huh
this is gnarly
but if it does does that really do
anything
like I go back
C5 is never good opening up the position
favors the Bishops
I still don't think it's gonna be enough
are you sure about yes
yeah hang on a second it doesn't work
because the bishop gets out to C6 with
checks so now white just has to put the
King on
somehow you have to be crafty about this
whole thing you have to do it with white
King on E3 or something but we don't
have to do these kind of like
uh-huh sorry go ahead yeah I was
thinking about using the old tactic that
these Grinders do they they play Nothing
moves for like 40 moves they're just
like shuffling the king side to side and
then they set up this construction and I
was thinking if you set that set up this
whole thing with the King on E3 mm-hmm
well or somewhere where it doesn't get
checked yeah
so uh there is this idea of going Bishop
A6 to B5 and forcing Black's Bishop onto
F7 Bishop A6 is on the board by the way
we called it and if you can force the
bishop to F7 then the Knight is sort of
free to roam about the cabin and it
doesn't have to worry about the black
Bishop competing for the same territory
I don't know I don't know if that is a
dead end itself but Levant is nothing to
lose and that's the fun of playing these
types of positions from the better side
from The Winning Side yeah
and yeah I mean you can take your time
something that I've been told many times
it's like don't rush don't uh Reveal
Your Cards too early if you spot a
potential trappy idea you know try to
implement it at a later stage first of
all catch your opponent off guard by
wasting time making seemingly useless
moves or nothing moves and then strike
it's time
yeah and also you love them into false
sense of security because they're
thinking hey you know what it's just
going to be a draw you're wasting time
why am I playing here and they start in
envisaging like this draw
and in the meantime you had something
sneaking up your sleeve
and what you want to be able to do is is
not necessarily win objectively because
objectively this position should be a
draw it's to face your opponent with a
new set of challenges I think that's the
first step because as you said when
you're to borrow your phraseology
envisaging the draw and then suddenly
that's taken away from you and you've
got this new set of problems you have to
confront that makes it so much more
likely that a player makes a mistake
even a player of climber's caliber so
love what aronian is doing here he's
exploiting his chances but Vincent
doesn't seem worried he's blaming should
be eight
four
no Bishop A4 doesn't work white just
plays HG and G7 wait whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa
no levant's got to go a try but he
raises eyebrows there
he's allowed it
is
more circumspect he's gonna do it this
is chance
yeah you can just see you know before he
has kind of resigned himself to the
possibility that it could be a draw and
now he's in calculation mode look at the
focus and he's a direct player look at
him he needs no moment to wait he's not
hesitating at all age five on the board
be still my Beating Heart I am changing
my tune completely here
now I can almost bet my house that uh
this is still a draw
maybe the best approach for Vincent is
to play what we discussed earlier and
just to go Bishop D4 as terrifying as it
is to allow the pawn to reach H7 because
white lacks a dark squared Bishop as
long as you keep it on this diagonal you
should prevent promotion but then C5
becomes a much bigger problem creating
potential trousers I mean because DC is
going to be forced you can't move the
bishop away
yeah no I mean this is terrifying stuff
like you said
um I I don't think I could
psychologically allow the white porn to
get to age seven knowing that it's
protected and one square away from
queening and plus at the back of my mind
I would be thinking of this old saying
which is that a bishop can't dance
two weddings so that just kind of refers
to the fact that when a bishop can
defend along one diagonal it's a very
good piece but if you stretch it to so
it has to defend against another
diagonal
so we're gonna get a failure and uh
there we see that uh Vincent is not
allowing a past H Pawn and now we have a
complete imbalance and there's been a
big change in the position I mean white
now has a past F Pawn
great are we from Levon
I loved the singer two winning score
this reminds me of the equivalent
Russian saying can't sit on two chairs I
mean you actually kind of can but you
get the point
um but there's also an old uh sort of
Russian Jewish joke on a similar topic
which is which goes something like
um two friends are are meeting and it's
one of their birthdays and the other
friend gives him two ties like tie that
you wear so the next day one of the
friends comes out wearing one of the
ties and his friend says what you didn't
like the other tie
so that's a funny expression of course
the point is those people who need an
explanation whichever tie you're gonna
wear
you're going to look upon it
pessimistically and uh say why didn't
you wear the other tie one more joke if
I may before we get to this end game of
course let me try to remember how it
goes It goes something like oh what's
the difference in a pessimist and an
optimist
um an optimist a pessimist says things
cannot get any worse The Optimist says
sure they can
that was a great one I'm gonna add that
one to my collection your cocktail party
collection anyways I sorry for the
detour
oh it was nice talking
speaking of detours that Bishop
detouring to D4
actually I was thinking that joke is
like the perfect analogy for this
position you can just imagine that uh
Kim was thinking oh things can't get any
worse lavon's smiling H5 hold my beer
sure they can
no exactly
okay okay so we joke but uh okay now the
task in hand is uh quite difficult for
Vincent white is going to go about just
improving his Knight there you go he's
centralized it and the white king is
going to start working its way over to
the H4 Square
and it's if you're on the defending
uh-huh
no I mean I go go for it
well if you're on the defending side I
think it's important to identify sources
of danger like where is the danger going
to come from and there's multiple you
mentioned King G3 King H4 adding strain
to Black's position obviously there's
our old friend C5 but there's our new
friend the new past F Pawn which can
move to F5 essentially whenever white
ones and I think the game would be
decided if white could squeeze that pawn
through to F6 so there's the plan Simple
Plan of going Bishop E6 F5
then King F4 and King G5 and at that
point black is hanging by a thread and
black has to try to position the dark
squared Bishop so he can force the king
away but the moment you move away from
D4 C5 becomes a possibility so with 13
minutes left I'm just not sure if
Vincent has enough left in the tank to
hold this together
huh it's uh
it's very difficult for him I mean the
thing is he can't really do anything he
just has to pass
I mean because anything else if he tries
to get active tries to get some counter
play like you say C5 is going to come he
has to keep an eye on the B4 Pawn which
is still potentially weak
all he can do is just sit back and react
that's exactly right and he's got to
decide where he puts his Bishops too so
there is sort of one decision he's got
to make
eyes he's messed it up
yeah I mean I was wondering whether he
could just pass with a light Square
Bishop just go Bishop F7 Bishop E8 and
say you're welcome
do whatever you like
I may or may not be ready
I think when I get these types of
positions after six and a half hours of
Defending and Vincent has been basically
defending from the very start of this
game
at that point I it's not that I get
tilted I just say you know what I'm just
gonna go back and forth and I want to
bring it on already I already want to
find out if I'm going to if I'm gonna
draw this game or lose this game Vincent
is thinking more diligently he's trying
to find the best defensive construction
for all three of his pieces and I do not
envy him one bit
uh what is the best construction if I'm
gonna pin you down and uh there we see
Vincent weight with the bishop
I I don't blame him I too would make
that move
yeah stopping Bishop E6 unfortunately
there's Bishop CA there's even Bishop to
H7
followed by F5 and the bishop could
slide back to G6 and I think in this
version a trait of light squared Bishops
is going to be decisive
oh man oh man
and I have a question for you I'm going
to put you on the spot how quickly would
you advance the F Pawn
without delay I would play Bishop H7 F5
because it's not like if you wait black
can make a mistake Vincent is just going
Bishop E8 Bishop F7 so white really has
only one approach to this position you
just have to decide whether you're going
Bishop C8 or Bishop page seven Lavon
didn't take long Bishop H7 on the board
he smells blood
he's going for it now the reason I ask
this is because there's a big debate uh
on the chess Champions Testo I mean
David is the more patient character and
you will see him wait and he would find
all the means possible before he commits
to playing F5
like he said he thrives in playing games
that are over 100 moves and this could
be one of them actually
this would be such an impressive game
for Lavon because again he's squeezed
this Advantage for 45 moves first it was
a middle game Edge then they got into an
end game where he had a positional
Advantage he trans transformed that into
an extra Pawn we thought the plaque had
an impervious Fortress five moves ago
but how things change in chess how
quickly do the tables turn in these
games just amazing
yeah and it just goes to show you've got
to persevere and also hats off to Levon
because we kind of didn't follow his
game that much but we did see that he
had a very promising position I mean
just looked like everything had worked
like a dream for him and then we came
back and it wasn't so easy I mean still
a lot of fight left in the position and
then like you say it must have been a
draw at some point and he didn't let any
of the emotions guide him he didn't let
he wasn't frustrated at all instead he
just continued prodding at Vincent until
he cracked and then now we have that
winning position and I I'm like you I
really like the idea of just simply
pushing the F on advancing the pieces
forward
it looks great and uh five and Bishop G6
yeah
that gets my vote all the time
and the h-man's not going anywhere too
that hurts black is no way to create
counter play here
he has to sit around and wait
I mean how are you
you can't really wait with anything
because you kind of want the bishop on
D4 just to keep an eye on C5
so you don't want to touch that you also
want her on the long diagonal
um the light Square Bishop is the only
piece I mean it's a useless there isn't
an idea I have but it's really bad it
just put the bishop back on E8 and wait
for F5 I know what you're thinking and
what you're cooking up here
on the board is Bishop A4
but unfortunately
there are multiple F6 in your face this
move is just you bang this out you look
at your opponent like who's the boss
here
I wasn't gonna do it immediately because
it didn't work but you know have it up
you know what you can do play this
yeah
but there's 92 .92
um but yeah we
we need some help right
look at this position
I love these types of constructions
where the bishop this is one of the
beautiful things about Chess that just
the concept that your own Pawn a member
of your own team can be the reason that
you lose the game it's so unique for
this to be the case in I think Sports
and games for one of your own pieces or
things to impede
your own position
yeah I've never really thought about
that but you're right
um is that any possible Sports
thinking of parallel well there's the
own goal in soccer right but but own
goals are largely coincidental whereas
situations where you use your opponent's
pieces to your advantage are often part
of a deliberate strategy
yeah the only thing that I can think of
is um one of these martial arts I can't
remember the exact name of it where you
use your opponent's strength against
them and
and somehow that's a disadvantage but
yeah but in terms of team sports no I
don't
know
I'd be interested to see if in Chinese
chess or in shogi go if you have similar
I'm sure you have parallels or you have
similar situations
uh but but just there's so many elements
of beauty and chess that you can
appreciate even if you're just a
beginner right you can understand the
concept of a pawn blocking in your own
bishop and
you know that that's what makes chess
such a fun game for anyone whether
you've been playing for a day or a
decade
yeah and I was also just thinking on
update that I mean it's kind of unique
that you have to keep the pieces that on
are on the board in play because it you
know in other sports you know if
something is not working your way you
just go bye bye you're not needed well
done and then you'd move it off the
board I mean you take it away
I mean that's how it would work and in
chess you're like no you're saddled with
that bad piece for life oh well I'm
being dramatic of course
imagine yeah well imagine how much chess
would change if one time per game you
had the ability to remove any one of
your pawns from the board let's just say
pawns no pieces that would
I mean it wouldn't just change the game
a little bit any situation whether you
have a rook on H1 and there's a Pawn on
H2 and there's a lot of lines like that
the dragon would be refuted immediately
because you would just take your H Pawn
off the board and there would be mate so
yeah it would make it's crazy
how much these small things change the
game
maybe we've hit on a new variant I think
someone needs to needs to put this one
into action and what can we call it
though
um I'm very bad with titles there we go
me too
I'm notoriously bad with inventing names
for Stuff
and
I don't know self-capture chest that
sounds terrible
and meanwhile uh lavona is in a good
mood and uh he has a reason to be
because not only is his doing well on
the board but he has history in fact
real good history in Vikings say he's a
four-time winner in 2007 the very first
time he won it he went undefeated with
an incredible four wins and in 2014 his
last tournament Victory he had uh gosh
get this a performance rating of 29 11.
that is epic for 2014 that is just
amazing and uh how much the game has
changed since 2007 that was only two
years after Gary Kasparov retired from
the game I'd like to check if Lavon
participated in vikon Zay with Kasparov
that would be an interesting thing to
check but the fact remains 2007 was a
completely different era in chess Lavon
has adapted himself successfully to each
new major sea change in the way the
chess is perceived is openings have
modernized through the years and the
fact that he's won wikons a four years
seven years apart and continues to be in
contention says volumes about his status
as a chess player
yeah and uh he played top board from the
American team and he he's a great great
player
and uh he has an interesting backstory
you know he Armenian
came from poverty actually I mean he
told a very moving story about how when
he played in certain tournaments and
Junior Championships um they didn't have
enough money for his mother to stay in
the hotel so she had to stay on the bus
that transported them there and and
thing actually owes a lot to his parents
and I know that he transferred to
Germany and he went back to Armenia and
uh after that Armenian Federation told
him no we think you're too old we think
that you don't want to support her
anymore therefore
you know you should just do something
else Levon was like no I believe in
myself and that's how he transferred
over to America and I think lives in
Saint Louis
he lives in St Louis
yeah
together with a couple other jams
yes yes everyone lives in San Luis I
mean it's becoming Grand Master Central
is there more Grand Masters in St Louis
um in other cities Fabiano caruana
Lanier Dominguez I'm pretty sure
um Eric Rosen of course not a GM but you
know well we'll put him in the honorary
society and I think that's just the tip
of the iceberg there is varicobian
who lives in St Louis as far as I know
and I'm sure that there's probably two
or three others that I'm not thinking of
so right I think it is the most oh Ray
Robinson you're absolutely right it is
the most jams per capita Lazar of brazon
you know everybody who goes to Webster
and everybody who goes to Slough I mean
there's definitely over probably over 15
GMS like Huang Lim
it's not just the most jams per capita
and like a US city it is blows all other
competition out by a country mile
no wow
that's uh incredible but actually this
is kind of a very fertile ground for
people just to get better just to I'm a
big believer in the hive mind of people
coming together studying I feel a chess
should be studied amongst friends and
also played amongst friends and that's
how the whole group gets better I'm
really anti this our whole idea of
you have lone wolves just stuttering by
themselves maybe with one coach because
quite frankly maybe one person can do it
but I think it sets a poor president
most people can't most people are social
animals they need that connection
um no it's just more fun that way
it is and you know thinking about the
idea that it takes a village to
piggyback off of your point about
lavon's life story I I read about half
of uh his his mom seta wrote an autobio
well not an autobiography biography of
her son and you know his trials and
tribulations on his way to the top it's
absolutely fascinating and Vincent kymer
levonne aronian might seem to have
completely different stories but both of
them had a mentor a kind of father
figure that propelled them through the
early stages of their chess career in
levonne aronian's case it was a less
well-known name melik katyon who is now
a grand master he lives in Los Angeles I
know him very very well he coaches
full-time he was lavon's essentially
live-in coach for many years to teaching
him so many of the skills that make
Lebon who he is today for Vincent kymer
that figure was none other than Peter
leiko who I still think who I think is
still his coach and his second lekko
lecco's imprints are so evident in
kymer's play and I mean that in the best
possible way there's resilience the
positional wisdom that he displays Which
is far beyond his years even at age 12
or 13 before kymer became a GM he won
some positional masterpieces that you
think would come more likely from a 72
year old rather than a 12 year old and
yet Peter leco has done a phenomenal job
as Vincent sits on 2700 and his
brightest days are definitely still
ahead only 18. I only 18 and I
definitely can see uh Peter leco's
imprint and his and Vincent's opening
repertoire I remember having a
conversation with Peter lecco on a bus
and he was telling me about the
Hungarian school of thought which is
very much that you start the opening
correctly and if you start the opening
correctly and it Fizzles out into a
drawer what can you do you know you
played perfectly but if you if one side
plays in perfectly it is game on
regardless if that opponent is 2200 or
2700 So I found that quite amusing
Hungarian school of thought
very interesting I I just love hearing
about Legacy and imprints and it's so
fascinating when you look at someone's
chess games too
to see the the mesh between their own
style and their own Tendencies which
everybody has and those of someone's
most significant Mentor or coach every
player has that for Carlson it was
Seaman Augustine uh former Norwegian
Champion uh and region number one also a
professional soccer player uh in his
youth fascinating story and Seaman also
instilled in Magnus a lot of the skills
that we take for granted in him today
whoever you turned to there was a mentor
there was somebody who imbued the player
with a lot of the foundation that
propelled them to Greatness
yeah the only person who I can think
who's playing now is Wesley to me he's a
bit mysterious because did he have a
mentor growing up I don't know so much
of his backstory I just don't either
actually
I I just I just I mean he's given
interviews where he said that you know
he doesn't work with too many people and
and as as a child of course everyone
knows what happened in his parents left
for I think Canada was it the U.S and
they left him behind and he was staying
rent free in the Filipino chess
federations flat so I mean then again
you know he was supported and okay well
we have seen both players shuffling
their pieces around and is it time for
Action fine F5 I mean we're not that
patient here in in this
hour number seven
okay so F5 I think it's over another the
reason Lavon put his skin on H3
specifically very clinical he wants to
be able to play King H4 right you don't
want to play it before Bishop G6 because
what's the point you want to go F5
Bishop G6 and then King H4 win the pawn
I I don't see a single wave for Vincent
to hold this together perhaps the only
chance is to play Bishop F6 try to hold
White's King at Bay but Bishop to G6
still seems to force the trade of
Bishops or Force black to give away
another Pawn just watch out for Bishop
A4 as you said if this could come at a
very inconvenient moment see it's easy
to blunder
wait wait one second so if Bishop F6 I
like that move
and uh you go Bishop G6 I mean
afterwards you need to create two
weaknesses and uh a sec or another past
Pawn would be good is it possible to no
92 is always in the air
yeah I was thinking try to get this
Knight somewhere you know remote and the
thing is here already Bishop A4 actually
works
but
it's probably not winning but at least
at least a draw the thing is who's gonna
go Knight H5 lavon's Gonna Keep His
night in the vicinity of the center and
at this point that city is threatening
to take into take and as we've already
discussed the same colored Bishop end
game is winning for white because of the
prospect of breaking through with C5
White's just gonna maneuver the King
around and play C5 it's kind of yeah and
kind of I also wonder
point out that uh in this type of
position with a knight on e4 say you
just pass with the bishop
to D7 I don't know quite where to go
isn't C5 winning
oh great call DC D6 yeah that
circumvents all of the technical
is something happening with those post
bones because it's not over until it's
over okay so the king moves and light
takes and then of course C4 no
chance no
just don't go F6 because that would be
illegal but they're not coming back to
C3 to stop the pawn every time that
Knight makes its way back just in the
nick of time
yeah okay Bishop B2 by Vincent By the
way let's go back to the live board
how does that help
not Bishop G6 and just wins it's 56.
it's I mean maybe he's hoping to go
Bishop D7 after Bishop G6
and that becomes resignable like once
white wins the second Pawn on H5 it's
essentially over and he's played Bishop
D7
yeah King H4
that's goody goody goody
yeah black just cannot hold both of
these pawns at the same time you just
can't
uh and what about once you win the pawn
I mean
is there any slight chance
of
a miracle
well
yeah
I mean I mean how how does white win say
you just take the pawn and then
the black Bishop just kind of just keeps
dancing on that one diagonal which is
the only thing what I can do because you
simply cannot allow F6 so my inclination
would be to take on H5 walk the king
back patiently let's say to D3
and at the right moment push C5 and then
push D6 you can play C5 DC D6 okay but
Vincent
has gone Bishop C8
probably D6 already went oh so C5
already wins
but there's no need you can play Bishop
H7 oh and Bishop H7 King G6 I think is
even simpler
yeah is there any Bishop D7 giving a
check to EU oh look at this line okay
he's King G5
oh then King G6 and King G7 and I push
F6 I interpose with a check this wins on
the spot
it
yeah
well played
whatever brilliant what an end game by
Lavon
and to stop that chance
from nowhere I I mean it was just
magnificent
um
absolutely caught Vincent unawares there
and
it's just just shows the beauty of
grinding out those difficult end games
managing just to press those points put
your opponents under some form of
pressure I mean I find that this is
actually one of the most beautiful
things about Chess I have fine
appreciation for the blistering attacks
and the Mad combinations but this is
clever and I feel that you it takes a
certain level of Genius to play in this
kind of way because you have to think
about it both players are kind of only
making like oh well not both players one
player is only making slight
in imperfections slight errors and the
opponent has to play with such position
to
fine-tune that advantage and take the
point home
well Anatoly karpov carpav yes was
famous for annotating his games as wins
and not including a single question mark
in his opponent's play the implication
being that he's such a genius that his
opponent didn't make a single mistake
and still lost and when carpool was
asked about this so goes the
anecdote he responded I don't know where
my opponent went wrong essentially I
don't even know what makes me tick I
just won the game and this game kind of
reminds me of that he just squeezed and
squeezed and squeezed and I don't know
exactly where Vincent missed the
opportunity to maintain the Fortress but
This lends a lot of credence to Magnus
Carlson's now very famous words that
chess fortresses they basically don't
exist there's always a way to breach
them
yeah that's true and what I love most
about that quote is as soon as he said
it you know he found himself in all
manner of fortresses defending things
and everyone comes up to him and they're
like so do you believe in fortunes now
[Laughter]
okay so Bishop H7
I I like Bishop H7
and then I love this move of just going
King G5 King G6 with some kind of neat
triangulation of the king
that's the if Lavon does not play Bishop
H7 that's what he would miss because the
idea is painfully obvious
he has gone instead King G5 okay well
this is of course the alternate idea
that we've already discussed the
prospect of bringing the King around to
the center and then pushing C5 with the
remnant also perfectly sufficient
yeah
Bishop goes back to where it came from
and
now
wait a second can we forecast how we
think this might go so let's say King F3
let's play Devil's Advocate and see if
placas any free chance because the evil
bar is not it's not giving Plus 10.
it's only giving plus three so let's say
Bishop D7 back here here
I have a worry
and My worry is that if you play C5 at
the wrong moment black has this check on
A6
King has to move
and I don't know if this is as easily
winning as it appears Black's Bishops
suddenly get very active
yeah I'm shocked Levon didn't go Bishop
H7 that ended the game immediately
sloppy there
yeah well I I think he's found it now oh
good stuff
[Laughter]
it's coming and I agree with you I think
this one isn't so clear
um after all there's a very general
principle that when your material down
you trade
forms not pieces SO trading pawns would
in fact favor the defender
Bishop H7 yeah he's found it phenomenal
just phenomenal and uh-huh
Bishop E5 I mean what can he do Bishop
nothing
nothing just wait for the inevitable
he's probably gonna decide so he's
probably gonna go Bishop D7 but King G5
is what we already talked about the king
inches its way to G7 Paving the way for
the pawn forward and we're entering the
Magnus Carlson abdusator of type phase
where it's really he can resign here he
can resign in five moves and it really
depends on personal preference because
the result of the game is no longer in
question
mm-hmm yeah
yeah it's a sad thing when this happens
oh yeah because there's a sense of
inevitability and you and the plays can
also feel it and the spectators also
feel it um there's something really
funny about Chess because
um last month in December I I went for
the very first time to adjust chess
boxing match in London and one of the
strange things is that the audience I
would say some of them were chess
players majority of them weren't but
everyone seemed to instinctively feel
when a blunder had been made even though
they could barely understand the rules
of Chess and if you could see everyone
oh my God and that was before the
announcers has said it's a blunder and
that was
quite something actually and I get the
same feeling here you know everyone can
sense what is happening everyone
understands the script that's been
written
yeah that's nothing to be done and uh
there we see Vincent
looking at the board he knows Lavon
knows
everybody the one has found the correct
plan
yeah yeah
despondent expression on Vincent's face
there and what you say Bears out with my
experience Bishop F6
is on the board I think Knight takes F6
and King F4
is going to
elicit resignation but at the risk of
sounding like a you know hippie from 60
San Francisco you can really feel the
energy shift when the result is no
longer in question there's a relaxation
that happens with one player and just a
total dejection that happens with the
player who's losing and who knows what
the result is going to be Lavon just
fully relaxed and he doesn't even take
he goes Bishop to G8 Exquisite technique
as he swings the bishop back toward E6 I
think now we're gonna see resignation
yeah yeah
definitely and there you go there we
have a result
I know it's our third decisive Victor
well decisive game of the rounds
uh and there we see the players
analyzing and we see Lavon
I think commenting on how he let his
Advantage slip under a smile from
Vincent
incredible just an Exquisite technical
display we have all of our results from
today this was the final game this round
lasted six hours in 17 minutes of
Amazing gameplay as we review
the results from today Levon aronian
live update there as he wins his game
three decisive games but the game of the
day I don't think there's any debate
about this Yogi will we debate Society
debates everything this is the one
remaining uncontroversial thing Agnes
Carlson losing is the result of the day
and there we see the standings he is
languishing in 10th Place the world
champion on two points out of five and
that's crazy results seemed absolutely
unheard of at the start of Tata steel
chess and now we can see that anything
is possible and tomorrow we'll have to
find out whether the world champion can
make a comeback and that we see the big
parent pairings and Wesley so against
Vincent kaima dingleren will face off
against Levon aronian
and uh Anish giri now has to has to run
the gauntlet of playing Arjun erag icy
who is in he's been phenomenal with his
tactics and with his calculation
abilities and the tournament leader
nordebec Abdul sotorov he will face off
against his rival pragnananda
and uh what do you think about the
matchup Jordan van Forest against Magnus
Carlson I mean I I'm first of all I'm
looking at Notre back against prognan
and I'm thinking this is fascinating
because Prague is in phenomenal form I
mean he was pushing on each Gary there
at the end he just seems so confident
he's got three points out of five after
a win against England with black he
hasn't lost a game
and he has an incredibly tall task of
facing a notabec who has just defeated
Magnus with black his reward is to get
the white pieces this is a game Notre
back is going to try to win really to
pull away from the rest of the field if
Anish giri doesn't keep Pace this could
turn into a blowout in the first half of
the tournament but Ben Forrest he's got
a tall task facing Magnus a furious in
fact it's Carlson a Magnus Carlson that
is near the bottom of the tournament
standings those two words those two
expression Magnus and bottom of the
tournament standings you don't hear at
all you don't hear them in the same
paragraph the same universe and one of
the sub story lines report from matsudu
and Fabiana who cash round out our
pairings for tomorrow one of our story
lines will be how Magnus gets back on
his feet can he not only finish on the
top of the tournament standings but this
reminds me of Fabiano caruano's
performance at the 2021 U.S Championship
he lost I think three games in a row and
yeah he was losing to you know semi
retire players and then he got up on his
feet he came back and he got he tied for
a second he almost won the tournament so
it is still possible for Magnus to
launch a comeback and win this event can
the world champion demonstrate that
Verve and that resilience which has
accompanied him for his entire chess
career what do you think yovial pass it
back to you for your final thoughts yeah
yeah
I think he's the king of comebacks I
mean we've seen him do this especially
in Rapid chess and Bliss chest time and
time again he gets knocked down but he
gets back up again and he doesn't let
one defeat or two in this case defeat
him so I I think he will be angry we'll
see him motivated we'll see a new kind
of Magnus appear to the board and I'm
looking forward to this actually I think
it's going to be a very dangerous game
for Jordan van Forrest it is indeed we
will watch Magnus we will watch the
tournament leader Notre back as he tries
to cement his position in the tournament
standings but all of that folks will be
coming your way tomorrow Friday at 5 00
a.m Pacific 8 A.M Eastern 2 p.m Central
European Time same start time as today
bright and early in the states iwaka I
could not have asked for a better first
day in terms of the games I could not
have asked for a better co-commentator
this was such a pleasure so thank you to
you for uh for bringing the energy all
six hours this time went by so so
quickly
yeah it did it was a fantastic day of
Chess and the feeling is mutual Daniel
thank you well folks we will see you
tomorrow at 8am this was round five of
the Tata steel chess tournament we would
like to thank everybody in the chat over
50 000 of you cheering on your favorite
players and our lovely wonderful
chess.com production team and our
producer holla for the Flawless work and
now from out of steel chess this is I am
Ivanka houska and GM Daniel nerdinski we
will see you tomorrow bright and early
round six of Tata Steel
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]